We bought all the chicken sandwiches
from every fast food
chain in the US and the UK
to compare the differences.
This is Food Wars.
At a UK McDonald's, chicken
sandwiches come in three sizes.
The mayo chicken, a McChicken
sandwich, and a McCrispy.
McDonald's in the US has four
chicken sandwich options.
The McChicken, the McCrispy,
the McCrispy deluxe,
and the McCrispy spicy deluxe.
The UK KFC options are a
regular chicken sandwich,
a Tower burger, which is the
same but with a hash brown
and some cheese, and a Stacker burger,
which is two chicken patties
with some cheese as well.
KFC options, we currently have two.
The Chicken Little - look at
this little guy, so little -
and the KFC chicken sandwich.
This is part of their Gourmet Kings range.
Whoops.
We have two types of chicken
sandwich at a UK Burger King,
the Chicken Royale or the
steakhouse crispy chicken.
Burger King in the US
also has two chicken sandwich options,
and they are as follows.
I am taking this off.
The Chicken Junior, this guy.
I mean, this looks
exactly like a McChicken.
And the original chicken sandwich,
the only chicken sandwich
we're going to see today
that is shaped like a smartphone.
Popeyes chicken sandwiches in the UK
only come in one size, the
classic chicken sandwich.
Popeyes in the US also has
but one chicken sandwich.
Shake Shack in the UK only has
one size of chicken burger,
the Chicken Shack.
Shake Shack, we haven't done
anything with Shake Shack
in years it feels like, but they're back.
They got a chicken sandwich.
Just on looks, whoa, this
looks ridiculously good.
Jollibee's chicken burgers
come in two sizes in the UK
as a standard or as a double.
Jollibee. I love Jollibee,
and their chicken
sandwiches are very good.
We have their regular chicken
sandwich and the spicy.
Wendy's in the US went all
in on chicken sandwiches.
As you can see, there are nine varieties.
Two, four, six, eight, yeah.
Wendy's only has one size of
chicken sandwich in the UK.
OK, I'm sorry, what sandwich is it again?
And the crispy chicken
sandwich, chicken BLT.
OK, OK, OK, Asiago club,
spicy chicken sandwich.
Wendy's, all right, we get it.
BLT or club?
Spicy ghost pepper.
Bacon. Pretzel. Pub.
Wendy's spicy pretzel.
Then we've got some options
that you won't find in the US.
Two things from a chain called Morley's,
a strip burger and a fillet burger,
and one thing from Nando's,
the grilled chicken burger.
Arby's, which is only available in the US,
has three chicken sandwiches,
starting over here.
They have their crispy chicken sandwich,
they have their bacon Swiss
crispy chicken sandwich,
and they got the Buffalo chicken sandwich.
Chick-fil-A, of course, the original.
You can also get the same
sandwich spicy version.
Raising Cane's, they have, of course,
one chicken sandwich option
on the menu. This is that.
Depending where you are
in the United States,
these are the five
Carl's Jr.-slash-Hardee's
chicken sandwiches.
So here are almost all
of the chicken burgers
you'll find in the UK arranged by price.
The cheapest at this end is
the McDonald's mayo chicken
at just 1 pound 19.
The most expensive is the
Shake Shack Chicken Shack,
coming in at 9 pounds and 35 pence.
For the price of one
Shake Shack Chicken Shack,
you could buy 7.8
McDonald's mayo chickens.
In general, I think it seems like the size
is tracking with the price.
So they do seem a little
bit smaller down this end
and a little bit bigger down this end,
with a couple of exceptions.
I do think the Nando's one
looks a little bit small.
Even the Chicken Shack
does look a bit small,
and that's very expensive.
OK, prices in the US
starting from least expensive
to most expensive.
The least expensive
sandwich, to no surprise,
is the KFC Chicken Little,
which comes in at $2.39.
But let's be honest, this
isn't actually a full sandwich.
I mean, it's almost like a little slider.
The most expensive is the
Carl's Jr. bacon Swiss
chicken sandwich, coming in,
just the sandwich, $11.49.
I think it's interesting that
McDonald's takes up this part.
Wendy's is almost all exactly right here.
Arby's is almost exactly right over here.
I do enjoy Raising Cane's,
but this sandwich should not
be in this percentage of price.
First of all, it's
chicken tender sandwiches.
It's not even like a full chicken patty.
I mean, the Jollibee spicy and regular are
in the lower third.
This is a great sandwich.
Popeyes is here, KFC is right here.
Popeyes and KFC positioned
almost right next to each other, price.
A lot of people, myself included,
would say these might be
the best fast food crispy
chicken sandwiches on the market,
and they're down here, man.
They're like hovering
around McChicken prices.
Here are all the UK chicken
sandwiches ordered by weight.
The lightest option is the
mayo chicken at 120 grams,
and the heaviest is the
KFC Zinger Stacker burger
at 325 grams.
Key takeaways there, a few
of them really dropped down.
For example, the Shake Shack Burger.
The Nando's burger has really plummeted
in terms of price versus weight.
Not a lot of movement at
the bottom end of the table,
which is interesting.
I think even just
visually, like the colors
are quite interesting.
Down the mayo chicken end, the
buns are kind of very dull,
quite a matte finish.
Then the sesame seeds
kind of start to disappear
the higher up you go,
and you head more towards
the kind of brioche bun,
which just looks a little
bit fancier and shinier.
OK, now this is all the
US sandwiches by weight.
Least weight down here,
most weight down there.
OK, once again, the Chicken Little
and the Wendy's crispy
chicken is at the very end
of the smallest. And all the
way down here at the end,
the Wendy's classic Pretzel
Bacon Pub at a hefty
284 grams on this one. Heavy sandwich.
I don't know what you want to
do with this information really.
The one thing I will notice
is the most expensive one,
or the one of the most expensive ones,
is the weight right in the middle.
So certainly not charging by volume.
Shame on you, Carl's Jr.
Popeyes, right?
Popeyes was over here.
Move this way all the way up.
So less in price, more in weight.
Let's go.
And here are all the chicken sandwiches
arranged in order of price by weight.
So the best value in
terms of price by weight
is the McDonald's mayo chicken.
Per 100 grams of burger,
that will cost you just 99 pence.
The most expensive by weight
is the Shake Shack Chicken
Shack. Per 100 grams of burger,
that one will cost you 4 pounds 25.
The Shake Shack burger
is 329% more expensive
than the mayo chicken.
I guess ultimately it comes
down to personal preference
as to whether you want
to pay a little bit more
for what you would hope
to be higher quality
or if you kind of just
want value for money
and quantity over quality.
I think when it comes to fast food,
I kind of just want value for money.
I just want to leave feeling
satisfied with my food
for as little price as possible.
I'm kind of surprised how
low down in the value scale
the Chicken Royale from Burger King
and the standard fillet
burger from KFC ended up.
You're really not getting
that much value for money
when compared to some of these options,
and I don't think the quality
of either of those chains
is necessarily high enough
to justify that price point.
For example, I think the
Jollibee double chicken sandwich,
as well as the Zinger Stacker burger,
you're getting a lot of
food for your money there.
And honestly, these are
really tasty burgers.
So the quality is good, price is good.
I think these ones are what I
would lean towards in general
if I were to order.
This is the order from
best value to worst value.
Coming in at No. 1 ...
... is a Wendy's BLT.
Look at this little guy.
What a deal.
I love the fact that both the Popeyes
and the KFC chicken sandwiches
are arguably the best deal
you can get in the US.
Look at this.
If you're going per 100
grams, the Chicken Little
isn't as good of a deal as
a full chicken sandwich.
I love it.
Glad to see the pretzel
buns are down here.
Because these were the heaviest.
But also comparing it with the price,
you're getting a pretty good deal.
I think from here on, it's like, yeah, OK.
Back here, Jollibee spicy chicken.
Glad to see it.
Great deal.
McChicken's over here, huh?
Raising Cane's.
All right.
I was a little tough on
Raising Cane's before.
Everyone's favorite, Chick-fil-A.
Chick-fil-A here and here.
Really?
This is your favorite restaurant.
We're closed on Sundays for this?
Give me a break.
Shake Shack's over here.
I don't know. I was enticed by its size,
but after running the numbers,
it's not that good of a deal.
Shame on you, Shake Shack.
McDonald's. Even McDonald's isn't safe.
Their McCrispy, all the
way over here for this one?
That's surprising and annoying.
Look at this. Look at this.
Every Carl's Jr., most expensive, right?
They weren't the heaviest. Worst value.
The Carl's Jr. hand-breaded.
Not even the ones with
all the fun stuff on it.
Just a regular hand-breaded sandwich.
Here you go.
It was $10.99 and it weighed 221 grams.
So it's $4.97 per 100 grams.
I know it's a lot of data to throw at you.
Let me just give you the
TL;DR. Too expensive.
So here are all the UK
standard chicken sandwiches.
I'm going to taste them all back to back
and provide you with
my definitive ranking.
Here are the standard chicken sandwiches
at several US fast food chains.
I'm going to try and rank them right now.
McDonald's McCrispy.
I'll give this one a try.
They've gone really heavy on the mayo.
The bun is quite fancy.
It's fancier than you'd normally find
on a McDonald's burger.
It's kind of like a pretzel bun effect.
Nice shiny, decent texture on it.
Not too doughy.
Chicken patty, maybe a little bit thin.
It's a good place to start,
because I think there is room
for improvement there, but
it could be a lot worse.
So starting with down
here, the chicken classic.
I mean, I feel like I'm a bit biased,
because I've been eating these
as long as I can remember.
I'll put it here for now.
I feel like, I mean,
it's good for its value,
but I don't know, it's a little basic.
Now, I don't think I've
had this one before,
the Burger King one.
Similar, I think I like that better.
Yeah, BK.
All right.
Next up we've got the KFC fillet burger.
By the looks of things,
also just mayo and lettuce and chicken.
Overall, it's just lacking
a little bit of something.
It's quite bland.
I think so far, whether it's the chicken,
the breading, or the mayo,
not quite as flavorful as the McCrispy.
So slightly below it.
Come on.
Popeyes chicken sandwiches
has been sitting for a while.
This is the one that everyone
lost their minds about
on the internet.
Everything I'm looking for. Still crispy,
amazing Popeyes flavor.
Love the bun.
Little bit of mayo or sauce on there.
Not too overpowering.
Wow, that's great.
That'll stay in this region.
Big competitor though, KFC.
Ooh, and this one, this
is still really crispy.
All right.
You hear that crunch?
Yeah.
Going in for another bite.
The Burger King Chicken Royale.
I'm tempted to dock points
just because of how
stupid this thing looks.
I've never understood
why they made it long.
I think the ratio is slightly off.
The bun is obviously a long
bun, but it's also quite thick.
So, if you can see that,
you're getting quite a lot
of bread-to-meat ratio.
Yeah, that's the worst one so far.
Wendy's we saw, we'll see later,
but Wendy's had a hundred
freaking sandwiches.
Dry, barely seasoned.
No, that's the worst one.
Was it cheese on this?
No, not very good.
Popeyes chicken sandwich.
Popeyes is a relatively
recent addition to the UK.
We didn't have this until
maybe a year or two ago,
and I will say so far,
people seem to be liking it.
On this one, you get
the chicken, the mayo,
and instead of the
lettuce, you get pickles,
which I think is more
of an American thing,
and one that I enjoy,
because I love pickles.
This is good.
I think we have a leader so far.
The chicken I would say
is thicker and crispier
than any of the three I've tried so far.
Get little, like, crunchy
bits that flake off the edge.
So yeah, I think my
favorite so far, Popeyes.
Arby's, I mean, they got the meats,
and I guess chicken's a meat,
but I don't think about getting
chicken when I go to Arby's.
It's roast beef, right?
No.
Flavorless.
Shake Shack Chicken Shack is up next.
This is the most expensive
of any of the burgers we've tried today.
It looks pretty fancy.
The bun is that classic Shake Shack bun.
I think it's a potato roll.
We have chicken, mayo, and lettuce.
No pickles in this one.
I was wrong.
There are pickles in this one.
The breading on the chicken,
it looked like it was going to be tasty,
but in actuality doesn't
have that much flavor.
And if you actually look at the chicken,
it's quite a thick piece of chicken,
but it's very dry and quite tough.
I think it's probably
worse than the McSpicy.
So I'll tuck it in there.
Here we go.
Let's get everyone
fighting in the comments
with Chick-fil-A.
Never been a Chick-fil-A fan,
and I hope everyone watching
can see what varieties
of chicken sandwiches
you can get at any fast food chain.
Why are you picking this?
What are you doing?
What are you guys doing?
I've never really cared for Chick-fil-A.
It's just the epitome of fine.
I mean this is looking
closer to these ones
than it is to these over here.
Looks really dry.
Got to get the sauce,
got to put sauce on it.
So I got Chick-fil-A sauce.
But I mean the fact that it's like, no,
you have to put sauce on it to enjoy it.
Well, then put the sauce on it.
Why do I got to do it?
And I do really like
the Chick-fil-A sauce.
It's a very good sauce.
I will say what this has
going for it other than these
is that its simplicity makes
it, to me, a little better,
because it's not bogged down
with a lot of, like, soggy
vegetables or sauce or whatever.
When you add in this instance
the Chick-fil-A sauce,
it is better.
So for that, I'm going to put
it, let me put it down here.
It's definitely not as
good as a McChicken.
I just don't see what the big deal is.
I don't.
And everyone's going to flood my comments
with the specialty orders I
have to get with the sauces
and then, no. This is the
sandwiches on the menu.
I got it.
I tasted it. Boring and bland.
Up next we got Jollibee, their
classic chicken sandwich.
Also a relatively new addition to the UK.
Let's give it a try.
Wow.
I think it's the crispiest
chicken we've had so far.
I think it's even crispier
than the Popeyes one.
Could maybe benefit from
a little bit more mayo.
It's just slightly dry is
my main criticism so far.
There's not much to
separate this from Popeyes.
But I think I slightly
prefer the taste of Popeyes,
so I'll tuck it in there.
Yo, Raising Cane's, though.
Chicken tender sandwiches.
Someone's head chef is a 12-year-old boy.
Not a bad idea. Just
stick tenders in a bun,
throw some sauce on here, let's go.
This is good.
Here's why this is smart.
With the tenders, there's
more surface space,
so the crispy-skin-to-chicken ratio
leans more towards the crispy chicken
or the crispy skin,
which just gives it a lot more flavor.
I really like Raising Cane's.
I know I was disappointed when
we put it in the value matrix
that Harry came up with.
But, you don't want to discount taste,
is a very tasty chicken sandwich.
Oh, Raising Cane's,
another one that's famous
for having this Cane sauce
you're supposed to dip it in,
and I didn't even put any
on here. It's still good.
So Chick-fil-A, get out of
here with your extra sauce.
Then we're onto the Wendy's
classic chicken sandwich.
Well, it looks like quite a dry
bun, chicken patty, lettuce,
tomato, and pickles.
Just visually, I had
quite low expectations,
but that's a pretty tasty sandwich.
Not bad.
I'm going to put it
slightly below the McCrispy.
All right, last two.
Shake Shack is great.
I don't usually go there that often,
because I always feel it's a little more
on the expensive side.
And aesthetics alone,
this looks like it would've
been maybe the best one.
It looks like a big piece of chicken.
Yeah, good amount of sauce.
I like the bun.
This looks like a big
chicken sandwich, right?
This is really good.
Yeah.
The flavor of that chicken
is Popeyes- and KFC-level.
I mean, Cane's is cool.
Everything this way has more
of a generic fried chicken flavor,
but from here on, the flavors
are getting more specific,
which I like.
And Shake Shack's, wow.
Then we've got two UK
exclusives to rank as well.
I'm going to start with
the Morley's fillet burger.
This kind of looks like the
platonic ideal chicken burger
that you might find.
Just the lettuce, quite a lot of mayo.
Chicken looks good.
Not the thickest piece of chicken,
but looks pretty well seasoned.
The chicken, I would describe
the texture as leathery.
Quality-wise, you can kind of
tell that the chicken in here
is maybe not quite as good
as some of the other ones.
I think it's down here actually.
Not as bad as the long chicken.
And last, what we've determined
arguably the worst value
for your money,
Carl's Jr. Oh man.
But they're really emphasizing
that this is a hand-breaded.
They're doing it by hand back there.
Let's see how it tastes.
Hello.
This is actually pretty good.
Oh man, I've been dogging
on Carl's Jr. all day.
OK.
All right.
Raising Cane's is better
than this one, but not,
I mean, it's close.
They both have a unique flavor.
Cane's overall has a
better-lasting flavor.
They don't taste exactly
the same, but Carl's Jr.,
your hand-breaded chicken
sandwich is actually pretty good.
Then our final option is the
Nando's grilled chicken burger.
It's some of their
signature grilled chicken
with your chosen spice level.
Leon chose the spiciest one for me.
Thank you.
And it's served on these kind of,
I think it's a Portuguese roll,
which have quite a firm texture to them.
I will say, you can taste
the quality of the chicken
with this one. The ratio is slightly off.
I've always thought this
bun is, like, quite a lot
for the rest of the ingredients.
It's good, but where does it rank?
I think this may upset people,
but I'm actually going to put
it slightly below the McCrispy.
And that is my ranking.
Coming in dead last,
Burger King Chicken Royale.
And I think my favorite is
the Popeyes chicken sandwich.
Going down the ranking from least to best,
says me, in last place we
have, was this Wendy's?
Yeah.
But, of course, the top
two, Popeyes and KFC.
And I want to say, at any given day,
it could be Popeyes one, KFC two.
Those guys are neck and neck,
depending on the KFC
and Popeyes you go to.
Oh my gosh, I almost forgot Jollibee.
This is the standard Jollibee sandwich.
I'll put that between the
McChicken and the Chick-fil-A.
Yeah, not impressed.
It's a lot of chicken I can keep track of.
Now I'm going to talk
about all the US sandwiches
you cannot get in the UK.
Here are all the chicken
sandwiches from the UK
that you won't find in the US,
only we call them chicken burgers.
Firstly, it's the return
of the value king,
it's the mayo chicken.
This is as simple, cheap,
and cheerful as it gets.
It's a slightly oddly shaped,
usually square chicken patty
with some mayo and some lettuce on a bun.
And for a few extra pounds,
you can also add bacon
and have a bacon mayo chicken.
Then we have a linguistic
difference. In the UK,
our spicy version of the chicken sandwich
is called a McSpicy.
You guys call yours a Spicy McCrispy,
which to me seems like an
unnecessary amount of words.
Whatever.
Yarrr.
Then we're onto KFC. In the UK,
instead of having a
spicy chicken sandwich,
we have a Zinger burger.
It's basically the same thing, same patty,
but the breading is a bit more spicy.
I quite like this.
I think generally speaking,
I'll opt for a Zinger burger
over just the classic fillet burger.
Also, do Americans find it weird
that we pronounce it "FILL-it"
burger and not "fill-LAY"?
Because I feel like you
guys will find that weird.
Unless you're talking
about the Filet-O-Fish
from McDonald's, in which
case we say "fill-LAY."
Figure it out.
Our next exclusive from KFC
in the UK is the Tower burger.
So this is the chicken, but
then they add some cheese to it
and a hash brown.
We've also gone for the
Zinger Tower burger here,
which means that you get
this spicy salsa-y sauce
on top as well.
And then we have the exclusive
Zinger Stacker burger.
Now this is our largest
burger that you can find
on a KFC UK menu, and it's,
if I can separate them,
which apparently I can't,
it's just peeled instead.
It's two chicken patties
with cheese between,
and on top, lettuce, spicy mayo,
and some more spicy sauce on top as well.
While we're talking about the KFC ones,
you'll note that on the UK
menu, they're all named a burger
rather than a sandwich.
It's hard to explain exactly
where the linguistic
difference comes from.
I think a lot of it comes
to do with the bread
that your sandwich comes in.
I think generally speaking,
if you have a round bun,
particularly with sesame
seeds on it, in the UK,
what's inside it is just
going to be called a burger.
We actually have quite
a few chicken exclusives
on a UK Burger King menu.
We'll start with this one,
which is the steakhouse crispy chicken.
This is part of their Gourmet Kings menu.
That's how I describe myself.
There's a tomatoey sauce on the bottom,
a crispy chicken patty,
big slice of cheese,
bacon, and then what looks
to be some rocket on top.
For the American audience,
we call arugula rocket.
I've not had this one before.
It was quite expensive.
I think it's got gourmet in the name,
and I think they're using that
to put this at quite a high price point.
It's not bad.
I do think to get this as part of a meal,
you're pushing 10 pounds in the UK.
And I feel like once you've
hit that price point,
just go somewhere else.
Just go to a restaurant, because
you'll get better quality,
fresher food for probably the
same, if not even less, money.
There's a linguistic
difference to point out,
which is that in the UK,
we call our weird long
Burger King chicken burger
a Chicken Royale.
In the UK, we can also
get our Chicken Royale
with bacon and cheese,
or we can get a Californian
barbecue Royale.
So that is the standard
Royale with the chicken,
the lettuce, and the mayo,
but also quite a lot of barbecue sauce,
and also some tomato on there.
Surprisingly, we actually
have a couple of Popeyes
exclusive sandwiches that
you don't have in the US.
Here we have the deluxe chicken sandwich
and the spicy deluxe chicken sandwich.
Now, while a regular Popeye
sandwich is just sauce, chicken,
and pickles, these ones have
sauce, chicken, pickles,
but also lettuce and cheese.
With the standard one, the sauce is mayo,
and on the spicy one,
it's actually the sauce
that changes rather than the chicken,
this one having a spicy mayo instead.
I don't know if adding
a little bit of lettuce
and cheese to something is
enough to qualify it as deluxe.
I think if you're
calling something deluxe,
I'm going to need a little
bit more than that, guys,
but I'll give it a try.
You know what, I'm going to say it.
I think the deluxe sandwiches are worse
than the originals from Popeyes.
I think for the couple of extra pounds
that it's costing you to
add a little bit of cheese
and lettuce to your sandwich,
you're better off without it, honestly.
The next exclusive is actually
a bit surprising to me.
It's this one from Jollibee,
the double chicken sandwich.
It's surprising in the sense
that the UK is the country
of excess here for once.
We're the ones with the
much larger portion.
This is a hefty, hefty sandwich.
We have one exclusive chicken
sandwich from the UK Wendy's,
which is the avocado chicken club.
So you get the chicken patty
with some cheese on top,
and then you have some
mashed avocado, bacon,
lettuce, and tomato.
Not to be outdone, the UK also has
quite a few chicken chains
that you won't find in the US.
And interestingly, our
chicken sandwich culture
is quite different to yours.
Now, in terms of chains,
Nando's is obviously a
pretty iconic chicken joint
over here in the UK.
Now, while you can find some
of these on the East Coast
of the US, over here, they're
in pretty much every city
and town and are kind of
like a foundational part
of the UK culture at this point.
We're now so obsessed
with peri-peri as a flavor
that almost every restaurant
that sells chicken
will have a peri-peri option.
And you've seen lots of other
chains trying to spring up
to capitalize on the popularity,
like Roosters and Pepe's.
Now we can't talk about
British chicken sandwiches
without talking about chicken shops.
Chicken shops are an integral part of UK,
and more specifically London, culture.
The big players are Morley's
and Chicken Cottage,
but there are literally
thousands of independent ones
scattered across the UK.
They're so popular that
people are ripping off
the big chains now.
So you'll see things like
Monley's and Mowley's opening up
with deceptively similar
branding and decor
to the classic Morley's chain.
To put into context just how
popular chicken shops are,
there are currently around
8,000 of them in London.
McDonald's has just 200 locations.
A funny thing is how some of
the independent chicken shops
aren't just ripping off
other ones like Morley's,
but they're trying to rip
off the big chains like KFC.
I think in the UK, people
don't really understand
what fried chicken means when you refer it
to a specific US state.
So I'm sure to Americans
they will know the difference
between Kentucky fried chicken
versus something that was fried elsewhere.
But in the UK, we don't
really have that context.
In the UK, you might walk down the street
and see Ohio fried chicken,
Maryland fried chicken,
or Alaska fried chicken.
As an American, yes, Kentucky
does have a distinct type
of fried chicken.
Popeyes is Louisiana,
other southern states
have their own ways of
making fried chicken.
Yeah, Nashville, hot fried chicken.
That's another one,
which is a city and not a state.
Yes, I realized.
But yeah, Alaska, no, Ohio, no.
Montana, no, no. Montana has no cuisine.
Another thing to point out
is that when it comes to
the big chains like Morley's
and Chicken Cottage, the individual shops
are often franchised.
Leon swears by the
Thornton Heath Morley's.
He's a South London guy, and
he says that's the best one.
If you've been to a better one,
let us know.
Now I'm going to talk
about all the US sandwiches
you cannot get in the
UK. Going to go by chain.
So McDonald's, for instance,
you can get a deluxe
crispy chicken sandwich,
which is just the regular chicken sandwich
with lettuce and tomato, mayo on it.
And then you can also
get the spicy version.
Sauce is a little bit oranger,
which I guess makes it spicier.
Burger King. I saw it
in there. What was it?
You guys called this
the the Burger Royale,
and ours is just the original
crispy chicken sandwich,
sub, sandwich, shaped like that
for seemingly no specific reason.
Yep.
KFC, the Chicken Little,
that's a little guy.
You can also get your Chick-fil-A
sandwich spicy version.
That looks spicier?
It comes in a red bag, because
red is hot, and spicy is hot.
I mean everything at Carl's
Jr. was an exclusive, I think,
because you guys don't even have one.
It just seems like we're kind
of just throwing everything
at the wall and seeing what sticks.
Crispy chicken with bacon.
I feel that Wendy's especially,
Wendy's and Carl's Jr.,
they just are trying to
do variations on a theme,
hoping that will kind of get everyone.
I understand why, but it's
a bit overwhelmed, right?
I mean I don't even know which one to get.
I don't want to bite any of these.
These all look bad.
This whole section here is just like,
throw everything at the
wall and see what sticks.
I don't agree with that strategy, guys.
Just by the looks of all these sandwiches,
the flagship chicken sandwich
at each one of the chains,
I would more go for than any of these.
I don't want any of these.
Harry: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Ikea food
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Quick note: It turns
out Ikea does not offer
a takeout option, but
fortunately they do sell
lots of Tupperware containers.
So in case you're wondering why the food
looks a little bit sad,
it's because we had to
improvise. On with the video.
Let's start portion sizes
with Ikea's claim to fame
when it comes to food,
the Swedish meatballs.
In the US, Ikea's restaurant
offer only one portion size
for meatballs, eight pieces,
but after that you can get
them in increments of four.
For instance, 12 meatballs.
In the UK, Ikea's iconic meatballs
come in two portion sizes, eight or 12.
You can also add four extra
meatballs to any order
for an extra £1.75, and there's seemingly
no limit to how many
times you can do this.
In the UK, the meatballs come
with either mashed potatoes
or chips on the side, as
well as some garden peas,
lingonberry jam, and of
course their famous gravy.
And of course the meatball
options all come with a side
of mashed potatoes and
peas. Get a load of that.
Also a little bit of cranberry sauce.
We're going to weigh eight
meatballs in both countries
to see whose meatballs are bigger.
One, two,
three, four,
five, six,
seven, and eight.
Let's also try and weigh our mash.
Now, I do feel like the stats
might be skewed slightly
because there's some
peas embedded in this.
I will try and free it where I can.
We got way more mash than
the UK, like almost double!
They're feeding us at our Ikeas.
Vegans and vegetarians,
rejoice. Ikea also offers
vegetarian-vegan versions
of its meatballs right here.
We're doing a blind taste
test, plant versus meat.
That's definitely plant-based.
What's the next one?
Peter: No.
Oh, was that wrong?
Wait, OK, give me another one.
OK, this is the other one?
Yeah, that's meat. Not even close.
Not even close. Thank you, Peter.
Neither were bad.
And if I was a vegetarian or vegan,
I would be perfectly happy
with those plant balls.
Tasted perfectly fine, but
the difference is noticeable.
We share a couple of
dessert options with the US,
notably the Daim cake.
Over here, we call that
the caramel almond cake.
Let's weigh a slice.
Another dessert option
we share with the UK
is the soft-serve ice cream,
which you get in vanilla or strawberry.
OK, first of all, the
gentleman who worked there
was adamant that's actually frozen yogurt.
I don't know if that's true or not.
Regardless, they didn't have to-go cups
like Harry was able to get,
so all they would give us
is the small cup where
it's kind of poking out
like it's ready to eat.
It is 97 degrees in Los Angeles today.
There was absolutely no way
that was making it from Ikea
to the car, let alone the studio.
So here's footage of me enjoying
it in the lobby of Ikea.
So, I'm sorry I didn't bring the scale.
I don't know how much it weighs.
We have soft-serve ice
cream in the UK too,
either as vanilla or vanilla
with chocolate sauce.
Impressively, they've
given us exactly 100 grams
of soft-serve ice cream.
Ikea is also known for its hot dogs.
In the UK you can get
either a classic hot dog
or a veggie hot dog from the bistro stand.
We're going to measure and
weigh the classic hot dog
to compare with the US.
The hot dog in the UK
is 7 inches in length,
and with the toppings
of pickles and onions,
it weighs 114 grams.
Hot dog.
Our hot dog is 5 ¼ inches long,
and our hot dog weighs 75 grams.
Here are all the menu items from a UK Ikea
that you won't find in the US.
Here's all the food
you'll find in a US Ikea
you won't find in the UK.
Starting out down here, hot entrées.
This single piece of chicken
is the Havana chicken.
Now, it doesn't come alone.
It comes with plantains,
rice, and beans, which we
will see in a little bit.
But just isolated, the chicken,
has been sitting for a minute, sorry.
Havana chicken. I wonder
what makes it so Havana.
Yeah, I'm definitely
getting some spices in here.
Very flavorful, not just, like,
a standard piece of chicken.
It's actually really good.
We'll start down this end
with some main courses.
We have two different
nonmeat-meatball options in the UK.
Firstly, we have the veggie balls.
These are meatballs which are formed
of ground-up vegetables,
and they're also served with
a vegetable couscous as well.
But for vegetarians who
prefer something a bit more
reminiscent of meat, they
also have plant balls.
Now, I'm kind of intrigued by these
because they look really good.
These are a fake-meat version
of Ikea's classic meatballs.
Now, compared to a classic meatball,
they're actually almost
more visually appealing,
I would say. They're a nice,
dark, golden brown color.
They look like they've been
cooked in a similar way,
maybe even kind of fried
or cooked for longer than
you would expect from these.
Let's do a very quick taste
test. Classic meatball.
We all know and love it.
These things are delicious.
And then one of the plant balls.
I will say the plant-based
one doesn't have that
distinct Ikea meatball taste to it.
That said, still pretty tasty.
I think texture-wise,
it's almost identical
to the classic meatball.
You can also get a salmon
filet with pea pesto,
vegetable medallions, and a corn medley,
which you can see right here.
I mean, salmon's OK, I guess.
OK. This isn't, it's
been sitting for a while.
If you like salmon, sure.
I don't know, you go to
Ikea, you get salmon?
Pea pesto's interesting though.
Still in the mood for fish
before you go furniture shopping?
You can also get the garlic
lemon cod with, of course,
mashed potatoes and peas.
Actually, that's a pretty
good piece of fish.
Yeah, I actually really like that.
OK, I stand corrected.
I was dissing the fish.
It's actually pretty good.
We have a British classic dish,
and that's fish and chips.
Now, the fish they serve at
Ikea in the UK is pollack.
It comes with chips, peas,
and some tartar sauce.
Now, unlike fish and
chips that you might find
from a classic chippy in the UK,
they've actually breaded their fish
rather than battered and then fried it.
I generally prefer the
battered fish texture.
I like the kind of crispy
crunch on the outside
that you get from batter.
I'm going to have a little try of this.
It's very weird tasting
things on "Food Wars"
using a knife and fork. I don't like it.
I respect that they have
attempted to localize their menu
to the UK market.
But maybe put a bit more
thought into your R&D there.
If you want to see what proper
fish and chips looks like,
go and check out our "Food Tours"
best fish and chips in London video.
Next up we have another fish
option. It's a salmon filet.
Charlie: Fillet.
Leon: Come on.
Next up we have another fish
option. It's a salmon fillet.
In the UK, we generally
lean more towards "fillet"
as the wording, and also we
spell it slightly differently.
Often we spell it with two L's,
whereas I believe in the US
it tends to be spelled with one.
I think you can get a
salmon fillet in the US.
However, like we say,
we pronounce ours slightly differently,
and also in the UK ours comes
with the veggie couscous.
Chicken tenders. I mean, come on.
Comes with fries and broccoli.
Hm, wait, these tenders
are actually very good.
Like, the breading,
they're really breaded.
Decent fries. Hearty.
Ikea also has a few things on the menu
that were not available
at the one we went to.
A chicken thigh with
garlic chipotle sauce,
broccoli, and rice. Sounds
actually pretty good.
Lingonberry barbecue
ribs with mac 'n' cheese.
Ah! I was so mad they didn't have those.
And a plant-based burger with fries,
also not available at
time of filming this.
Now, lingonberries are majorly
popular in Swedish cuisine,
and you're going to see
them pop up a few more times
in the Ikea menu.
Next up is penne pasta with tomato sauce.
Penne, of course, refers
to the shape of pasta
that they use here in Ikea.
[Charlie laughing]
Charlie's loved that.
I think penne is maybe my
least favorite pasta shape.
I do not respect penne.
Moving swiftly on from the penne,
we have a chicken katsu curry.
I think this is a relatively new addition
to the UK Ikea menu.
So, katsu refers to the
chicken katsu fillet,
which is a breaded and
fried piece of chicken,
and then it's served with
rice and katsu sauce.
I've not tried this before.
That looks like one just massive
piece of chicken, you know?
Science.
Other than a couple of
slightly disconcerting
dark patches inside the chicken breast,
it's actually not bad. I
think because of the size
of the breast it's dried out quite a lot,
but the katsu sauce is really nice.
I like it with the rice.
I think particularly
if we'd eaten this hot,
this actually would be pretty good.
Next up on the UK menu you can find
a potato and cauliflower rogan josh curry.
A rogan josh is a curry
that you'll find on the menu
of a lot of UK curry houses.
It's not super spicy,
generally quite mild.
I'd say traditionally you
would see this made with lamb,
but they've made a
vegetarian version here,
obviously with potato and cauliflower
as the main bulk of it.
The rogan josh from Ikea
is served with rice,
and then you can also
get some side options
which are designed to go with
it, including some pakoras,
samosas, and a garlic naan.
Obviously the UK has a large
British Indian population,
so I do think this is another attempt to
kind of localize the menu.
That's pretty good.
That's pretty flavorful.
There are some other main-course
options from UK Ikeas
which unfortunately we
couldn't find today.
These include such things
as butternut squash
and sweet potato soup;
Mangalore chicken curry;
butternut squash, blue cheese,
and caramelized onion pie;
chili sin carne; garlic
butter chicken pie;
and leek and potato soup.
I would like to move on to the sides.
Right here we have the
vegetable medallions.
I like veggies presented like this,
just like in a little
puck. Just bite into it.
Looks like it has some broccoli,
mostly potato friendly, little onion.
Yeah, not bad. Decent side.
It's like broccoli potatoes,
like broccoli mashed potatoes.
That Havana chicken that
I mentioned earlier,
this is the beans and rice it comes with.
I don't know if they mix them
up or it just got mixed up
in transit, but, you know,
beans and rice. Let's go.
This is just white rice and black beans.
I don't taste any additional
flavor to this at all.
They do sometimes offer plantains.
Again, the Ikea we went to
today did not have plantains,
but they did have a garlic bread.
I think that's an exclusive.
On to the Ikea cold dishes.
They have a veggie dog.
Well, the veggie dog wrap
is under the cold dishes
according to the script,
and this veggie dog is cold.
Maybe it's been sitting a while.
Either way, it's not very good.
Also, they have a Greek
salad, also the Caesar salad,
which, once again, I mean,
this is pretty low effort.
A Stockholm salad,
not to be confused with
Stockholm syndrome,
which I'm starting to feel
right now eating this food.
Salmon, lettuce, lemon.
Sure.
That's not bad, actually.
I like this sauce that's
turning color under these lights
and this salmon.
We're not quite sure
what is in this salad,
what the sauce is right now,
but due the miracle of editing,
we can put that on the screen right,
and that's what it is.
Tastes pretty good.
Also, you can get a BLT chicken wrap.
Not bad if you like wraps
and BLT and chicken.
Also at a US Ikea, which was not available
at time of filming this
at our Burbank Ikea,
is a Greek veggie ball
wrap and marinated salmon.
The UK's cold-plate menu is
pretty bland in comparison.
The only one they had today was
this marinated salmon plate,
but we can also get an egg
and shrimp sandwich with mayo,
marinated salmon wrap, small salad bowl,
and a tomato and mozzarella salad.
I guess I'll give the salmon a quick try.
I do like smoked salmon.
Here, of course, they call it gravlax
because it's the traditional Swedish way,
and it comes with a dill
sauce and some lemon.
Fairly mild flavor.
I like the kind of herb
crusting that you get.
The dill sauce is pretty dilly.
And now on to desserts.
There are three exclusive
Ikea US desserts.
I was only able to get one of them.
So, the first would be
the strawberry shortcake,
not available at time of shooting this.
The second is this, the
caramel almond cake.
And the third is the infamous
chocolate layered cake,
also known as the conspiracy cake.
I asked everyone there,
"Please tell me you have chocolate cake."
And they all said no.
No chocolate cake at the
Burbank Ikea, today, at least.
Tragically, we don't
have the conspiracy cake
here in the UK, but we do have some other
exclusive dessert options.
For example, this
delightful-looking strawberry tart.
There's some real pieces
of strawberry in there.
I like the pastry, I like the cream,
I like the fresh strawberries.
Whatever the kind of
strawberry syrup jelly stuff
that they've put around
the outside is, it's OK,
but it has a slightly, almost
medicinal quality to it
that I don't really love. It
almost reminds me of Calpol.
I don't know if you have that in the US,
but it's a medicine
that's marketed towards
children in the UK.
Next up, we have Ikea's famous Daim cake.
Now, you do have this on
the menu in the US, however,
I believe you guys call it
something slightly different.
I think caramel almond cake.
Is Daim not a particularly
big brand name in the US?
Because over here in the
UK I'd say most people
are familiar with Daim
as a chocolate brand.
Harry was just talking a
minute ago about the Daim cake,
the diam cake, D-I-A-M cake?
I've never heard of it. I've
never heard of that brand.
I have no idea what it is, I'm
sorry, but we do have this,
which I think is supposed to be similar.
Oh, yeah. This is fantastic.
I'm getting one of these every time I go.
I'm going to get one of these,
and I'm going to get that
chocolate cake. I'm going to
be on the lookout for it now.
It's maybe not quite as popular
in the UK as it used to be.
It reminds me of my grandad a lot
because he used to really love a Daim bar.
I wouldn't see many people
my age going for it,
but still very tasty if
you're in the mood for it.
And this cake is sensational.
You get these layers of chocolate,
this kind of biscuity crumb,
and these kind of, like,
almost pancakes in the middle.
I think these dividing
lines might almost be
kind of cold, chilled pancakes.
This might be my favorite
thing on the menu.
This is why I'm making
excuses to go to Ikea.
Mm.
They did have these at the register,
and this also says Daim
on it. Have we seen that?
Yeah. OK, this tastes like this.
Never heard of this, but it's very good,
and this is fantastic.
Maybe they just rebranded
it because no one in the US
knows what ... Daim cake? Diam cake is?
Our next dessert option is a cheesecake
with blueberries and raspberries.
It's a very soft cheesecake,
really easy to cut.
There's a nice baked crumb on top.
There's a layer of the berry stuff,
so there's some blueberries
in there, some raspberries.
Then finally we have these
Under the Sea rocky road biscuits.
Obviously, rocky road
in the UK is a dessert,
which is usually a no-bake
dessert made of things
like melted chocolate,
golden syrup, marshmallows,
even things like cornflakes,
pieces of biscuit,
that sort of thing, all
just kind of mixed together,
left to set, and then you
have a nice easy dessert.
It turns out what makes this Under the Sea
is that they have a kind of animal stamp
in icing on top of it. Here
we have this nice octopus,
and here we have a couple of dolphins.
I think when I eat a rocky road
I kind of want some
more distinct elements.
I like being able to bite
into it and crunch through
a bit of biscuit or chew
through a raisin or something.
Whereas with this one, it's
kind of all blended together,
so you don't really get
the texture contrasts.
The flavor's very much there.
It's still all those elements
that I'm used to in terms of the flavor.
You may also be able to find
some other dessert options
on a UK menu which we couldn't find today.
These include things like a
caramelized biscuit cheesecake,
a chocolate clementine bomb,
an elderflower and lemon cake,
a gooey chocolatey cake,
a lemon cheesecake,
rhubarb and custard cake,
and a strawberry jelly.
Aside from its restaurant, Ikea also has
the Swedish bistro for quick bites.
The bistro serves quick bites
like hot dogs and pizza slices
that you can generally grab
on your way out of the store.
A few exclusives we had,
of course, was pizza slice.
There it is.
I went with cheese.
Is this like Costco where, like, surprise,
Ikea has amazing pizza?
This is a really good slice of pizza.
I can't tell, but I think
this was oven-cooked,
fire-oven-cooked, not
just like the pizza oven.
This has, like, a,
yeah, like a brick oven.
It's not as good as Costco,
but it's pretty good.
Wow, weird. Ikea's got good
pizza. Good on you, Ikea.
You can also get this
giant bistro pretzel.
Look at this little,
like, a little braid here.
Look at me, I'm a Jedi.
But you are not a Jedi yet.
And it comes with mustard.
They didn't have the mustard either, man.
I don't know, is it because I
went at 10:30 in the morning
and the stuff hadn't shown up yet?
They didn't have anything.
A pretzel with no mustard.
No, no.
You need to dip in something.
Also at the US Ikea bistro,
you can get a marinated salmon baguette.
They didn't have it.
We have a few exclusive bistro
options of our own in the UK.
Firstly, if you like the
onions on the hot dog,
you can just get a side of fried onions.
Next up we have these,
which are chick'less strips.
So, these are a plant-based
version of a chicken tender.
I'd say they look pretty good.
They kind of passed the visual test.
Yeah, when I tore this apart I was worried
that the texture wasn't going to be right,
and unfortunately it's not.
It's very spongy, it's very mushy.
It just needs a little bit more texture.
Just something to make it resemble
a chicken tender a little bit more.
Obviously when you get an
actual piece of chicken tender
or chicken breast, you
can kind of tear it,
and you see those strips and the fibers.
They just really haven't got that here.
Flavor's not too bad, though.
We can also get chips
from the bistro in the UK.
It doesn't seem like you
guys can do this in the US.
We have our veggie dog option,
which comes with the same
toppings as the regular hot dog.
So, here we've got fried onions.
You can also get some with pickles.
The veggie dog in the UK isn't
a plant-based-meat thing,
it is just vegetables.
So it looks like there's some
kale in there, some carrot,
maybe, like, some mustard seeds.
I think that, with the fried onions,
with the pickles and some sauce,
actually a pretty good veggie option.
Then we have some drink
options, notably milkshakes.
In the UK you can get
milkshakes in four flavors,
vanilla, chocolate,
strawberry, and banana.
We got a banana one
today. Have a little sip.
That's not bad. Pretty
gentle banana flavor.
It's mostly just ice cream
but with a little bit
of flavoring in that,
which, who could say no?
Ikea in the UK does serve
breakfast, although unfortunately
when we arrived today
they weren't serving it.
The options that you'll
find there are pretty much
everything that you would normally find
on a full English breakfast,
so it includes things like
bacon, sausages, hash browns,
beans, tomatoes, mushrooms, black pudding.
Sometimes you'll find things
like tattie scones as well,
and you can also get
white or wholemeal toast.
If breakfast platters aren't your thing,
then you can also just go for
some fruit or some porridge.
Breakfast!
The breakfast platter in the
US also comes in both regular
and small sizes and is made
up of eggs, potatoes, bacon,
Swedish pancakes, and now
it's supposed to be topped
with the lingonberry jam, and
they didn't give it to us!
The US breakfast menu also offers
a skagen croissant sandwich,
which is a croissant
filled with traditional
Swedish shrimp salad.
They didn't have it.
I think Ikea has its own
line of drinks available
in its restaurants. The US
Ikeas, you'll find cola,
sugar-free cola,
sparkling raspberry juice,
lingonberry juice, and sparkling lemonade.
I went ahead and got
the lingonberry juice.
Straight up, no idea
what a lingonberry is,
but it's fantastic.
There's no difference in the size cups.
You just have glasses
that are the same size
or these to-go cups or whatever.
We have some drink options
at the restaurant in the UK
that you guys might not have in the US.
There are a couple of options for kids,
which are these Pip Organic juices.
We have a couple of
Robinsons options in the UK.
Robinsons is probably the
most popular brand of squash
in the UK, and this is basically just
a diluted version of their squash.
Squash, for those who don't
know, is a concentrated,
fruity drink that you kind of water down
to have a nice refreshing beverage.
You can get a peach and mango version
or a raspberry and apple version.
And if you feel like celebrating
any of your purchases
that you've just made
from the Ikea, you can also get alcohol.
We have three alcoholic options
on the menu at a UK Ikea,
a rosé wine, a red wine, or a dark lager.
Finally, Ikea has a Swedish
market where you can buy
prepackaged food items to take home.
The items on offer include
some of their classic foods,
like the meatballs,
which you can buy frozen,
or some gravy sachets,
which you can make at home.
In the UK, you can also
find the plant-based balls
on offer in there.
You can get a whole frozen Daim cake,
which I'll be taking home
and eating all by myself.
And speaking of Daim, you
can also get the chocolate
which the cake is based on.
Here it's in bite-sized form rather than
as actual chocolate
bars, but as you can see,
it's chocolate with a kind
of hard caramel center.
Charlie has dibs on these.
Another thing at the US Ikea,
maybe not exclusives per se,
but of course they have a
whole thing of frozen stuff.
I just grabbed stuff that was interesting.
Come on, the Cinnabons, huh?
The cinnamon buns.
Meatballs.
And, you know we were talking about
the Daim cake,
but they do have, it's
frozen to take home,
and of course it is the Daim cake.
Let's compare the nutritional
information of some iconic
Ikea dishes in the US and the UK.
In the UK, eight Ikea meatballs
contains the following:
342 calories,
25.1 grams of fat,
8.2 grams of carbs,
and 856 milligrams of sodium.
In the US, the same plate
of Swedish meatballs contain
304 calories,
22.4 grams of fat,
6.4 grams of carbs,
592 milligrams of sodium.
The UK takes this round in every category.
What about the Ikea hot dog?
In the US it contains 260
calories, 15 grams of fat,
24 grams of carbs, and
780 milligrams of sodium.
And in the UK, the hot
dog contains 293 calories,
15.2 grams of fat, 29.5 grams of carbs,
and 708 milligrams of sodium.
Looks like the UK version
is higher in calories
and fat once again. USA, baby.
What's actually in the
iconic Ikea meatballs?
According to the Ikea
website, if you want to make
their meatballs at home, use
the following ingredients:
beef mince, pork mince, onion,
garlic, bread crumbs, milk,
egg, and salt and pepper to taste.
But is that actually the ingredients list
for proper Ikea meatballs?
Well, on the back of the frozen packet,
you'll find an ingredients list.
According to this packet, they
contain beef, pork, water,
bread crumbs, egg, dried onion,
salt, egg powder,
black pepper extract, and allspice.
Overall, it seems like it's
pretty close to the list
that they gave you on the
website, with a few more things
like powdered ingredients
versus fresh ingredients,
and a couple of spice differences too.
I wasn't able to find it online
or in the cafeteria,
the ingredients list, but I got here
the frozen precooked meatballs,
and those ingredients ...
hm, actually not bad.
Assuming these are the ones
that they have in the cafeteria
in the US, the ingredients
for this is beef, pork,
water, bread crumbs made
of unbleached wheat flour,
salt, and yeast,
whole eggs, salt,
dehydrated onion, egg white,
that's not plural. Egg white, singular.
Spices.
That's not bad, I think, for
a prepackaged product, right?
It's like, well, that's, you
know, what's in them, right?
While we're on the subject
of Ikea ingredients,
one thing that UK viewers might remember
was our infamous horsemeat scandal.
Back in 2013, a number of foods
in the UK claiming to be beef or pork
were actually found to
contain traces of horsemeat.
While this wasn't
necessarily a health issue,
it did raise some major
questions concerning
the traceability of foods
throughout supply chains,
and unfortunately Ikea was
also caught up in this scandal.
Czech authorities found
traces of horsemeat
in some Ikea meatballs that
had been produced in Sweden
and shipped all around Europe.
Thankfully, the horsemeat
meatballs were found
before they reached consumers.
In total, 760 kilograms of
meatballs were destroyed.
Given the fact that
there's no health concerns
related to the consumption of horsemeat,
I think they should have
just leaned into it.
Just passed them off as, like,
limited-edition horse meatballs,
and just go with it, lads, it's fine.
Ikea's food is almost suspiciously cheap,
and it's actually one of
the ways it tricks you into
spending more time and
money in its stores.
Ikea is basically willing
to take its losses
with its cheap food prices
because it's counting on you
to spend a bunch of money
on furniture and other household items.
A former Ikea executive even
referred to the meatballs
as the "best sofa seller."
In the UK, a plate of
eight meatballs, peas,
mash or chips, gravy, and lingonberry jam
will set you back just £4.95.
At the time of recording,
that's around $6.49.
I do have to say, that's really cheap.
I don't think the quality's that bad.
It's really tasty food and,
yeah, it's a real bargain.
I will make an effort
to go via the restaurant
if I'm just going through Ikea.
Even if I'm just popping in
for, like, one or two bits,
I'm going to sit down,
eat a plate of meatballs.
It's good value, it's tasty, I love it.
An eight-meatball meal in the US is $9.99,
which in the UK is £7.80.
That's a 54% increase in the States.
Overall I would say Ikea is
pretty popular in the UK.
It's most people's go-to
for basic furniture
and household needs, I would say,
especially when people are buying a house
or moving house or something like that.
Personally, I love Ikea.
I love going there.
I do enjoy a trip. It's
fun. I like the food.
I like walking around
and pretending, like,
"Ooh, that could be my apartment
or my bedroom or my kitchen."
I wouldn't say Ikea is
somewhere I go often,
particularly because I live
in quite central London,
and there aren't many in Central London.
I think they're trying to
open one on Oxford Street
right now. At the time of
recording this, it wasn't open,
but they're kind of trying to get there.
But so, like I say, it's more
of a place where you'll go
specifically when you
need to do an Ikea shop.
Ikea is so popular here.
I think it's popular in the whole country.
The one in Burbank, we went
there at 10:30 in the morning.
It opens at 10, and at 10:30,
parking lot was pretty full.
The cafeteria line was full.
So I'd say Ikea's pretty popular.
I personally wouldn't go
to Ikea just for the food.
Again, it might be because
I don't live close enough
to one to make that worthwhile.
I do love the food. The
meatballs are great.
Like I say, the desserts are fantastic.
But I don't like it to
the extent that I would
make the effort to travel
to one just to eat there.
I'm not going to say I
go to Ikea for the food,
but the food definitely is a
good motivator to go to Ikea.
I will say overall I
do enjoy the experience
of going to an Ikea.
I am aware that it's kind of designed
to make us spend money.
Obviously the restaurant
plays a part of this as well,
because it's kind of
encouraging you to make a day
of your trip to Ikea, really
spend some time there,
sit down, take a break in
the middle of the day, eat,
re-energize yourself for more shopping.
And as you can guess by
my friends on the table
with me here, I do think that
their marketing is a really
clever ploy to make us spend
more money there as well.
I'm joined here by my friend Djungelskog.
I'm really sorry, I'm going to
butcher these pronunciations.
And my friend Blåhaj, who
is the adorable little shark
who is also, I think, a
trans icon. Love that.
You'll often see things like this
really getting a
reputation on the internet,
driving more commerce to Ikea stores.
I don't know if they're
doing that deliberately
or if it's just kind of a
side effect of making some
very, very cute plush toys.
But everyone, I think, will generally have
at least one thing from
Ikea in their home.
So whatever they're doing,
it's kind of working.
I'm not mad about it either.
I support Ikea. Keep
up the good work, guys.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Pop-Tarts
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Pop-Tarts come in
one main size, an eight-pack.
You might also be able
to find a 36-pack online,
but these seem more
geared towards retailers
rather than consumers,
so for the purposes of "Food
Wars," we're not counting them.
In the US, our Pop-Tarts
come in seven size varieties.
Down here with the two-pack; eight-pack;
12-pack; 16-pack, the value pack;
32-pack, the family pack,
I don't know if you can see
it says "family" on there;
and the biggest amount, the 48-pack.
They probably also come in one box.
That means our biggest Pop-Tart
variety is 33.3% bigger
than what you can get in the UK.
But are the Pop-Tarts the
same size in both countries?
Let's measure them to find out.
So, our UK Pop-Tart was 8 centimeters wide
and 11 centimeters long,
for a surface area of
88 centimeters squared.
We will do the same.
3 by 4.
And of course, we're going to weigh it.
Joe: And a Pop-Tart in
the US weighs 48 grams.
Harry: Our UK Pop-Tart
was bang on 50 grams,
which I think is actually slightly more
than it's supposed to weigh.
Kellogg's woke up feeling
a little generous today.
"But what about the
pastry-to-filling ratio?"
I hear you cry.
Well, don't worry, we're
going to look at that too.
You can sort of chisel
off layers of pastry.
I mean, there's really
not much jam in there.
That's a very thin layer
of jam right there.
I think we might have to abandon this.
It's gone real bad.
So, unfortunately, we had
to abandon the scrape test
because that was not working.
Joe, if you pulled that
off, you're a genius.
I don't know how you've done it.
However, on the back of
the box of the Pop-Tarts,
it says that the fruit
filling should be 34%
of the Pop-Tart by weight.
If our maths are correct,
this was a 50-gram Pop-Tart.
34% of that should be 17 grams of jam.
Joe: Yeah, all right.
Hot! Hot! Hot!
Hot. Ow! Mm!
Ow. Mm!
I'm wiping it on here. Right?
We'll round up to 10 grams.
So that is this percentage of jam.
Here's all the Pop-Tarts
you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
And here are all the Pop-Tarts from the UK
that you can't find in the US.
Yes, it's just the one.
[laughing]
We got all of them.
Wanted to get this out
of the way real quick.
There are currently two
limited-edition Pop-Tarts
out right now, the red,
white, and blueberry
and the frosted strawberry throwback.
I went to Walmart. The guy
said they didn't have them.
Also, newer ones,
there is an Apple Jacks
frosted apple cinnamon one,
which is supposed to be
delivered to my house tomorrow.
I'm sorry.
But one new one we do have
is frosted banana bread,
which is ... looks like a Pop-Tart.
Gave us some extra frosting up top there.
Yeah, it tastes like banana bread.
Actually, it's very good.
You can only find three Pop-Tart varieties
on sale in the UK, including
strawberry sensation,
frosted chocotastic, and hot fudge sundae.
These two you can also find in the US,
so they're not exclusives,
but this one is. The frosted chocotastic.
While it has its own name, it
does seem a little bit similar
to the US chocolate fudge one,
so we'll take it out and have a look.
So, this is a UK frosted
chocotastic Pop-Tart.
It's got the chocolate icing,
the pastry itself is chocolate-flavored,
and it's got these little
flecks of white stuff on it.
Ambitiously, in my mind, I
was hoping it might be, like,
flaky sea salt, but it's a Pop-Tart.
I think it's more likely
to just be some icing.
Not too bad.
You also have a chocolaty
filling on that as well,
so it's kind of like three levels
of chocolate going on here.
Not too sweet either, actually.
All right, starting with
the frosted chocolate fudge.
All right, let's compare
this to what Harry got.
Chocolate on chocolate.
I know I'm just going
to state the obvious,
but this is, like, really
chocolaty and fudgy.
Seeing as we only have three Pop-Tarts,
I figured I'd try the
other ones too just to see
how they stack up against
the exclusive chocotastic.
So, this is our version
of hot fudge sundae.
Pastry-wise, looks kind of similar
to the chocolate one with
the chocolate pastry,
but then it has something more resembling
the strawberry icing.
I feel like this is probably
a slightly lazy attempt
to just kind of rehash
things they already have
into a new product. The
filling looks pretty similar
to the filling found on
the frosted chocotastic.
Slightly lighter in color,
so maybe they've gone for
more of a fudge vibe rather
than just straight chocolate.
I think with the combination
of the standard icing
and the slightly different
filling, this has more of a
well-rounded, balanced sweet flavor to it.
And, of course, the classic
strawberry Pop-Tart.
Obviously, visually this stands out
because they have not gone
for the chocolate pastry.
It's that very, kind of almost
alarmingly pale pastry color.
Pretty much the same icing, I think,
that they've used on the hot fudge sundae.
It's the classic for a reason.
It's just really good.
It's the blueberry. All
right, getting some fruit.
I wouldn't be able to
guess what fruit this was
just by looking at the outside. I mean ...
Here in the US so far,
one thing I've noticed,
they're really skimping on the filling.
I know it's, like, dusty, but
brown sugar cinnamon, beat up.
Ooh, this is, like, really smooth.
Also very dusty.
I honestly can't tell if the flavor
is the frosting or the jam.
Cherry. I mean, I feel like
this is a flagship one.
Aim's not so great over
there at the factory.
Already though, both on
this side and this side,
you can almost see the filling
coming out of it, right?
I'm starting to think that a
lot of the sweet fruit flavor
is coming from the frosting
and not the inside.
Chocolate chip.
All right. Already, this.
Could we get that sad trombone please?
It's like, so — it's
like a doctor's signature.
It's just, whoop! Right across it.
I can't read this. What does this say?
Oh, come — ugh, Pop-Tart.
Ooh, this really irritates me.
This really winds me up.
Oh, you gotta be kidding me with this.
Your mom or your school
or your work, whatever,
doesn't get Oreos,
they get the knockoff-brand
sandwich cookies,
and it's like, you'll eat them,
but you're like, "Ah, man.
Kind of wanted Oreos."
That's what this tastes like.
This tastes like a knockoff of an Oreo.
Frosted confetti.
Ugh. No, don't make me eat this.
Please don't make me eat this.
It's like just eating straight frosting.
Next up, frosted hot fudge sundae.
Breakfast is served.
This looks like an absolute nightmare.
Imagine eating this and going to school.
Totally phoned in, like, blah! Drizzle.
It's very sweet.
Oh, man.
A Pop-Tart s'mores. Yuelei's choice.
OK. It tastes like a s'mores.
You can see a little pocket
of marshmallow there.
This is the first dual
filling I think I've had,
or at least I've noticed.
And you know what?
I don't really like it.
I can't believe we only had one exclusive.
I feel like I'm really missing out
on some of those tasty American Pop-Tarts.
Joe, can I get some of those?
No worries, man. I got you.
Ah!
Thank you!
So, it looks like Joe
has kindly shared with me
some confetti cupcake Pop-Tarts,
the American version of the
hot fudge sundae Pop-Tarts,
and some frosted s'mores Pop-Tarts.
Frosted confetti.
I feel like Americans are just obsessed
with eating sprinkles
because it seems like every kind of brand,
whether it's chocolate, pastry,
will have a kind of confetti
cupcake, birthday cake flavor,
and Pop-Tarts are no exception.
American sprinkles look so much better
than British sprinkles.
I know it's because they
are using banned chemicals,
which we don't have over here.
We have to opt for natural alternatives.
But when it comes to baking,
they just hold their color so much better.
They look a lot more vibrant.
I kind of get why you guys are using it.
It doesn't give me any
pleasure to admit it,
but that is really tasty.
It's got almost a sort of
cake-batter taste to it, that filling.
So it kind of is like you're
eating a confetti cupcake,
or at least the batter
of a confetti cupcake.
In my left hand, I have a
British strawberry sensation Pop-Tart.
In my right hand, I have the American
frosted confetti cupcake one.
Just quickly wanted to point
out the color difference
because that is wild.
Next up is the American version
of the hot fudge sundae Pop-Tarts.
The American version of these
looks so much more fun than ours.
Size-wise, they look pretty much the same,
but the American one looks thicker.
The American one has
this white icing filling,
whereas in the UK I think they've gone for
more of a kind of fudgy chocolate filling.
The difference between these
two is kind of night and day.
The American one, better than
ours in pretty much every way.
I tasted this at first,
and I wasn't disappointed by it, per se.
But now that I've had the comparison,
direct comparison with the US,
this tastes like eating cardboard.
Finally, it's the
frosted s'mores Pop-Tart.
I gotta say, s'mores aren't
really a thing in the UK.
In the UK, we don't have graham crackers,
or, as we would pronounce
it, gray-ham crackers.
Shout out to my dad, Graham.
Yeah, there we go. There we go.
It's almost like a digestive biscuit.
These are pretty good.
This one looks maybe the scariest.
It's cookies and cream.
Whenever it's frosting
inside, I know I'm in trouble.
Yuck.
Don't give this to a child ever.
And most adults should also not eat this.
Grape. Grape?!
Fruit ones look how I think a
Pop-Tart is supposed to look.
They don't look that intimidating.
Grape is a really
popular flavor in the US,
but anyone in the US will tell you
that grape-flavored candy
doesn't really taste like grapes.
They somehow invented a grapelike flavor,
probably because grapes have
a weaker flavor, I think.
I'm not quite sure
exactly how it came to be,
but this tastes exactly like that
fake, imitation Bubblicious
bubble gum grape.
You know what I'm talking about.
A grape soda.
It's not bad. So far, all the fruit ones
are better than any of the other ones, so.
Yeah, Eggo.
How unnatural looking is this?
You know how you can take those classes,
I think they're called,
like, sip and paint,
where everyone paints the same
picture, the same still life
while they're sipping
wine with their friends?
This was the image they were painting,
and this is what they painted drunk.
This does not in any way
taste like an Eggo waffle.
I don't think it tastes
like waffles at all.
What ruins it is this frosting on here.
This is so sweet.
Raspberry.
I have a feeling this is
going to be a good one.
Yeah.
Top tier right here.
These were optimized for fruit filling.
Wild berry.
So is just the combination wild?
Or these were found in the wild?
Oh, no!
Alarm bells in my
caveman DNA is going off.
Do not eat. This is poisonous.
Do not eat. Warning. Warning.
Ancestors who ate this died.
Let's go against millions
of years of evolution
and bite into this woefully
bright-colored piece of,
I'm assuming, food.
We'll find out together.
With all the frosting that's on there,
it's actually not that sweet,
compared to the other fruit ones.
Play this part of the video
to the ambulance driver
when he asks what happened.
Boston cream.
Boston cream doughnut
is this doughnut right here,
if you haven't seen it.
You can't even tell where the cream is
compared to the color of the pastry.
What I'm about to say
will come as no surprise
to anyone watching this video,
but this one tastes completely artificial.
I know, right? Can you believe it?
On to the next, smaller pyramid.
Snickerdoodle.
Bland.
All right, let me look
at the unfrosted ones.
Unfrosted?
Unfrosted, we got strawberry,
brown sugar cinnamon,
and blueberry.
Unfrosted v. frosted.
I was complaining how sweet they were,
so maybe I'm more of an unfrosted guy
and I don't realize it,
but this looks weird.
This looks like an army ration.
This one is sweeter,
but not that much sweeter.
Don't you think with the
frosting it'd be night and day?
They're pretty similar.
Simply frosted harvest strawberry.
There you go. No artificial colors.
Color from natural sources.
Once again, regular strawberry Pop-Tarts.
They look pretty similar, right?
This one maybe has more frosting on it.
Wow. They taste exactly the
same as the artificial ones.
One other thing that
we wanted to talk about
was the
toasted-versus-untoasted-Pop-Tarts debate.
Now, people have been debating for years
whether it's better to
eat your Pop-Tarts toasted
or straight out of the packet.
I will say, in the UK,
this is less of a debate
because I feel like most
people are more likely
to toast their Pop-Tarts,
even though they are
safe to eat straight out of the packet.
However, we did notice that
on the American ones that Joe sent over,
there are some varying instructions,
which kind of confused us.
Apparently in the US,
you can microwave them,
which you're supposed to do
in bursts of three seconds
until they're hot enough to eat,
despite the fact that the British ones
explicitly tell you to not microwave them.
I'm assuming at some point
someone tried to microwave them
in the foil and was met
with a nasty surprise.
And also the American ones say
that you can freeze them
and eat them frozen.
Don't know why you would do that.
Frozen or semi-frozen pastry
does not sound like it would be nice.
But we're not here for
microwaved or frozen Pop-Tarts.
We're just going to heat a couple up
in the toaster oven and then compare them
to some untoasted Pop-Tarts
to see which ones I prefer.
All right. Toasty boy going in.
Let's see if we can rectify that.
Also, did you notice?
What is with Harry's giant toaster oven?
Look at the size of that thing!
Just get a regular toaster.
Ta-da!
Smells like toasted pastry.
Ah!
Hey!
Ooh, it is falling apart.
They're just breaking apart already.
The untoasted.
Yeah, toasted's way better.
The filling's more flavorful.
The crispiness of the pastry.
I just am too lazy to toast them.
So, this one on my right
is the untoasted version,
and on my left is the toasted version.
I gotta say, visually,
not a lot has changed.
I was hoping for a
little bit more browning
while it was in the oven.
Still not much of a snap from
the pastry, even when toasted.
But you can see that the
filling has slightly liquefied.
Really impressive that
they've actually managed
to create a pastry that doesn't just burst
and leak all of the filling
when it does get toasted.
I say impressive; probably
just uses a lot of chemicals.
Whereas when you compare
it to the untoasted one,
even when you kind of squish it down,
that filling is not going anywhere.
I do prefer the toasted
version, as I sort of expected.
I think the main difference for me
is actually in the filling.
Obviously, the flavor doesn't change a lot
when you toast it. It's
more the texture, I think.
Just the fact that it
does liquefy slightly
gives it a much more pleasant texture
when you actually bite into this thing.
Also in the US,
you can get something
called Pop-Tarts bites.
These guys right here.
I have strawberry, of course,
and confetti cake.
But you can also get brown sugar cinnamon,
frosted blueberry,
frosted chocolate fudge,
and strawberry banana.
I have no idea what these are.
No, these are not good.
Pop-Tarts also does
collabs with other brands.
For instance, there's a
Pop-Tarts Jeni's ice cream,
Coffee Mate has its own Pop-Tarts flavor,
and, of course, Pop-Tarts cereal.
It was originally called
Pop-Tarts Crunch, discontinued,
but they renamed it after
they brought it back.
In the UK, an eight-pack
of strawberry Pop-Tarts
costs you £2.99,
which is around $3.86.
That same box in the
US is $4.49, or £3.47,
a 16.3% increase in the US.
Oof! With the gouging!
Come on, guys.
It's not surprising to me
that Pop-Tarts are
really popular in the US.
We love a quick and convenient breakfast.
They have positioned
themselves in their advertising
as a more convenient
breakfast than cereal,
because you know how
inconvenient cereal is.
You gotta get the box and
the bowl and the spoon
and the milk and sit down and eat it.
Not Pop-Tarts. Cereal, too much work.
Pop-Tarts, way easier.
For me, the price increase
per portion makes sense
because I've always seen
Pop-Tarts as more of a treat
than an everyday breakfast food.
It was the sort of thing that
my mom might have let me had as, like,
a weekend-treat breakfast
if I had accompanied
on her weekly shop and
been very well behaved.
I will say that the marketing in the UK
explicitly doesn't brand
these as a breakfast food,
compared to something like cereal.
There is no mention
of the word "breakfast" anywhere on here.
They're just referred to
as "toaster pastries."
So I guess they could be
construed as more of a snack.
Is the lack of breakfast
talk the same in the US, Joe,
or are you guys a bit less shameless
about marketing desserts as
breakfast foods for children?
So, I originally thought
this was supposed to be
breakfast food, but
Harry makes a good point.
It doesn't say breakfast anywhere on here.
Even the box says you can get them
straight from the foil,
toasted, stacked, or frozen.
But they really are not saying
anything about breakfast.
So I went back and looked online.
In the '90s — I looked on YouTube.
I found a bunch of commercials
where they said it was
specifically for breakfast,
they even quote "part of
your complete breakfast."
So they did sometimes market them
as breakfast foods and then sometimes not.
And just for me, it sunk in that, yeah,
you have these for
breakfast in the morning
when you're in a hurry
to get to school or work.
Here is the nutritional information
for one strawberry Pop-Tart in the UK.
Let's be honest. They
come in packs of two.
So we're going to double those numbers
for a more accurate serving-size reading.
Thank you, Harry. Because in the US,
we go straight for the
two-tart serving size,
and here, our strawberry Pop-Tarts are ...
It looks like the UK numbers
are actually slightly
higher than those in the US,
so I guess that means we're winning?
Now, if calories are
your thing, in the US,
our cinnamon brown sugar
Pop-Tarts have the most.
400 per serving.
But wait!
The unfrosted
have even more calories.
410 per serving.
I don't know how that works either.
In 2021, somebody sued Kellogg's,
claiming that Pop-Tarts
contained way less strawberry
than what was presented on the packaging.
This case was ultimately
dismissed, as the judge said,
quote, "No reasonable
consumer could believe
from Kellogg's packaging
that the breakfast staple" —
Hey, breakfast! Perfect. OK.
"Contained only strawberries,
or more strawberries
than other ingredients
such as pears and apples."
The US packaging actually states that
the strawberry Pop-Tarts
contain 2% or less
of dried strawberries.
Here are all the ingredients
of a UK strawberry
sensation frosted Pop-Tart.
One thing to note is that the
gelatin used in a UK Pop-Tart
is explicitly labeled as "beef gelatin."
So unfortunately, this
means that British Pop-Tarts
are not suitable for vegetarians.
And here are all the ingredients
in a US strawberry Pop-Tart.
Doo, doo, doo, doo.
Of the many differences
between these two lists,
there are a few ingredients
we wanted to highlight here.
The first is TBHQ, or
tert-butylhydroquinone.
[beeping]
Leon: Tuberculosis headquarters, isn't it?
To be honest, quite.
[beeping]
This is a preservative which
is used to extend shelf life
or for added freshness,
as the US label states.
The FDA has put limits on
how much it can be used.
"TBHQ can't account for
more than 0.02 percent
of the oils in a food
because the FDA doesn't have evidence
that greater amounts are safe.
While that doesn't mean
that more than 0.02 percent is dangerous,
it does indicate that higher safety levels
haven't been determined."
Research has linked
TBHQ to health problems.
The National Library of Medicine
found vision disturbances
when it was consumed by humans,
as well as "liver enlargement,
neurotoxic effects, convulsions,
and paralysis in laboratory animals."
Pop-Tarts in the US also
contain synthetic food coloring
which are restricted in the UK,
specifically yellow 5, yellow 6, red 40,
because of their link to hyperactivity
and inattention in children.
Golly gee, I can't imagine why.
My brain is just going all over the place.
Another thing to note is that
the Pop-Tarts Joe sent me
are technically contraband items.
If you're working with the
police or the government
and you watch this, please
do not extradite Joe.
We need him for filming.
That's because the flour used
in US Pop-Tarts is bleached.
Bleaching flour has been banned
in the UK since the 1990s
over concerns about
potential health effects.
It also just seems unnecessary to me,
especially for something
that's going to be toasted
and darken in color anyway.
You guys just love putting
chemicals in your food
and seem to seize any
opportunity you can to do it.
Yeah, don't arrest me, but
he did ask me to send it.
So I will flip on the UK team in a second.
FBI, if you're watching,
I will wear a wire.
It was all Harry's idea.
I will help you take him down.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Hard Rock Cafe
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Let's break down "the
burger that started it all,"
the original legendary burger.
Let's weigh the US burger.
318 grams.
Here's the original
legendary burger in the UK.
Let's weigh it.
Our burger weighed 280 grams.
That's a pretty big difference,
from 280 to 318 grams.
This is a heavy, heavy burger.
And, of course, all their burgers
come with a side of seasoned fries.
We're going to weigh ours to
see how much we're getting.
So, our side of fries came to 178 grams.
They feel so soggy right now in my hands.
So, that is 126 grams of french fries.
Another iconic menu
item is baby back ribs.
We're going to weigh our UK portion
to find out how much we're getting.
Is that too heavy?
Charlie: That's too heavy.
335 plus ...
oh, God.
300.
635 grams.
This is heavy.
This is 802 grams of ribs.
That sounds like too much
ribs for one sit-down dinner.
That's a lot of ribs.
The cowboy rib eye is
supposedly 16 ounces of beef.
Let's see if that's actually true.
This is 12.8 ounces of meat.
Meat does shrink,
so a little wiggle room is to be expected,
but that's
a pretty decent chunk.
Crew: Boo!
We booed.
Everyone's booing.
Everyone's booing me.
So, after being booed by everyone,
I'll be more upset about losing out
on some of this meat.
It just looks like such a big portion
that I'm like, it's fine.
But it is 4 ounces that we're missing
that was advertised. So I understand.
I understand why everyone's upset.
Strangely, the cowboy rib eye
is advertised as being
14 ounces here in the UK.
I'm not sure why we're
getting shortchanged,
but we're going to measure
it to keep them honest.
So, our UK cowboy rib eye
has actually only come to
10 ½ ounces.
I understand that steaks
do lose some of their mass
while cooking, but 3 ½
ounces? That seems like a lot.
Let's get into some apps.
We got the classic nachos, no meat.
This is "Food Wars,"
so you know we gotta weigh these nachos.
602 grams.
Here are the UK nachos.
I'm going to weigh them
with the paper because
our scale has had enough trauma already.
Our UK nachos weighed 510 grams.
I'm interested to see which country
has bigger wing portions,
so let's count them out.
Count them out with me. We have one,
two.
Three,
four.
Harry: 10,
11,
and 12.
Nico: Seven,
eight.
I'm going to let them have this one.
I'm going to let them have this one
because we've literally
been destroying them
in these portion sizes this entire time.
So you know what? You deserve
the extra amount of wings.
Hard Rock Cafe is also known
for its famous onion ring tower.
Now, on the menu, they don't specify
how many onion rings you get in a tower.
However, in a promotional
photo, I counted eight.
So we're going to count ours
out now and see if that's true
or if we get more or less
than we were promised.
I'm going to try my hardest to beat Harry
in the onion-ring-tower-making.
Somehow built this the wrong way round,
so it's getting wider near the top.
Six,
seven.
Oh, God, no!
I'm not doing that again.
Eight,
nine,
10.
Girls in STEM.
So, while my tower design failed horribly,
we did get 11 onion rings
in our onion ring tower as a side.
What about dessert?
Let's compare Hard Rock's apple cobbler
in the US and the UK.
It smells so good.
I'm resisting every urge I have
to bite into it right now.
We've got 432 grams of apple cobbler.
So, the apple cobbler in
the UK came to 376 grams.
Here are all the menu items you'll find
at a Hard Rock in the UK that
you won't find in the US.
Here's all the food that you'll find
at Hard Rock Cafe in the US
that you won't find in the UK.
There are a couple of burgers you'll find
in the US but not in the UK,
the turkey burger and
the Impossible burger.
I think Impossible beef isn't
available in the UK yet.
There's an ingredient in it
called soy leghemoglobin,
which is approved in the
US but not in the UK.
The Impossible burger.
That soy leghemoglobin is
doing what it needs to do.
That's the ingredient
that makes this taste
like actual beef, and it's
working. It's working for me.
I can tell texture-wise,
in the back of my head,
this is not beef,
but it's doing enough
where I don't really care.
It tastes pretty good.
There's also a small difference
in the classic legendary
burger in the two countries.
The UK uses just regular cheddar cheese,
while the US specifically
uses Tillamook cheddar.
Tillamook is a popular
creamery based in Oregon.
I'm not going to bite
into everything here today
because we are going to
give some of this away,
but if there's anything that
catches my eye particularly,
then I'll give it a try.
We actually have quite a
few exclusives in the UK,
so I'll start at this
end and work my way down.
First off, we have cauliflower tacos.
I think they are pretty
much as the name suggests.
It's a taco, which is a,
I think is a flour tortilla
with some pieces of seasoned
cauliflower in there
as well as some slaw, some
sauce, and some jalapeños.
Next up, we've got barbecue chicken.
This one really just does
what it says on the tin.
It's just half of a chicken,
which has been grilled and
covered in barbecue sauce.
It's almost unnerving
how accurately they have
halved this chicken.
It's literally like they've just gone
straight through the middle
of it with, like, a laser beam
and sliced the thing in two.
The next exclusive menu
item is fish and chips.
You get this a lot. You
might have a company
which branding-wise seems
like it's not from the UK,
but when they launch in the UK,
they feel compelled to have
fish and chips on the menu.
I will have to try this one.
I can't let them off the hook
if they've really
butchered fish and chips.
Although I will give them,
again, some credit for the fact
that this has been
sitting around for a while
and therefore has lost all of the crisp
which I think it once had.
It's not too bad.
I do think had we eaten
this hot and fresh,
it would've been a bit crispier.
You can definitely see some
of the flakes of batter
which would've crisped up.
Next up, we have the
Moving Mountains burger.
Now, we don't have the Impossible burger
on the UK menu because as of right now,
Impossible beef still
cannot be sold in the UK.
Moving Mountains is a company
which does very similar things.
It's making plant-based meat alternatives,
including a beef burger, which is approved
for sale in the UK and is on offer here.
I mean, visually, I gotta say
the Moving Mountains burger
does look pretty good.
It's got a nice brown exterior.
They've got the kind of grainy,
like, meat fibers, almost, in the middle,
and it definitely looks a bit pink, even.
I'm quite impressed by that.
That's really not bad.
Obviously it doesn't
have the exact beef taste
that you're used to, but
there's definitely a meatiness to it.
Every Hard Rock Cafe location
also has a local burger
which is inspired by
ingredients found in that area.
So this is the London burger.
On here, you'll find a beef patty
with some layers of roast beef,
a horseradish mayo, rocket,
some tomato, and some lettuce.
Now, the London burger is loosely inspired
by a British Sunday roast,
specifically the roast beef.
I do think I need to taste this
to see if it's giving an
accurate representation
of British cuisine.
They've been fairly generous
with the roast beef slices, I have to say.
Cheers.
You definitely do get
that roast beef flavor
from these pieces of beef.
I think it could maybe have done
with even more horseradish mayo,
because the flavor of
that is really lovely.
It's pretty good.
Whether it's a accurate
representation of London
and London cuisine, I'm
going to go with no.
But is it a tasty burger?
Kind of, yes.
New York City doesn't have
a region-specific burger,
but they do offer a French
dip on garlic bread.
Joe made me aware that the French dip
was not created in New
York, but rather LA.
But I can kind of see
what they were going for
because roast beef sandwiches in general
are popular here. That
includes French dips.
And they might have
chosen the garlic bread
because New York City has so much Italian
and Italian American
culture ingrained in it.
I feel like I'm kind
of reaching right now,
but I'm just trying to
make sense of it all.
This is the garlic bread
that they speak of.
Um, I think we need to have
some words with Hard Rock Cafe.
What is the sauce called?
Bless you.
Got her.
Got both of them.
I'm taking a dip. I'm taking a dip.
You can do it! You can do it!
This is the coldest au jus
and the coldest French dip.
This is just not it.
Go somewhere else. Go somewhere else!
Hard Rock Cafe has also partnered
with the greatest footballer of all time,
Lionel Messi.
Now, I'm not sure if
Messi's diet allows him
to regularly eat at Hard Rock Cafe.
However, he's partnered with
them to release two burgers.
You can find the Messi beef burger
in both the US and the UK,
but in the UK we have an exclusive one,
the Messi chicken burger.
Let's just take a look
and see what we can find.
So, we have what looks to
be maybe a potato roll.
We've got some bacon, some cheese,
a big grilled chicken breast.
There is some sauce on here as well.
Mayonnaise.
As well as tomato and lettuce.
If I take a bite out of this,
do you think I will gain
the footballing ability
of Lionel Messi?
Whether that is a sandwich
fitting for the GOAT,
I'm not sure.
Speaking of Messi,
I think now's a great time to quiz Joe
and see if he can pick him
out in a group of photos.
He is one of the most famous
men in the entire world,
so it shouldn't be hard. Right, Joe?
So, one of these persons is Lionel Messi,
and I don't know which one he is.
Well, this guy's from "Ted Lasso,"
so I'm assuming it's not him,
or someone would've said at some point,
"Can you believe that guy
is also a famous soccer player?"
This looks like a person
who works in a café.
So I'm going to assume that's not him.
Tough times for football
players, apparently.
I mean, this just looks like,
I feel like I've seen this guy somewhere.
I feel like this guy works at Insider.
Who's this?
This can't be him.
This looks like a stock photo.
And then this looks like a guy
from, like, a background
extra in "The Matrix," so.
So I'm going to think that it's this guy.
Oh, it's not?
This guy?
Yuelei: Yeah.
This guy is this super-famous
football soccer player?
So, I think I was right.
This is Shutterstock, though.
Hey, what do you want from me?
None of this means anything to me.
A legendary burger in the
US contains 1,610 calories.
Now, I don't know if
they mean 1,610 calories
with the fries or without,
so just keep that in mind.
According to the FDA, that is 81%
of my daily recommended caloric intake.
Here in the UK, the
original legendary burger
contains 1,375 calories,
which, according to FDA guidelines,
is around 69% of my daily
recommended allowance.
A lot of food items on the Hard Rock menu
are actually super high in calories,
including the baby back ribs,
which clock in at 2,433 calories.
Here in the UK, the baby back ribs
contain around 1,796 calories,
which makes the US version
around 35% more calorific.
More detailed nutritional
info for Hard Rock Cafe
doesn't seem to be available online,
but I did notice this
little tiny salt symbol
that was next to a whole bunch of dishes.
This indicates that the
sodium content of that item
is higher than the total
daily recommended limit,
which is 2,300 milligrams.
There's something about a fudge brownie
with vanilla ice cream
that feels very American food chain.
In the US, this dessert contains
1,122 cals.
I think it's worth it, though.
This thing looks really good.
In the UK, the fudge
brownie with ice cream
comes to 2,009 calories.
What we have here is the takeaway version,
which I personally do not think
contains 2,000 calories.
I think what they're referring to
is the in-restaurant version,
which is an enormous
chocolate fudge sundae
with loads of ice cream, sauces, and more.
In front of me now, I have a
starter of 12 chicken wings
with Buffalo sauce; I have the main,
which is the legendary burger and fries;
and I have dessert, which
is an apple cobbler.
Now, I would say this is
a fairly standard dinner.
I think it would be on the heavier side
for a dinner, but if I was hungry,
I could definitely polish off
all three courses, no problem.
However, if I ate all of this,
I would be consuming 4,819 calories.
I think those daily-caloric-intake values
might be outdated and vary
depending on the person.
I'm not a nutritionist.
I'm just a girl.
In the US, an order of Buffalo
wings, a legendary burger,
and a hot fudge brownie
would cost around $52.97.
Why in God's green earth
is this burger $20?
It looks good. Just not $20 good.
Hard Rock Cafe is a theme restaurant,
and I feel like with a theme restaurant
also comes pretty high prices.
I think that's because they're
kind of tourist-trap-y.
They think people are willing to pay more
because it's an experience
and not just the food.
In the UK, the same meal
would cost you £43.85,
which is $56.56.
All of this food for £43
is kind of a lot of food,
and, as we've discussed,
a lot of calories,
but also, I don't think I'm getting
that much value for my money.
I feel like even in London,
I can find better value elsewhere,
and I do think it's kind of being marketed
as kind of a tourist trap
or maybe kind of a
special-occasion treat meal.
Did you know that the first Hard Rock Cafe
was actually opened in London?
It was the Hyde Park branch,
and it opened in 1971.
It's pretty rare to come
across a Hard Rock Cafe
if you don't live in a major city
or tourist destination.
I think because of that reason,
they're not super popular here,
even though they are popular
in the sense that we know what it is.
There are only 34
locations in the entire US,
and six of those are in Florida.
18% of the Hard Rock Cafes
in America are in Florida.
But this is an international chain,
so you can find Hard Rock Cafes
in over 50 countries, including Armenia,
Nepal, Nigeria, and Poland.
Hard Rock Cafe does have
a very dedicated fan base.
There's a community of collectors
who will buy and swap commemorative merch
from the different locations,
including things like
the pins and, of course,
the iconic T-shirts and jumpers.
Some superfans even celebrate
Hard Rock milestones
like visiting your 25th location.
I think I've got maybe 24 to go.
Same. All we have to do is go to Florida,
and we can cross six more off our list.
They sell normal American fare,
which I can find anywhere,
like at a Chili's or an Applebee's,
chains that are much more available.
The thing that makes Hard
Rock Cafe special, though,
isn't the food, it's the memorabilia.
The first piece of memorabilia
donated to Hard Rock Cafe
was Eric Clapton's Lead II Fender in 1979.
Since then, they have
amassed quite the collection,
with 86,000 pieces worldwide.
Supposedly, it is the
largest private collection
of music memorabilia in the entire world.
These days, the memorabilia is
still either donated to them
or sometimes purchased through auctions.
There are some pretty
cool pieces out there,
including Elvis Presley's
24-karat gold leaf piano,
handwritten lyrics for
John Lennon's "Imagine,"
and, of course, One
Direction's iconic phone box,
which they used in
their album cover shoot.
I am so jealous that Harry
got to take a picture
with the One Direction phone booth.
I don't care if something
good happened to you.
It should have happened to me instead.
I did manage to get a picture
with one of Beyoncé's outfits
from her "Green Light" music video.
It's not as iconic as the
"One Direction" phone booth,
but it's something.
We have a quote here from one of the
Hard Rock Cafe founders which
we think is quite interesting.
It says, "The Hard Rock
Cafe Mayfair's grace
was becoming London's
first classless restaurant
at a time when a baker and a banker
could not commune, live,
shop, or dine together."
I think they might be
reaching a little bit here.
I do think that London in the '70s
was kind of in its punk era.
I think social barriers were
already being torn down.
We'd already had the kind of
hippie movement in the '60s.
I don't think Hard Rock
Cafe can really claim
that they were the only ones
to break down social barriers.
And there is nothing more
punk than the Hard Rock Cafe.
Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find the
differences between MREs
and ration packs in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
A US MRE is manufactured and packaged
by Wornick, AmeriQual, and Sopakco
and comes in one standard pack size.
UK MREs, or ration packs, as we call them,
are produced by Vestey Foods
and come in three portion sizes.
The standard portion is
this, a 24-hour ration pack.
You can also get a smaller version,
which is a 12-hour ration pack,
and our biggest portion
is this.
This is a 10-man operational pack,
which contains 10 of these
24-hour ration packs.
According to the Defense
Logistics Agency website,
a case of MREs, which is 12 meals,
weighs around 22 pounds,
or 9.98 kilograms.
So on average, one meal
would be roughly 831.6 grams.
The approximate weight of
one of these ration packs
is 1.75 kilograms.
We're going to weigh it
to see if that's accurate.
So, the weight of our 24-hour ration pack
here in the UK was
actually 1.49 kilograms.
This is a bit lower
than the promised 1.75.
I don't know if you're
a soldier in the field
if this is actually a positive thing
because you've got less
weight to carry or if you're
actually getting slightly less
food than you were promised.
In the UK, our ration pack menu No. 2
contains a chili con carne.
We're going to compare
ours to the American chili
to see who's getting more.
I do think I've lost a little bit in here.
And if I were eating this
straight out of the packet,
maybe tearing the packet
open, getting better access,
I could probably get that
closer to the 300 mark.
So, here are the contents
of a 24-hour ration pack
in the UK.
In total, we counted 29 edible items
as well as a few extra
bits, including tissues,
sanitary wipes, matches,
and other stuff like that.
Joe: We counted 11 edible
items in our US ration pack.
Here are all the military MREs for the US
not available in the UK.
And here are all the
ration packs in the UK
that you can't find in the US.
There's actually very few overlap
of specific meals in US MREs
and the UK ration packs.
Also, depending on which MRE meal you get,
they contain different
combinations of snacks and sides.
In both countries, official
MREs are not available
for sale directly to consumers.
Basically, when you get
a ration pack in the UK,
it will come with a
corresponding menu number.
The menu number will give
you a rough indication
of what you're going to find inside,
although there is a bit of variation.
So, what we've done here
is lay out the breakfast
and the main-course options
in order of the menus.
In the UK, we're currently able
to get hold of menus one to 10.
All right. We got the US MREs.
I think we got every menu, one through 24.
We're going to go through the entrées
and the breakfasts now.
I want to point out that for the US MREs,
not every single one came
with a definitive breakfast,
and some of them just had something
that was fruit or fruit-related,
which we assumed was supposed to be eaten
first thing in the morning.
Now, all of these can be
eaten either hot or cold.
I guess ideally, you'd
have them heated up.
We actually got sent this
flameless heating bag.
Instructions for use.
This is either going to go really well
or I'm going to give myself
and the "Food Wars" table
some chemical burns.
I'm going to do a chili
because we've already
got a chili opened and I kind
of know what they taste like.
Filter line only.
And then leave that for 10 minutes.
Oh.
Well, it works. [laughs]
I hope I've sealed that well enough,
because that steamed
up very quickly there.
So, while that does its thing,
I guess all that remains
is for me to try the rest of them.
Starting down here, remember
our good friend the chili?
Not bad. I would say as
average as chili can be.
I think, honestly,
I've never been in the military,
I haven't done any service,
but I used to camp a lot when I was a kid,
and I do remember going on
sometimes two-, three-week-long
canoe trips in Canada.
Couple days in, this is, like, gourmet.
You know what I'm talking about.
Like, your standards change quickly
when you're outside all day.
It comes with a cornbread.
This cornbread muffin's
actually really good.
Let's try it with the chili.
So, the breakfast that we got for menu one
was pork sausage and
beans in a tomato sauce.
This is kind of an iconic
British meal. I can't lie.
It's kind of good.
We're starting off strong. I like that.
Next up, we have a pindi chana aloo,
which seems to be a
potato and chickpea curry.
And then the final option
from menu one in the UK,
meatballs and pasta.
Do I have high or low expectations
for meatballs and pasta?
Yeah, I mean,
I think my fear was that,
like, pasta doesn't hold up
very well when it's kind of submerged
in a sauce and cooked for a while,
and I think that's kind of come true.
Meatballs are all right, though.
Menu No. 2, shredded
beef in barbecue sauce,
but also came with seasoned
black beans and tortillas.
So, I mean,
I don't know how you would do this
out in the field with no
plates and not a table.
And then the beans.
A military taco. Here we go.
These beans are rock solid.
The consistency's a little weird.
This one is the chicken and noodles
with vegetables in sauce.
Yeah, this looks like a
can of, like, chunky soup
or chunky stew before you heat it up.
This definitely should
be heated up before.
And this smell — oh,
my God, this is brutal.
If you had this
and you couldn't heat it
up for some reason ...
This is very bad.
The first potential breakfast,
the applesauce with raspberry puree.
Now we're talking here.
Oh, my God, that does
not taste like fruit.
That tastes like pure sugar.
There is fruit in it,
but it tastes more like
fruit-flavored soda.
This will definitely wake
you up in the morning.
Then we're on to menu two,
and the breakfast is a
raspberry muesli with milk.
Now, it says "with milk," but
there is no liquid in here.
So I think what they've
done is actually put
powdered milk in here,
and you add some water,
and then hopefully that kind of
turns into something resembling milk.
It looks very chalky and powdery
at the moment, without the water in it.
It says to add around 100 mils of water,
mix it, and then leave it
to stand for a minute or so.
But yeah. I mean, now that's
looking a lot more like muesli.
That's actually not bad.
I'm quite impressed by that.
There is a slightly noticeable difference
between that and real milk.
Then the mains for menu two,
obviously the chili con carne,
which we opened for the
portion-sizes section.
Not the best visuals,
but it's quite hard to make a
nice-looking chili anyway, so,
it's more about the taste.
It's not spicy. Pretty well seasoned.
And then menu two also has a rajma masala.
The longer I leave this one,
I think this is the first one
that has actually a bit of heat to it,
but not unpleasant at all,
just a nice warmth there.
This hits close to home.
Spaghetti with beef and sauce.
Oh, and it even came
with Italian breadsticks.
What do we think? It's not meatballs.
They had meatballs. We
only have meat sauce.
Breadsticks.
They're a bit dry.
They're the most driest
thing I've ever eaten.
These are so dry.
White chicken chunks.
Oh, no! It's just, look.
Yeah, just canned white chicken.
No, I would be so bummed.
Yeah, this is the worst one.
So, we got a beef taco
filling with Santa Fe rice.
Um, not horrible. Decent
seasoning, but yeah,
I think what's missing
for all these is cheese.
Then we're on to menu three,
and we have our first duplicate item.
It's another muesli for breakfast.
Now, this one, I'm intrigued by.
One of the main options in menu three,
steak and vegetables with dumplings.
A classic British beef stew
is kind of one of my favorite foods.
Having said that, I've opened this,
and it looks and smells like cat food.
Now, I've been eating most of
these straight out of the bag
because they've had a kind of
texture which permits that,
but this one I think we're
going to have to plate up.
This apparently is steak and
vegetables with dumplings.
Now, I started this section by saying
that all of these can
be eaten hot or cold,
and I do think that's true.
I guess the question is
whether or not all of them
should be eaten hot or cold.
And I think this one, just
immediately from the look of it,
I think probably needs to be heated up
because we've had our first
womp-womp moment of the episode.
[womp womp]
That's not good.
Beef strips in a savory tomato sauce.
Marinara sauce with meatballs.
Wait, so there's no noodles?
Just sauce and meatballs?
Oh, my goodness. Look how
little these meatballs are.
Look at these little guys.
There's no pasta in
there, just the meatballs.
Yeah, ooh. SpaghettiO
level of meat flavor.
Beef stew. Oh, at least
this one has noodles.
And this one came with a "breakfast"
that was grape jelly.
We're going to jump ahead
slightly to menu eight
because that's where I've
taken our hot main from.
And the alarm has just gone off,
which means it's ready to eat.
Once it's cooked, just tear it along here,
and then it's at the perfect height
that you can then just also tear this
and eat the whole thing.
It's changed the consistency
of this a little bit.
I think with the steak and
vegetables, for example,
I think that would change
the consistency a lot,
whereas this has just made it
a little bit more runny, but not too bad.
That was very hot, but
that's still really good.
I think this one I do
prefer heated up, actually.
It brings out a few more of the flavors,
a little bit more depth of flavor to it.
That's really good, and I'm so impressed
with this heating-pad thing.
The heating pad, as well as
just, I guess, warmed-up meals.
Thumbs up from me so far.
Macaroni in a beef
sauce. Well, that's good.
We got noodles! And the chili.
Oh, that's terrible. It
doesn't taste like anything.
Vegetarian taco pasta,
which is a vegetable crumble
with pasta in taco-style sauce.
Is this supposed to be "Zapplesauce"?
Who doesn't love a little applesauce?
Again, wow, super sweet.
With sugar, not high-fructose
corn syrup, so that's a plus.
And the last item from menu three
is a beef burrito-style filling with rice.
Sadly, this does not
come with any tortillas,
so you can't make an
actual burrito with it.
There's a little bit more spice
than anything else that I've had so far.
The texture of the rice
would be improved by heating this one up
because the rice is still
a little bit al dente.
Elbow macaroni in tomato sauce.
Granted, I mean, I know
I gotta heat them up.
Yeah, this one's all right.
Mango peach applesauce.
I'm liking the applesauce.
This would be considered,
I guess, a breakfast,
or ... it's fruity,
so maybe this you would
have first thing in the day.
Ooh, yeah. Ooh, this is really good.
Next up, we've got menu four,
and we're starting with
an all-day breakfast.
Apparently it differs
from the sausage and beans
because this contains some omelet
as well as some bacon pieces.
I think my only criticism
of this is that the sauce
that they put the beans
in is exceptionally sweet.
Carrying on through menu four,
we have a pasta Bolognese main.
I have a similar concern
to the meatballs and pasta.
I think that is roughly the color
that you want your Bolognese
sauce to look like.
I think when I looked at this
one, I was expecting worse.
Again, the vibe I'm getting,
particularly from the pasta dishes,
is very much tinned-pasta vibe,
like a tinned Bolognese.
And the last menu-four item
is a chicken curry with potatoes and rice.
There's actual decent-sized pieces
of what I hope is chicken.
Less flavorful than
some of the other ones.
I want to try heating some of these up.
You do this. And then
you put your MRE inside.
Sorry, if you can't tell,
we're adding water to this.
Here we go.
Real exciting stuff here in the studio!
While we're moving on,
so, we got one, two, three heating up.
The staff was able to make
this thing work. I was not.
I don't know why. We're moving on.
We have a cheese tortellini
in a tomato sauce.
Oh, yeah, look at this.
They got the whole tortellini right there.
Then we're on to menu five,
and we're starting off
with another muesli.
It's the third muesli
we've had in five meals.
The variation, I think, is going to
start to kind of run dry.
Speaking of a lack of variation,
meal five also has
another pasta Bolognese.
The different option from meal five
is a sweet and sour chicken with rice.
Good color on it. Nice
familiar orange color.
There's pineapple in
this. And water chestnuts.
I'm kind of impressed.
This is pretty good.
I'd say this leans more on the balance
of sweet rather than sweet and sour.
I think with the water chestnut
and also the pineapple chunks,
there's still some things
in there with bite,
which I appreciate.
Creamy spinach fettuccine
with egg noodles,
spinach, and mushroom in a cream sauce.
Ugh.
it feels like they're going a little,
I don't want to say overboard
because I figure you gotta
have a variety of meals,
but doesn't a fettuccine with
mushrooms in a cream sauce,
like, after a long day of
hauling stuff around and soldiering
and exhausting job and
carrying all this stuff,
just being like, "Ah, let's kick back
with some spinach, mushrooms
in a cream sauce," like.
The most colorful one so far.
I don't feel great. I do not feel good.
Next up is menu six,
which we've actually
covered all of already.
Starts with an all-day
breakfast, which I've had,
then moves on to another pasta Bolognese,
which I've also had, and
finishes with my old friend
steak vegetables with dumplings,
which I will absolutely
not be trying again.
This should be the
Mexican-style chicken stew.
Oh, and then they're saying
there's another "Tear
here to remove the MRE."
Very smart. So you got
a second spot to tear.
This is really smart. Second spot to tear.
So it's easier just to grab the MRE out.
All right, so the package is hot,
so it feels like this is much ...
kind of smooshing around a little bit.
So, they are still flimsy tortillas,
but it looks like they're
chipotle flavored.
Not as gelatinous, I guess.
Definitely better heated up.
Yeah, I like this. It's pretty good.
Next up is menu seven,
which, I don't know if
this was deliberate or not,
but appears to be a fully vegetarian menu.
For starters, we have a
vegetarian all-day breakfast.
I think the main difference
is that they've subbed out
the meat sausages for vegetarian sausages.
It's another one that
seems to be mostly beans.
It seems very fitting
that the British army
is powered by baked beans.
Makes you proud to be British.
It's got the same issue as before,
that the beans are just I think too sweet.
One of the main-course
options in menu seven is
the rajma masala with rice,
which I've again also had,
but one that I have not had is
a vegetable and chickpea biryani.
I like a biryani.
For those who don't know,
it's just various things,
sometimes meat, in this case vegetables,
cooked down with rice and
a bunch of Indian spices.
I've had much better biryani in the past.
I'm sure there are lots
of people watching at home
and recoiling in horror
at the thought of this
being a biryani, but it's OK,
and I think on the whole,
vegetarian menu, pretty good.
Moving on, we have the
chicken burrito bowl,
which comes in a bag and not a bowl.
Sure, a lot of it's just, like ... eh, no.
We got some heated up, so
you can see the difference
when it's not heated up. It's
just this weird gel cube.
And that comes with what
essentially would be considered
a breakfast, I guess, apple
pieces in a spiced sauce.
So, the entrée appears to be
a maple-flavored pork sausage patty.
OK, so just one block of — yep.
Ah, it is of course just this.
It's like a Clif Bar, but pork.
Not good. Really weird.
It tastes surprisingly bland.
A hash brown potato with
bacon, pepper, and onions.
Ooh, no! This is the most
cat-food-y-looking one.
Menu eight is another duplicate one.
We start with another all-day breakfast.
Then there's another chili con carne,
which I've actually already
heated up and eaten.
And we have another beef
burrito-style filling with rice.
A cooked beef ravioli, once again.
It, like, heated the bottom of it,
so you still gotta
massage it a little bit.
Like, this side is heated,
and then this middle
part didn't get heated.
It also came with
tortillas, which is funny.
This is what this looks
like, and it looks gross.
Menu nine starts with more muesli,
then moves to a new dish,
which is sausage casserole.
This is another classic British dish,
a sausage casserole.
Slow-cooked stewed sausages
with tomato, potatoes, other vegetables.
On the whole, the sausages
have actually been,
like, surprisingly good.
It might just be because I quite like
those slightly cheap,
like, prepackaged sausages.
And then for your other main course,
we have another pindi chana aloo.
This one, another hot one.
Oh, so it's just going to be a patty?
Ugh!
Yuelei: Oh!
Joe: It has a sauce, apparently.
It's grilled jalapeño
pepper jack flavored.
Comes with au gratin potatoes.
Au gratin potatoes? What
do you think of that?
This looks really rough.
Italian sausage with peppers,
onions in a marinara sauce.
Yeah, OK.
Menu No. 21 should be lemon pepper tuna
or tuna chunks in a bag.
We've just been informed that this bag
actually says white chicken
chunks, which we saw before.
There is a lemon pepper
tuna that we don't have.
And finally, last but not
least, we have menu 10,
which starts with an instant porridge.
The cooking instructions actually specify
that you need to put boiling water in it,
leave it for three minutes
to soak, and then eat it,
whereas all the other ones
are technically able to be eaten cold.
Menu 10 has a couple of mains,
one of which is another
beef burrito-style filling with rice.
And our final main course
is hunters chicken.
It's another plate one,
which I don't think is a compliment.
Doesn't look great, does
it? This is hunters chicken.
Traditionally, this is chicken
breast with some bacon,
some cheese, some barbecue sauce.
I think bits of chicken in here,
although I'm kind of
struggling to see where.
I think it's these small bits
rather than, like, a chicken breast.
Nah, that's really bad.
Beef goulash. Beef with brown rice,
spinach, carrots, tomatoes,
and smoked paprika.
A pepperoni pizza and cheese slice.
[groans]
Army pizza.
Oh, God!
That's so bad.
This has been brutal.
I don't know what it is about this food.
Like, yeah, some things tasted bad,
but most things just tasted OK,
but I have a headache and my
stomach doesn't feel good.
I noticed there's a
lot of sodium in these.
So that might have
something to do with it.
Tortillas came with this one,
the Southwest-style beef
and black beans with sauce.
Again, we have very few "breakfasts,"
but this one is mixed
fruit, which appears to be,
there's some chunks in there.
So you got a bag of mixed fruit.
On top of the mains and breakfast options,
you also get a dessert
in a British ration pack.
The options we got today
included a chocolate brownie,
a cinnamon cake, a vanilla cake,
a chocolate cake, or an orange cake.
The US MREs have an
assortment of desserts,
which looks all right: muffin
tops, cookies, puddings,
cakes, a bun, a toaster
pastry, cookies, and cobblers.
I'll try a couple of these.
I want to try the brownie
because it's packaged
differently to the others
and because I like brownie.
It looks a little bit more
cakey than brownie-ish,
but, uh, we'll see.
No. That's so dry.
Starting down here,
get a maple muffin top
or a chocolate banana nut muffin top.
Three different types of cookies.
You get a oatmeal chocolate chip cookie,
chocolate chip cookie, and
oatmeal cookie. That's funny.
And actually, now that I think about it,
we've got patriotic sugar cookies.
Could be in the cookie category.
The packaging was different,
so I separated them,
but I'm curious what a patriotic
sugar cookie looks like.
Oh, no, nothing.
These look like broken-up
Girl Scout cookies.
Is that a rocket? What is that?
I don't know what that is.
Do you know what that is?
Joe: Ah!
It's the Liberty Torch.
[eagle calling]
Oh, it's a bunch of different ones,
but they're all broken up.
Oh, well. These are pretty good.
Then I wanted to try
one of the cake options.
It's actually probably the cinnamon
that appeals to me the most, so.
I mean, this looks better.
It could be, again, slightly more moist,
but it's got a pretty nice texture to it.
There's definitely a
cinnamon flavor there.
In terms of, like,
shelf-stable baked goods,
this is a much better
effort than the brownie was.
This is actually perfectly edible.
I have an assortment of pound cakes.
Applesauce poundcake, lemon
poppy seed pound cake,
vanilla pound cake, marble pound cake.
Cinnamon bun
and a toaster pastry
that just feels completely
destroyed in here.
So, I don't know what toaster
you're using out in the
field, but all right.
And last, this package that
looks like all the other ones
is a cherry blueberry cobbler.
Eh, I think this'll just be fine.
Oh, that's colorful.
But it just looks like a
whole thing of, like, jelly.
Every ration pack in the UK
also comes with four
to five snack options.
We've taken all of the ones we got
from menus one to 10
and laid them out here.
Snacks. Our US MREs come
with a lot of snacks.
You usually find three or four of these
in each MRE in various combinations.
So, here we have a mixed-fruit snack,
which is, like, a fruit puree
in one of these handy little pouches.
First of all, I mean,
how bright do these look,
just compared to all the packs
you've been dealing with this whole video?
Like, I'm looking at these,
I almost want to, like,
turn the saturation down.
Peppermint candy rings,
and then you got M&M's,
Twizzler nibs, more M&M's,
Skittles, Skittles, Reese's Pieces.
Very nice. Thank you.
There are a few different peanut options
on the menus in the UK,
starting with barbecue
peanuts, some chili peanuts,
and the classic salted peanuts.
Dried fruit, dried cranberries, raisins,
and a trail mix that has ...
a nut raisin mix. For the trail.
Here we have cheddar cheese flavor spread.
In the UK, if you're having cheese,
you have cheese and crackers.
So I feel like maybe this
is supposed to be enjoyed
with some of these crackers down this end.
Down here, three different types
of energy bars you can get.
I've never heard of
the brand First Strike.
Not sure if that is a brand
that exists outside the military,
but you can get an apple cinnamon,
chocolate, or cran-raspberry energy bar.
Oh, geez, look at this thing.
A bunch of junk.
It tastes OK.
Next, we have a fruit flapjack.
Flapjack in the UK is a mixture
of oats, syrup, butter, and often raisins,
which are kind of packed together
to make a nice nutritious sweet treat.
This is an oatmeal block. I'm
not really sure what this is.
I'm actually going to open this one
just out of curiosity more than anything.
Looks like a sort of shortbread
biscuit on the outside.
Yeah, somewhere between
a digestive biscuit
and a rusk, which, for the uninitiated,
is I think an oaty biscuit
that's basically made for babies.
I feel like I used to steal rusks
from my baby sister when she was little.
Sorry, Annie.
Trail mix, granola, nuts. You get it.
Packages of either dry-roasted nuts.
Man, they really sucked this
thing dry. Look at that.
Same with this one, the smoked almonds
and jalapeño cashews.
Recovery trail mix with pretzels,
granola,
and this trail mix that
has beef jerky in it.
Wanna mainline your jerky?
US government has you covered.
Beef sticks.
Here we have a sachet of peanut butter.
We have three different
types of jam that we found.
We have apricot, we have plum,
and we have strawberry jam.
This is an exotic-fruits nougat bar.
Here we have a sesame bar,
which is basically just sesame seeds
held together with melted sugar.
Apricot oat biscuits.
A tropical fruit and nut mix,
as well as just nuts and just fruit.
Cheese-filled cracker, pepperoni flavor;
cheese-filled pretzel, cheddar flavor;
pretzel nuggets;
barbecue corn nuggets;
barbecue-flavored corn kernels.
So like corn nuts, right?
Baked snack crackers, cheddar flavor;
and the protein puffs,
ring-shaped, barbecue.
I feel like if you get these
ones, you've done quite well.
These sound fancy. We have
chocolate orange mini cookies
and coconut biscuit bites.
These sound like a more gourmet approach
to a ration-pack snack.
On to the breads and
spreads, we'll call it.
Multigrain bread, white wheat snack bread,
wheat snack bread.
I mean, how good are the
shots we have to get of these?
Everything looks the same.
And then this one, Italian
bread blobbity blob.
Got it. OK, great.
You have a vegetable cracker
or a regular cracker.
What do you want to put on
those breads or crackers?
You got chunky peanut
butter, peanut butter,
chocolate peanut spread,
cheese bread, cheese
spread with jalapeños,
cheese spread with bacon.
Here we have cheese and oat biscuits,
which I think are probably
designed, like I say,
to be eaten with the cheesy spread.
Next up, our biscuit browns.
I wasn't sure what a biscuit brown was,
and after tasting it, I'm
still kind of equally unsure.
It's, like, a sort of brown, like,
wheaty cracker-type thing.
For the fruit, you got
apple jelly, strawberry jam,
and I know there was a
grape jelly from earlier.
I don't know where it went.
But it looks exactly like this package.
And finally, we have a
cookies and cream bar.
[laughs] That's not what
I was expecting at all.
When you hear cookies and cream,
I'm right in thinking that
you expect Oreo, right?
Whereas this is more like a
rice crispy type of treat.
Doesn't smell of Oreo at all.
It literally smells of
a rice crispy treat,
maybe dark chocolate.
Doesn't taste great either.
The US MREs have an assortment
of different drinks,
both I guess regular temperature and warm.
So, the first thing I want
to do before we get into that
is point out that we have four different,
in the middle here, coffee drinks,
hot drinks, as you will have it.
This is a French vanilla cappuccino. Mm.
And I want to make it real quick.
And we saw how we heated
up the drinks before, so.
Here it also comes with
a hot beverage bag.
Pre-added the water.
So now I'm going to go ahead and put
powder in here.
This looks all right.
Mix it up a little bit.
♪ I have me cappuccino ♪
It smells like when the
VCR gets really hot,
when you watch, like,
three movies in a row.
Now we're on to the drink
options, which, again,
I think you get four of in a
24-hour British ration pack.
These all come in the form of powders,
which you mix with water and then consume.
They're also split into
four different categories.
We have just a standard drink powder,
we have an energy drink powder,
a fortified energy drink powder,
and we have an isotonic drink powder.
Having quickly scanned the
ingredients of both of these,
I'm actually not sure what
the difference is between,
say, an energy drink powder
and a standard fruit-flavor powder.
There's no caffeine in the
energy powders, for example.
I think most of the energy is coming from
the sugar content in these.
While that's cooking, let's
see what other drinks we have.
We got orange, lemon-lime, and grape.
That's definitely not grape
colored. It says grape on here.
I think it tastes like grape,
but also because it's blue,
I'm thinking blue raspberry.
While my coffee is cooking,
I also have different coffee flavors.
I get a chocolate hazelnut protein drink,
Irish cream cappuccino,
chocolate protein drink.
Regardless of the type of drink
powder that you're getting,
they do come in a bunch of
different flavor options.
I'm not sure if any of these
particularly appeal to me.
I'll try the tutti-frutti one.
I feel like of all of
these, sounds pretty fun.
Yeah, I was really hoping
that the color would be, like,
a bright blue or pink or
something, but just normal.
It's unlocking some kind of, like,
repressed alcohol memory, I think.
I'm fairly sure I've drunk a cocktail
to the point of oblivion that
tasted pretty much like this.
So, this is my French vanilla coffee.
Oh, yeah.
I'm not recognizing a lot of these words,
but yeah, this is nice.
And the last thing we have
here are beverage base powders.
So, these had electrolytes in them.
It's like energy drinks almost.
And then these, I think, are just,
these have lots of sugar in them.
So, we have lemon-lime,
orange, and tropical punch,
and then this little stick,
beverage base, orange type three.
Finally, every ration pack in the UK
also contains a bag of common items.
We'll start down this end,
where we have some matches.
Then we have some
water-purification tablets.
I think there are six of
these in here, actually.
And according to this,
you can purify a liter
of water per tablet.
That's pretty good.
I like that this is in
the essential-items thing.
We have some hot sauce.
We have some tissues,
as well as two alcohol-free hand wipes.
Then you have two tea bags,
two sachets of instant coffee,
four sachets of beverage whitener.
I think, again, this might be
something along the lines of
they can't legally call
this powdered milk,
but it is effectively a
powdered-milk substitute.
And four sachets of sugar.
Our US MREs have these
following accessories.
First of all, over here,
you've seen it a few times this
episode, the heating thing,
the heating bags to heat up
your food and your drinks.
Saw this the whole time, the spoon.
Every MRE comes with a spoon.
Now, did you notice I had a difficult time
kind of cutting into some
stuff? And I thought,
why don't they have anything
like a knife in here?
Of course they have a knife.
They're soldiers. They have pocket knives.
They come with a
concentrated beverage base.
This one is cranberry grape.
Over here is the coffee
zone, for the most part.
Bill's Brew freeze-dried coffee.
You can add it to hot or cold water.
6 ounces right here.
And you have your choice
of either Splenda or sugar.
Salt, if you need more
sodium on your food.
This is a coffee creamer.
Each pack of accessories
comes with two pieces of gum.
These are waterproof matches.
Spice up that food a little
bit, a little bit of Tabasco.
A little Tabasco guy. Look
at this little guy. Right?
A moist towelette and regular napkins.
In the US, MREs were first
introduced in the 1980s
and were designed to be
lightweight, portable,
and self-contained meals
that didn't require
cooking or refrigeration.
They were also intended to
provide the necessary nutrition
for soldiers in the field.
Early iterations of British ration packs
actually used cans.
It wasn't until the 1990s
that these were replaced with pouches.
Each MRE typically contains
around 1,200 to 1,300 calories
with balanced nutrition essential
to supporting the demands
placed on soldiers during
military operations.
Each MRE is said to have approximately
170 grams of carbohydrates,
45 grams of protein, and 50 grams of fat.
As we've said, a British
ration pack is usually designed
for 24 hours' worth of nutrition,
whereas it seems as if
the American ones are not.
We can assume this because
the average nutritional value
of an entire British ration pack
is somewhere between
3,800 and 4,200 calories.
Now, here's a chili meal from before.
We're going to go through
its specific nutrition.
Now, I want to point out
that the bag didn't have anything on it,
so I am learning about the
nutrition of these in real time.
The chili with the
beans, one serving size.
All this is 260 calories.
And this single serving of cornbread
with your chili, also 260 calories.
Your vegetable cracker is
going to be 170 calories,
and your cheesy spread is 120 calories.
Then the cheese-filled crackers,
the pepperoni pizza flavor,
240 calories for this one.
And if you're going to be sipping on your
lemon-lime-flavored non-fruit-juice juice,
that's going to be 130 calories
for the whole beverage.
A grand total of this many calories.
We've selected some items
which seem to match up roughly
with what you'd expect
to find in a US MRE.
Here we have the chili con carne main.
We've got some crackers
with the cheese spread,
some peanut butter, and
a fruit-flavored drink.
The total calories for
these items comes to 1,379.
The FDA recommends that adults consume
around 75 to 90 milligrams
of vitamin C per day.
Just two of these drink sachets
is more than enough
vitamin C for that intake.
We are not getting scurvy anymore.
We learned our lessons
back in the navy days.
Although it's also worth noting
the amount of sugar
that is in one of these.
In a 45-gram sachet of mango
and passion fruit drink,
you will find 40.5 grams of sugar.
That's 81% of your daily
recommended intake,
just in one of these.
Let's take a look at the ingredients
of the chili con carne in the UK.
Beef, red kidney beans,
tomato puree, water, onion,
red and green peppers, wheat
flour, calcium carbonate,
iron, thiamine, and nicotinamide,
modified maize starch,
salt, spices, spice extracts,
calcium carbonate, and smoke flavor.
The ingredients in here are
actually all pretty natural,
without any real artificial preservatives.
Our eyebrows were raised
when we saw nicotinamide
in the wheat flour.
Thankfully, it's not
some kind of nicotine,
it's just another type of
vitamin B3, aka niacin.
This chili with beans contains all this.
Looks like mostly normal stuff
until you get the bottom
of the list there.
Ethoxylated mono- diglycerides,
I have no idea what that is.
I don't think we've ever had
that in "Food Wars" before.
So if someone in editing can go ahead
and say what it's used for ...
These have a minimum
shelf life of three years,
depending on storage conditions.
The storage conditions for these MREs
I'm assuming were room
temperature the whole time,
so I'm feeling pretty confident
these are all not expired.
Similarly, ours have a shelf
life of around three years,
and after that, it's
down to the temperature
at which they're stored.
For example, this chili
was made in December 2021
and apparently is shelf
stable until around 2025.
"But how can these meals have
such a long shelf life?" you ask.
According to the USDA,
MREs are shelf stable
because they have been
commercially sterilized by heat
in a sealed container to destroy bacteria
that can make it unsafe or spoil the food.
Like food in metal cans,
MREs can be kept for a long
time, but not indefinitely.
The shelf life of MREs and ration packs
is pretty directly related
to the temperature at
which they're stored.
The cooler the storage temperature,
the longer they'll last.
Rations in a desert temperature
might only last a few months,
whereas rations at room
temperature or colder climates
can be good up to five years.
We're filming this
towards the end of 2023,
which means that our chili
con carne, for example,
is already around two years old.
I've gotta say, I don't feel
great after eating them.
However, I do think
that's probably more due
to the quantity that I've eaten
rather than due to the
storage quality of these.
Since 1981, the US menu has
changed about five times,
improving the quality and the taste.
It also has expanded the menu variety
and now includes vegetarian,
kosher, and halal options.
There also aren't many changes in the UK.
However, there was a recent
controversial change.
Chocolate bars were taken
away from British troops
serving in Iraq and Afghanistan
because they kept melting
in the desert heat.
They were replaced with the
much less popular peanut butter.
I can see how people would
be annoyed about that.
Harry: From portion sizes
to exclusive flavors,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Prime in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Let's start with Prime hydration.
In the UK, it comes in
a 500-milliliter bottle.
You can either buy this as a single bottle
or as part of a 12-pack.
In the US, our hydration
also comes in one size,
the 16.9-fluid-ounce
bottle, or 500 milliliters.
You can get it in options of one bottle;
an eight-pack, which
we did not get, sorry;
the 12-pack; and a 15-pack variety.
We also have Prime energy,
which in the UK comes
in a 330-milliliter can.
Just like Prime hydration, this
either comes as a single can
or as part of a 12-pack.
In the US, Prime energy
is a 12-fluid-ounce can,
or 355 milliliters,
and it comes in a single can, the 12-pack,
and a 24-pack.
In the US, our biggest
Prime hydration single item
by volume is this, the
15-drink variety pack.
Total fluid volume, 253.6 fluid ounces,
or 7,500 milliliters.
Our largest size is a 12-pack of bottles,
which adds up to 6 liters of Prime,
but that's still 20% less than
the biggest size in America.
And if you're going energy drink,
[grunts]
24 cans of these energy drinks.
This is 288 fluid ounces,
or 8,520 milliliters.
Our biggest Prime energy
item is, again, the 12-pack,
but remember that our cans
are slightly smaller than America's.
A 12-pack of Prime energy in the UK
adds up to 3,960 milliliters.
That's 53.5% smaller than
the biggest size in America.
Here are almost all of the
exclusive Prime products
you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
And here are all the Prime drinks
you'll find in the UK but not in the US.
There aren't any. Sorry, guys.
There are currently seven
flavors of Prime hydration
available in the UK.
However, all of them are
available in the US as well,
so none of them are actually exclusive.
That said, there are some subtle
differences in ingredients
when it's compared to the US,
and also, I've never had Prime before,
so I want to try all of
these, give you my thoughts,
and maybe rank them as well.
Here are currently three of the four
Prime hydration drinks
you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
So we got the lemonade, we got orange,
we have this LA Dodgers flavor
that might be just
specific to Los Angeles,
and there's a grape flavor,
couldn't get my hands on. Wah.
And here are all the other
flavors you can get in the US.
We'll start down here.
Lemon lime. I mean,
this, they're just going
after Gatorade on this one.
Wasn't that the first
Gatorade flavor, lemon lime?
Really sweet. Wow, that's really sweet.
Ice pop. But also, this looks like --
they have different names,
but I grew up calling them bomb pops.
I feel like I'm only tasting
the cherry in this one.
I think everyone who's
tried these has said it.
These are very sweet.
But, I mean, I'm kind of not surprised.
I mean, it's marketed towards kids.
Another thing I wanted to point out
is that I was able to find ice pop flavors
both in the UK version and the US version.
We're going to get more into ingredients
a little bit later on, but
I'll do a very quick taste
to see if there's any notable differences.
We'll start with the UK one.
And then we'll try the American version.
The flavors are broadly the same,
but the way that this one
kind of hits your taste buds,
it's very different,
and it's really weird.
When you consume a drink,
obviously you want to feel
like your thirst is being quenched.
You take a sip, and
there's something in here
that's actually kind of
drying my mouth out, almost.
I think if I had to pick
which one to prefer,
it is going to be the UK's,
and I'm not just saying that from bias.
Tropical punch. [grunts]
OK, I'm not ...
What the?
[groans]
All right, well, that's
pretty embarrassing.
Hope nobody's watching this.
I do like that.
No kidding, they're getting
progressively better
as we go through.
Can't screw up orange.
Mm.
Yeah, this might be my favorite one.
This is really good, and
this doesn't feel as sweet
as the other ones. Or am
I just getting used to it?
Like how your eyes adjust to the dark,
I think my tongue's
adjusting to the sweetness.
Of the many sports teams in the world
that have some sort of deal with Prime,
LA Dodgers is one of them.
Yeah, I've seen people on eBay
bidding a lot for these, so ...
Straight up, I don't
know what flavor this is,
but it's good. Do you want to try it?
My lips did touch it. Is it too weird?
We have a professional relationship.
Oh no, I've gotten used to it!
It's a good lemonade. As
far as lemon-flavored,
not-carbonated beverage, pretty good.
I was also able to get my hands on
one of the American exclusives,
the lemonade flavor.
I'm interested to try this
because the US and the UK
do have slightly differing
ideas of what lemonade is.
Obviously, in the UK,
we consider, generally,
lemonade to be a carbonated,
clear beverage, like a Sprite,
whereas in America, it's
usually just kind of
lemon juice, sugar,
and water combined, so.
It does taste a bit like you've let, like,
a Sprite kind of go flat.
You can probably keep this
one for the time being, guys.
Glowberry. It is supposed
to glow in the dark.
The label, not the beverage.
What the hell? Yeah, I
think that's the worst one.
That's really weird.
Meta moon. What is the vibe of this?
What about this says, like,
oh, that's so refreshing?
This tastes the way sunblock smells.
Strawberry watermelon, all right,
back to things I've heard of.
No, this tastes exactly like gum.
Bubblicious, like one of
those really fruity ones,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to start down this end
with the glowberry flavor.
Now, I did have to Google
this to see if glowberries
were an actual berry or not.
As far as I can tell, they are not.
I think it generally
refers to a berry flavor
and also the fact that the bottle
is supposed to glow in the dark.
I think we should put that to the test.
Charlie, hit the lights.
[laughing]
Not really glowing, is it? [laughs]
It's my first taste of Prime,
and it's not blowing my socks off, to say.
It's just a very artificial berry flavor.
Got a bit of tang to it.
Next up we've got strawberry watermelon.
I like that. The flavor I get from that
is almost more like a kind
of blue-Powerade-type flavor.
According to the label, the ice pop flavor
is supposed to taste like
cherry, lime, and blue raspberry.
Yeah, I mean, so far, the vibe I'm getting
is that they all just
taste of artificial fruit,
but I think in terms of,
like, balancing the flavors,
this one's done a pretty good job so far.
Maybe the most delicately
balanced flavor of the lot.
Next up, we've got meta moon.
Obviously, I don't know
what the moon tastes like,
and I don't know what the meta
tastes like right now either.
If there were a "Food Wars" meta,
yellow No. 5 would be S-tier right now.
Label just says this is candy-flavored,
which doesn't fill me with confidence,
because, like, which candy?
Tastes like Mark Zuckerberg.
No?
Like, at least these ones have had, like,
a fairly identifiable fruity flavor,
whereas this one is just
kind of generic sweet thing.
Then we're on to blue
raspberry, and one thing
that's immediately stuck
out to me is the color.
I think I was actually
expecting this to be
a more bright blue color,
but it's actually just kind of white.
It's quite a gentle blue raspberry.
I want a bit more acidity
from that, I think,
but it goes down very smoothly.
I do feel like I'm giving
Prime way too much credit here.
I'm swirling it around in a
glass like I'm a sommelier.
Maybe if we had a decanter
I could pour it out,
let it breathe a little bit.
I'm drinking too much Prime.
I'm going to be hydrated as hell.
I'm getting hopped up on Prime.
I need to go do a celebrity
boxing match or something.
Yeah? Joe, you down?
You and me in the ring,
the full 12 rounds?
I actually don't know who'd win that.
Who'd win the fight between me and Joe?
You back me? Charlie backs me.
Harry's vibe is very, like,
they're really always just
calm and reserved or whatever,
but that sarcasm that they
have over there, to me,
says that they're, like,
something's going on
underneath the surface
that they're suppressing,
so Harry strikes me as the type of guy
that if he got into a fight-fight,
he would just, like, black out,
and then come to, like,
in the middle of a field
at midnight with a
shovel, covered in blood,
with a corpse in his trunk.
I'll box him as long as it's supervised.
Moving swiftly on from
me and Joe fighting.
Next up, we've got tropical punch Prime.
Whoo! So, while I was
out in the US recently,
I was able to try Hawaiian Punch,
and that's basically exactly
what I'm getting from this.
And then finally, we've
got the lemon lime flavor.
Of all of these flavors, this is the one
that tastes the most
like it's supposed to.
If I had to rank them, I think I'd do it
in the following order.
I think my least favorite,
probably meta moon,
right in the middle here.
Meta moon is down there.
I think with ice pop,
they've just tried to combine
a bunch of flavors that don't necessarily
work together very well,
so I think that's actually
going to be my second to last.
I think blue raspberry is
going to come next for me,
and they lose points because
they didn't even try and color it.
I think next is going to be glowberry.
The bottle didn't really glow,
so maybe leave it in
the sun for a bit longer
if you're going to try that at home.
I think next up, we're going
to have tropical punch.
My No. 2 is lemon lime,
which means that my No.
1, strawberry watermelon.
My favorite's the orange.
In second place, I like
the Dodgers flavor.
Actually, now that I think about it,
I think I'm going to go here,
yeah. The lemonade's good.
And from here on, ice pop, eh.
I mean, yeah, lemon
lime, these are all like,
I'd grab any one of these.
These three, I'd say skip.
A little bit of flavor tweaking
or balancing might go a long way.
I think with some of
these, you wanted maybe
a bit more tang to them, bit more acidity,
maybe dial back the sweetness
on one or two as well.
I don't know if I would
necessarily pick a Prime
over a classic energy
drink, like a Powerade,
but I do think, in general,
if I wanted a sports drink
and I went into a store
and this was all they had,
I think I'd still be
happy to buy one then.
They're all fine, and they
kind of do that same job.
Next up, let's take a
look at Prime energy.
Now, while the Prime hydration drinks
are similar to maybe a Powerade,
these are much more similar
to a classic energy drink
like a Red Bull.
There is one exclusive energy drink flavor
in the US you can't get in the UK.
It is the original. That
just was announced this week.
Couldn't get it. Anyway,
here are the rest.
Yes, the UK also has them.
Most of them are similar
to the hydration flavors,
but there is a new one, orange mango.
I'm a bit apprehensive about trying these
because I don't drink energy drinks.
I don't even drink
coffee, I only drink tea,
and I think one of these contains
about as much caffeine
as three cups of tea, so.
We'll start with ice pop.
Chin-chin.
I think that does mirror the flavor
of the hydration drink pretty closely,
but I will say it tastes
better than, like,
a standard Red Bull flavor.
Strawberry watermelon.
I think there might be a theme here.
They just kind of taste
like fizzy versions of that.
Here's the new one, orange mango.
I get mostly mango. I'm not
getting much orange from that.
Yeah, not far off, like, a Rubicon.
Tropical punch is up next.
Yeah, I think that one's actually improved
by becoming an energy drink.
Lemon lime.
You could give me a glass of
that and a glass of Sprite,
and I'd struggle to tell
the difference, I think,
because it is just,
again, like, a carbonated
lemon and lime beverage.
Blue raspberry.
I actually think for a few of these,
just carbonating them has
actually made them better.
I think notably that was the
case with the tropical punch,
and also to a degree, I
think, blue raspberry.
One I could not get for
the time of filming this
was the ice pop.
Strawberry watermelon, though.
It's, like, sweet and tart.
Orange mango.
Somehow worse. Uh-oh.
So far, not good.
Tropical punch, OK.
Yeah, this one's good.
Lemon lime, ooh.
Yeah, it's pretty good, too.
Kind of tastes like Sprite.
Harry: Like some Sprite.
Blue raspberry, ooh.
Nah. Yeah, this one also has
a tart flavor to it that,
not that into it. So I think
I'm going to rank it like this.
Favorite was lemon lime,
really enjoyed the fruit punch,
blue raspberry is in the middle,
and then these two I wouldn't get.
I guess, wow, apparently the
strawberry watermelon flavor,
I'm just not digging.
Now, for the orange mango,
which was the worst,
something about it just
tastes like an armpit.
Ice pop, did not like
that one, I'm afraid.
Orange mango, fine, but
a bit too artificial,
and there are, I think, better
fizzy mango drinks out there in the UK.
Tropical punch and blue
raspberry were both improved,
I think, by making them fizzy,
but I think just in terms
of, like, flavor balance,
strawberry watermelon, undefeated.
One thing I will say about Prime energy
is that so far, when
I've been tasting these,
I feel like on the very
rare occasions when I drink,
like, a Red Bull or a Monster,
they have kind of a very
distinct flavor to them,
and even if you add flavorings to that,
it's hard to mask it completely,
whereas I don't really get a distinct
energy-drink flavor
throughout all of these.
Most of them actually
do just kind of taste
like fizzy versions of
the hydration drink.
I think it's actually quite impressive.
I think you probably could
drink them almost as a soda.
I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing.
I do think there's still
some room for improvement
with the flavors themselves,
I think particularly
down this end, of course,
but in general, I think they've done
a pretty good job with the flavors.
One product that we have
exclusively here in the US
are these Prime Hydration+ sticks.
These are like the
hydration flavors we have,
but in powder form,
and I think you can get it in
almost every single flavor.
I got two, four, six of the crowd.
Got six sticks.
OK.
Mm-hmm, OK. I mean, it
looks lemon-limey too.
I guess probably you're
supposed to shake it up,
and that's why you do a
water bottle and not a cup,
because look, it's all, like,
globulating at the top here.
Ah, very strong.
I think I could have cut
it with more water, but.
Oh, God.
Yeah, it's pretty close.
I mean, this is obviously stronger
because there's not as much water.
Sadly, the Prime Hydration+ sachets
have not hit UK shelves just yet,
although I can't say
I'm too mad about that.
I feel like, just buy
the drink, it's fine.
The price of Prime can vary wildly
depending on where or
when you are looking.
On the official UK website,
a 12-pack of Prime hydration
sells for £24.99.
That's around $31.82.
The per-bottle cost on
the website, therefore,
is just over £2.
In the US, that same pack is $29.99,
or £23.56,
so, not much of a price difference.
If you're not aware, Prime
is a brand of hydration
and energy drinks promoted
by the influencers
Logan Paul and KSI.
The two have amassed
a huge fan base online
through various ventures
on YouTube and podcasting,
music, and even wrestling.
Now, Prime is manufactured
by Congo Brands,
a company based out of
Louisville, Kentucky.
Paul and KSI are the primary
spokespeople for the brand.
When Prime launched over a year ago,
with KSI and Logan Paul
putting their celebrity weight
behind the promotion of the
brand, it was a huge success.
However, due to the
popularity of the drink,
a huge reselling market has emerged.
Prime came to the UK in June 2022
and was an immediate smash hit.
On release, Britain saw
teenagers queuing up
outside supermarkets all morning
to try and get their hands on some.
Places like Asda sold out
so quickly that they had
to implement a
three-bottle-per-customer limit.
Convenience stores realized
they could buy Prime in bulk
and flip individual
bottles for a huge markup.
Some, such as the
TikTok-famous Wakey Wines,
achieved infamy when they were caught
selling bottles or cans
for as much as £100 each.
KSI even had to step in at
one point and scold resellers,
saying that it was "not ethical."
It wasn't as bad over here.
It did fly off the
shelves for a little bit,
but I think it might've
had something to do with
the resale value of these
online was pretty good.
I've never seen anyone
drinking it, and, to be honest,
I got everything at Target
and online kind of no problem.
Now, currently, the LA Dodgers
limited-edition bottles
are pretty pricey on eBay.
I'm assuming, once again,
that has more to do
with its scarcity than its taste.
Even now as we film this, in October 2023,
the Prime market hasn't exactly
calmed all the way down.
For some of the more standard flavors,
the supply has now caught up with demand,
and you're able to find
them in most supermarkets
for the standard retail price.
For example, I was able to find the bottle
of strawberry watermelon
in Tesco for just £2.
However, for some of
the more exotic flavors,
the only places you can find
them are specialist candy shops
or niche resellers.
The only place I could
find my bottle of glowberry
was at one of those weird
American candy stores
which plague Central London.
This one bottle cost me £14.99.
I wouldn't have paid £18
for a bottle of Prime,
but you did expense it, so
you didn't pay for it either.
What is the most I would realistically pay
for a bottle of Prime hydration?
I don't know, 5 bucks?
You think 5 is high?
How much would you pay?
I've just been informed $5 is too high.
$1.50?! You can't get anything for $1.50.
What are you talking about?
Fine! I would pay as much
as Gatorade and Powerade
and all the other ades are for this.
It's hard to find empirical evidence
as to whether or not
the craze around Prime
has kind of died down, but
just from anecdotal evidence,
I really don't think it has.
Even when I was out buying
the Prime for this episode,
I would see kids in the
stores just taking selfies
with bottles of Prime
like it was a celebrity.
I think due to the
scarcity and the demand,
it's almost become like a status symbol
among certain generations of kids.
It's a race to see who
can get the new flavors
of Prime the fastest.
People will, I guess, empty them out
and just use them as water bottles
when they go to school, and again,
it's just kind of a way
to flex on your peers.
Besides converting their massive fan bases
into loyal customers,
KSI and Logan Paul have also been able
to translate this into
commercial partnerships.
Prime is now an official
drink supplier of the UFC,
the LA Dodgers, and Arsenal,
of which I believe KSI is a fan,
and they're also the official
sports-drink partners
of FC Barcelona and FC Bayern Munich.
We've seen other influencers capitalize
on their success in the
food-and-beverage space.
MrBeast, of course, has Beast Burger
and his chocolate bars, Feastables.
Emma Chamberlain has her coffee
brand, Chamberlain Coffee.
Now, according to Paul, in the first year,
the brand has cleared $250
million in retail sales.
Goodness.
Here are all the ingredients
for a Prime hydration
ice pop flavor in the UK.
These are the US hydration
ice pop ingredients.
The ingredients are
pretty similar overall.
The UK has slightly more coconut water,
10.5% compared to America's 10%,
but ours is actually
reconstituted from a powder,
whereas America's is from concentrate.
Prime hydration in both
countries, both zero added sugar,
but does contain artificial
sweeteners sucralose
and acelflame, no, that's not it,
acesulfame K, or ace K.
According to the Center for
Science in the Public Interest,
ace K raises health issues such as cancer,
hormone disruption, and
potential pregnancy risks.
Per Healthline, there is
also evidence suggesting
that acetoacetamide, a
compound formed in the body
during the breakdown of ace K,
may result in thyroid
damage in lab animals.
Now, ironically enough, the lack of sugar
may be an issue for the very
purpose of Prime hydration.
Electrolytes play a
crucial role in making sure
your body functions properly.
When you exercise or play hard, you sweat.
You lose not just water,
but you also lose important electrolytes.
Electrolytes are key to hydration,
and Prime does contain electrolytes
like magnesium and potassium.
But the low amount of
glucose may impair your body
from properly absorbing the electrolytes,
as glucose is useful in
transporting them to your cells.
Typically, you don't need glucose
to absorb electrolytes, but it does help.
Prime energy is currently
in hot water with the media
as well as the US government
because of its perceived
excessive levels of caffeine.
Here in the UK, our Prime energy cans
contain 140 milligrams of caffeine.
To put that into perspective,
a grande coffee from Starbucks
contains around 136.
Energy cans in the US, however,
contain 200 milligrams of caffeine,
which is a 42.9% increase from the UK can.
Because of this, Prime
is currently experiencing
a significant amount of backlash,
resulting in some shops
actually pulling it from shelves
in order to protect kids' health.
In July of this year, Sen. Chuck Schumer
called for an FDA probe of Prime
and said it was a "cauldron of caffeine"
that posed "serious
health concerns" for kids.
One Prime energy contains
200 milligrams of caffeine,
which is about as much
caffeine in a six-pack of Coke.
Says it right there on
legally the smallest font
you could put it in.
However, looking at the caffeine amounts
of some other drinks currently
on the market in the US
paints a slightly different picture.
Let's be clear: 200 milligrams in this can
is a lot of caffeine.
Pound for pound, it contains more caffeine
than Monster Energy or Red Bull,
but other American drinks,
such as Bang Energy
or Celsius Heat, contain
300 milligrams per can.
That's 50% more than Prime.
We don't have these in the UK.
I've never heard of
Bang or Celsius energy,
and they sound terrifying.
One distinction that Sen.
Schumer is highlighting
is that Prime is aimed at a kids market,
despite the fact that the can says,
"Not for children under the age of 18."
Now, if that is the case,
Prime still isn't the biggest offender.
G Fuel, a brand that appears
to also appeal to kids,
specifically in the gaming space,
has several drinks with
300 milligrams of caffeine.
They got flavors like
rainbow sherbet, snow cone,
hype sauce that contain
more caffeine than a Prime,
as well as celebrity-branded
flavors from PewDiePie
and someone or something
called One_Shot_Gurl.
Both have 300 milligrams
of caffeine in the can.
Where's the outrage for that?
A bottle of ice pop
Prime hydration in the US
contains all of this.
In the UK, a bottle of
ice pop Prime hydration
contains the following.
So in the UK, our Prime
has slightly more calories
but less sodium.
If you grab yourself a Prime energy,
I have the lemon lime flavor,
it contains all of this.
In the UK, the same drink,
albeit in a slightly smaller
can, contains the following.
So it's almost identical to America's,
although we have a little bit more sodium.
Harry: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Chinese takeout
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Here are all the menu items you'll find
at a UK Chinese takeaway that
you might not find in the US.
Here's all of the Chinese
takeout we got at our local spot
that you might not be
able to find in the UK.
We'll start with the appetizers.
In the UK, it's pretty common
when you order a Chinese
to order a few starters,
and you kind of eat them
alongside your meal.
One thing to point out,
almost all of these are beige,
and I think that's going
to be a bit of a theme
as we go throughout this episode.
A lot of British Chinese food
is just kind of beige fried
stuff, and we love it.
We'll start with an
exception to the beige rule,
with crispy seaweed.
It's actually got a misleading name,
because this isn't seaweed.
It's shredded cabbage
which is then deep fried.
It's always aggressively salty.
Sometimes you get a little bit
of fish flakes sprinkled on top.
I think this one is
basically just fried cabbage
with some salt powder on it.
When we have a Chinese takeaway at home,
it would pretty much be the
only green thing on our plates.
And here's what we got for
our exclusive appetizers,
starting with the steamed dumplings.
That's so good. I love a dumpling.
Another pretty iconic starter
is a chicken satay skewer.
They will take a piece of
chicken, put it on a skewer,
grill it up in a kind of satay sauce,
which is mostly peanuts,
and they'll serve it to you there.
We also have a bit of
additional satay sauce
for dipping as well. These are great.
They're always a little bit dry.
I think that's why you
have to have the sauce
on the side as well.
Next we have the scallion pancake,
which literally looks like
a cut-up little pancake.
I'm going to take a taste.
Yeah, that's really tasty.
I want to dip this in something, though.
I'm getting the urge to dip.
When I think of a
British Chinese takeaway,
this might be one of the main
dishes that comes to mind.
These are sweet and sour chicken balls.
So, the sweet and sour bit
actually just refers to the sauce
that it's served with.
It's basically just a piece of chicken
which is then battered and deep-fried.
Mm-hmm.
Now, these vary in quality a lot
from restaurant to restaurant.
If chicken balls aren't your thing,
then we also have the
option of a prawn ball.
Now, instead of a piece of chicken,
they take an entire prawn,
batter it, and deep-fry it.
Kind of like a tempura prawn,
but I think a lot heavier on the batter.
We've been locked in a debate here as to
if there's any difference
between prawn and shrimp.
It seems like sometimes
they're used interchangeably,
but maybe they are
actually different species.
I don't know if Nico,
you have any thoughts
on the differences
between prawn and shrimp.
There is actually a difference
between shrimp and prawns.
It's not just linguistic.
Shrimp are more common in the US
and tend to be smaller
with a more savory flavor
when compared to prawns.
Charlie's saying that when
he's had it in the past,
it's been like a sort of prawn paste
mashed up into a ball, whereas these ones
are just whole prawns inside some batter,
so I feel like I've
got a better deal here.
This is a fried wonton.
It's so cute. It looks
like a little flower.
That is so good and crunchy.
Next up, I did want to take
a look at British wontons.
I know you can get these in America,
but I thought there might
be some differences.
So, these ones are not
crispy. These are steamed.
Pretty tasty. Not something
that I would commonly order.
Moving on, we have the crab rangoons.
These are kind of a meme
now for some reason.
I don't know why. These
had a spike in popularity
just in general, but this
is what they look like.
Kind of similar to a wonton, but bigger.
Let's crack this bad boy open.
Oh!
Gorj.
The filling is just crab and cream cheese.
I get it, I think.
I get why it's so popular.
This is a banger.
When you talk about your
beige-food Mount Rushmore,
this has got to be up there.
This is sesame prawn toast.
We have four beige foods
immortalized forever in stone.
Now, if you order a full
English breakfast in the UK,
you're likely to find
some fried bread on there.
Basically, what Chinese
restaurants in the UK have done
is elevate fried bread by putting a layer
of prawn paste in the middle
and then topping it with
loads of sesame seeds.
These are delicious. I love these.
Moving on, we have the spareribs.
I have to admit, I've
never had a sparerib.
It's not something I've ever ordered.
These have bones!
That's literally a bone.
I thought I ordered
the boneless spareribs,
but I guess I ordered the spareribs
with the Peking duck sauce,
and they look and smell amazing,
so I am going to take a bite anyway.
Yeah, that's literally so good.
That is so good! Why don't I order ribs?
That's so yummy.
Now, I was shocked when I saw these
as an exclusive in this episode,
but our next one is prawn crackers.
These are another thing that you'll see
on pretty much every UK
Chinese takeaway order.
Even if you don't order them,
often they'll just throw
you in a bag for free.
They're just great for mopping up
bits of sauce or something.
You can also dip them in
the sweet and sour sauce,
and you kind of get this crackling.
I really almost hope
that we've made a mistake
in the script and that
you can in fact find these
on Chinese takeout menus in the US,
because they're great, and
you guys are missing out.
The last two items we wanted
to talk about were chips.
We have two versions here that you'll find
on pretty much every British
Chinese takeaway menu.
We have regular chips, and we
have salt and pepper chips.
As I'm sure some of you might know,
British people don't tend to have
the most adventurous palates in the world,
and there's usually a
lot of demand for chips.
Same with Indian restaurants
and Chinese restaurants.
Basically, they're just
catering to the demand
of the British public.
Also, it's very common to pair your chips
with curry sauce.
So, curry sauce in this sense,
it probably has some of
the similar flavorings
that you would find in a
katsu-curry-type sauce.
I would refer to this type of curry sauce
as chip-shop curry sauce,
and that kind of applies to
whether it's Chinese takeaways
or fish and chip shops.
Then we also have the
salt and pepper chips.
Now, salt and pepper
seasoning is quite common
at Chinese restaurants in the UK.
That refers to a seasoning mix
which is comprised of salt, white pepper,
and Chinese five spice.
They kind of take that, base it around it,
they'll make chips, cook
them most of the way,
and then finish them usually in a wok
with some chili peppers, some onion,
and some spring onion.
These are delicious.
Now, I will defend salt and pepper chips,
but they were kind of at the center
of that TikTok controversy
around British Chinese food,
which honestly is kind of
why we've made this episode.
I also got an order of fries.
Obviously these are not an exclusive
just to US Chinese takeout places,
but I just wanted to show
what they looked like here
versus in the UK.
Very bland. I don't even
think these have salt on them,
which is kind of interesting.
This is definitely one of those
Chinese takeout menu items
that feels very catered to
a different kind of palate.
I would say that I do not see people
ordering french fries pretty much ever
from a Chinese food place.
Something like this is probably for kids
who are picky eaters,
which I definitely was.
I was ordering white
rice and chicken wings
from Chinese takeout as a child
because I didn't want to
try anything else, but,
that's what this feels like.
Something to please the children.
I'm calling Harry a child right now.
Something to please the child.
Another British Chinese takeout staple
is a crispy aromatic duck pancake.
Now, it sits somewhere kind of between
an appetizer and a main course,
because, I mean, if you
gave me enough of this,
I would just eat that as my main.
It can be kind of
expensive, so I feel like
some people just get
a little bit to share.
So, it was neatly packaged for us,
but it comes in a few
different components.
Obviously, we have the
crispy aromatic duck itself.
These little crispy bits
of skin are amazing.
We have the pancakes.
We have hoisin sauce.
And then you have your vegetables.
In this case, we have
some julienned cucumber
and spring onion.
I'll do a little demo assembly here.
I feel like everyone's got different ways
of assembling, so don't judge mine.
Start with a pancake.
Get as much of that
crispy skin as possible.
Little bits of cuke.
Some spronions.
Hoisin is kind of a plum-based sauce.
Just nice and sweet.
Works really well with the savory.
Have some fun with it, you know?
Beautiful. These are sensational.
I've not actually had
one of these in a while.
Next, let's talk about the
exclusive soup options we have.
This is vegetable bean curd soup.
I should mention that I never order soup
when I get Chinese takeout,
but it's obviously going to
vary from person to person.
Some people like a little soup appetizer.
I'm not one of those people.
Although I love soup in general.
It mostly just smells like broccoli to me.
It doesn't have a super-strong flavor.
I feel like the broth isn't as rich
as I wanted it to be, but
the tofu is really tasty.
Next we have the hot and sour.
I've never had hot and sour soup before,
so I am interested to try it.
This smells a lot like
sweet and sour sauce,
so I assume that that's what's in here.
I'm seeing vegetables,
what I think is tofu.
It smells really good, so
let's take a little slurp.
The texture is not my favorite.
I think it's got the
texture of a sauce to me,
so sipping it like a
soup doesn't feel right.
But it does taste good.
And lastly, we have the egg drop soup,
which I feel like is a pretty popular soup
when you're ordering Chinese takeout here.
The one we got here is
chicken and sweet corn,
which I think is kind
of like the archetypal
Chinese takeaway soup here in the UK.
I won't necessarily go out of my way
to order one of these,
although I do think they're pretty tasty.
One thing to point out though
is the texture of these,
because if you're not used to it,
it can really take you by surprise.
There's something about a
chicken and sweet corn soup
in particular that's just so comforting.
We actually do have a corn
and chicken soup here too,
I just don't think it's as popular
as something like a hot and sour soup.
In the UK, we have a lot
of fried-rice dishes.
These probably could be
ordered as your main meal,
but I would say in the UK,
they're more traditionally
ordered alongside a
meat or a vegetable dish
and kind of enjoyed together.
We picked out a couple of options.
Here is the house-special fried rice,
and then also we have
the Singapore fried rice.
I just wanted to find out what makes this
the house-special fried rice,
because usually, it'll include a variation
of kind of things mixed in with it.
There's little pieces of chicken, pork,
and prawn in here, as well
as some spring onions.
The Singapore fried rice
seems to actually have
the same fillings, because I'm seeing
these little tiny shrimps in them.
I'm seeing bits of
chicken and pork as well.
I think this is supposed to be
a slightly spicier fried rice,
so let me give this one a quick try.
Not overpoweringly hot,
but definitely more of a
chili kick to that one.
Moving on to our fried-rice option,
we only had one, and this is
the young chow fried rice.
It's basically made with a bunch
of different protein options.
Looking down right now,
I just see spareribs,
I see chicken, I see shrimp.
Looks kind of good.
I've never thought of
eating multiple meats
at one time like this.
I would argue and say
that fried rice in general
is a popular food here.
I make it all the time.
It's such an easy dish to make at home.
And it's definitely popular
at Chinese takeout places,
but for some reason, we only
had one exclusive option
at this particular location.
I'm going to try to get a bite
with every single meat on it.
Oh! There it is.
It has a very odd taste when it's
three different meats at
once, but it's not bad.
It's actually pretty good.
Now, chow mein has to be
one of the most popular
dishes in the UK.
I think surveys have actually
placed it as the No. 1 dish.
It's pretty versatile.
I'd say usually, again,
this would be an accompaniment
to maybe a meat dish as well,
or you could kind of
just eat this on its own.
Personally, chicken chow
mein is my favorite,
and I think probably
most Brits' favorite too,
but you can also just get plain,
vegetable, or various other toppings.
Here we have the chicken chow mein.
It's effectively just a
stir-fried-noodle dish.
Chow mein definitely is a thing here,
it just isn't a thing at
this particular restaurant.
I'm sorry I have to repeat myself so much.
Let's talk noodles.
This is the pan-fried noodle,
this is the lo mein,
and this is the Singapore mei fun.
Opening this up, I knew
exactly what it smelled like.
It smells like curry, so there has to be
some sort of curry element in it.
It smells really good, so I
think I'm going to take a bite.
I've never had this before.
And it also looks like they use
a smaller noodle than in
either of these two dishes.
It's like those thin, is it,
like, vermicelli noodles?
Vermicelli noodles.
That's my daughter's name.
[crew laughs]
This dish also has
multiple proteins going on.
I'm seeing chicken, and I'm seeing shrimp.
I don't know if there's
anything else underneath,
but that's what I see right now.
The flavor's pretty good.
I don't know if I like vermicelli noodles.
I think this is my first time having them.
They're just such a thin noodle.
I like something chewier,
like the ones that come in the lo mein.
Once you get past the rice
and the noodle portions,
the Chinese takeaway menus in the UK
are usually categorized by protein,
so you'll choose either chicken, pork,
beef, or anything else,
and then you kind of choose a sauce
that goes with that.
For example, we can get
sweet and sour chicken,
but you can also get sweet and sour pork
and sweet and sour beef.
From each protein category,
we're going to show you
a couple of either interesting
or unique food items.
Let's start with chicken.
Here I have lemon chicken.
This is another one of those
that's probably going to be found
on pretty much every Chinese
takeaway menu in the UK.
The sauce is pretty good, though.
It's lemony. A little bit
sweet. A little bit tart.
Then here we have the kung po chicken.
You might also see this
referred to as kung pao chicken,
with that A in the middle there,
but it's the same dish.
It's basically not too dissimilar
to sweet and sour chicken
that you might find
on the menu at a UK Chinese takeout.
It's these dredged and
fried pieces of chicken
in a sweet and spicy sauce.
Kung pao chicken I think traditionally
also might have some peanut in it.
In the US, it's exactly the same.
Our menus are categorized
by the protein type,
but a lot of the dishes
are really different,
so you don't always get the same sauce
for, say, a seafood dish as
you would a chicken dish.
Let's start with the chop suey,
which I have never had before,
but I'm very interested.
You can get it with any protein.
We got ours with chicken.
And here's what that looks like.
The chicken looks a little pale.
I feel like this is a
surprisingly bland dish
compared to a lot of other chicken dishes
I've had from Chinese takeout.
It's definitely not my favorite.
Moving on to the sesame chicken.
This was a fan favorite.
I was told I had to get this.
I'm not a sesame-chicken orderer,
but my friends and coworkers are.
Yeah, it's so good.
Next we have orange chicken,
which, as the name suggests,
has orange in the sauce.
And this particular place
uses the orange peel
to season the chicken.
I've definitely had a lot
of orange chicken in my day,
particularly the frozen
kind from Trader Joe's.
So it is pretty popular.
It's not a spicy sauce.
It's definitely just a sweet, tangy sauce,
but it's very delicious.
And last but not least, we
have General Tso's chicken,
which is my personal favorite thing
to order from Chinese takeout.
You'll see it on a lot of
Chinese restaurant menus
here in the US, but it's not
exactly authentic Chinese food.
Shocker.
General Tso was a real general
from the Hunan province
who supposedly enjoyed eating a dish
similar to General Tso's chicken,
although this modern American version
would probably be unrecognizable to him.
The dish was actually created in the 1950s
by a chef named Peng Chang-kuei.
When he immigrated to New York in 1973,
he altered his recipe to
cater to the American palate,
which in this case means
he made it sweeter.
Peng Chang-kuei called
it General Tso's chicken
because he and General Tso
are from the same town.
Now we're on to the beef options.
Now, firstly, I have to shout out
what might be my favorite
British Chinese takeaway dish,
which is crispy shredded beef with chili.
One thing I've got to say,
talking a lot about textures
and crispiness here,
what you will often find from
Chinese takeaways in the UK,
they'll actually break a little hole
in the plastic container.
This is probably the first
thing that I'm ordering
when I'm ordering a Chinese takeaway.
What they do is they get
these little slivers of beef,
dredge them usually in
something like corn flour,
fry them up, and then
toss them in this lovely
sweet and spicy chili sauce.
I just love the variation you get.
Like, some of them will
be slightly chewier,
some of them will be crispier.
Flavors are great.
Next up we have some Szechuan beef.
Now, I really enjoyed hearing Tianran
talking about Szechuan flavors ...
Tianran: The Szechuanese-style
cooking with the peppercorn.
... when we were doing
the US vs China series.
Go check that out.
But I think Szechuan food
tends to be pretty spicy,
and they also use Szechuan peppercorns,
which give you this kind of
numbing effect in your mouth.
The beef here also isn't fried.
It's more just like
pieces of braised beef.
I'm kind of intrigued to give this a try,
although I'm worried
about my spice tolerance.
Yeah, that's pretty spicy.
It's very tasty, very flavorful.
And then finally we've got
some beef in black bean sauce.
I'd say this is a pretty
common one as well,
and this is one that you can also get
in different meat varieties,
so you can get this with the chicken,
with the pork, anything else.
Comes with loads of peppers as well.
Some chili in there, onions.
It's a nice, very rich sauce.
That's really good. That with
some rice, beautiful pairing.
We'll often actually get this one.
This is one of my favorites.
I feel like I've said that
about a lot of things.
I think I just order too
much Chinese takeaway.
There's a variety of beef
dishes that you can get
at Chinese food places here in America.
Today, we got the moo shu beef.
So it's got cabbage, some
mushrooms, obviously the beef.
Let's take a taste.
The beef in that is really,
really tender and delicious.
I actually really like this!
Seafood is also a pretty common option
on UK Chinese takeaway menus.
A lot of the options you will find
have similar sauces to some
of the beef or pork options,
but there are also a
few unique ones as well.
Firstly, we have salt and pepper squid.
You might remember the salt
and pepper chips from earlier.
It's basically crispy squid
cooked in that same seasoning.
Sometimes this might be
found under appetizers.
Today, they had it in their main section,
so we're going with that.
I love crispy squid.
The way that they kind of cut it
with this crosshatch pattern,
particularly in Chinese cuisine,
gives it a really nice texture.
It's not that chewy.
It's really flavorful, not super fishy.
Just to illustrate that sometimes
the sauces are the same in
different parts of the menu,
this is the pepper and
black bean sauce again,
but this time with squid.
Then we have a couple of
prawn options as well.
Here we have the king
prawns in oyster sauce.
And king prawns with cashew nuts.
While we have the prawn
here in its un-balled form,
let me get one of those out.
Nico, how does that look?
Is that a prawn or a shrimp?
Or neither?
That prawn kind of looks shrimpy to me.
It certainly does not
look like a king prawn.
That's not the king of the prawns.
In the US, shrimp is
definitely the most popular
seafood option when you
get Chinese takeout.
We have a couple of shrimp options here,
the Szechuan shrimp and a seafood delight,
which has shrimp in it
and I'm guessing other
delightful sea creatures.
That's just shrimp.
Is that what is delightful?
Or do they mean delight is, like,
you get a bunch of veggies with it?
Let's just try the Szechuan shrimp.
It smells as spicy as I
think it's going to be.
This is probably the biggest
shrimp I've seen today.
I swear I've eaten with a fork before.
Oh no, it's tail-on!
It's spicy, not as spicy as
I thought it was going to be,
but I'm sure the more you
eat it, the spicier it gets.
But that sauce is really, really good,
and the shrimp is awesome,
even though it's got tails on it.
Take the tails off.
We also got a shrimp egg roll.
Harry really wanted me to try this,
and I'm glad he mentioned it,
because I've never had a
shrimp egg roll before.
Just pork. That's what I get every time.
Do you see that one little
tiny piece of shrimp?
I feel like it tastes slightly
different than the pork,
not just because the meat is different.
Another item you'll see in
a lot of Chinese restaurants
in the US is egg foo young.
It's an omelet made with vegetables,
a protein, and a stir-fry sauce.
Whoa, baby.
This is a big omelet.
It smells really good.
It doesn't just smell like egg.
It smells like a lot of good stuff.
It needs a lot more salt, actually.
I wonder if you're supposed to add sauce
or something on top.
I think we're actually supposed to add
this gravy to it, so let me add that
and see if it helps with the salt factor.
This feels very UK-core right now,
me pouring this gravy all over food.
Better.
Still not great. I don't
know if I like this.
Yeah, egg foo young is interesting,
but I'm not sure British people
would really be going
in and kind of ordering
just an omelet from a Chinese takeaway.
I'm not sure how well that
would take off over here.
It's time for s-s-s-s-s-s-sauce talk.
Sauce talk.
If there was ever a time
to do sauce talk, it's now.
So, in front of me here,
I have all the sauces
that were on offer at the
restaurant we ordered from.
I'm going to go through them now,
explain what they are, what
they might be paired with,
and give them a try.
We'll start with a slightly infamous one.
It's British curry sauce.
The British went round the world,
took spices from everybody,
and this is somehow the only
thing that we came up with.
Brits love curry sauce,
or at least this iteration of curry sauce.
There's definitely some
heat there. Not a lot.
It's quite a gentle spice flavor.
There's something about the texture of it.
It's just really satisfying.
That really gloopy, cornstarch-y texture.
Goes excellently with chicken balls.
You'll often see Brits
drizzling this onto chips.
Chips and curry sauce is
a big thing in the UK.
Or you'll just see it drizzled
across your entire succulent Chinese meal.
I will say Joe really loved that
when we did our fish-and-chip-shop
"Food Tours" episode.
It's not just the Brits who can enjoy it.
Then we have another iconic
UK Chinese takeout sauce,
which is sweet and sour.
Depending on where you get it from,
the color again will vary.
That's a pretty well-balanced one.
The first thing that hits
your tongue is the sour,
then it pretty quickly mellows out,
and you get a nice sweet aftertaste.
Again, I think this is kind of intended
to be paired with the chicken balls
or prawn balls or
something else like that.
But I do think a lot of Brits
will just kind of coat
their entire meal in it.
While we're on the subject
of these iconic sauces,
I also have to shout out
the polystyrene cups.
I think Americans might
call that Styrofoam.
But these are really iconic.
This is the standard delivery
vessel for your sauces.
The restaurant that we ordered from
had two chili options.
Firstly, we have sweet chili.
Brits love sweet chili.
This is on the menu at
a lot of restaurants.
And then the next one
that we have is chili oil.
I'd say this one isn't
super-commonly found
on UK Chinese takeout menus.
Next up we have the black bean sauce.
Now, this is the same sauce
that you might have seen in
some of the dishes earlier.
Then we've got two more sauces.
First up, we have hoisin sauce.
Now, this is most commonly
paired with the crispy duck
that you'll find on UK
Chinese takeout menus.
It's a very thick dark brown sauce.
Again, gloopy sauces. We love it.
I think the main
ingredient in hoisin sauce,
or one of the main ingredients, is plum.
So you get this real sweetness from it,
which works very well
with the savory duck meat
and other things on the menu.
And then finally we have barbecue sauce.
Now, I was a little bit confused
when I saw this on the menu,
because barbecue sauce in
the kind of Western sense,
so like a Texas barbecue
sauce, for example,
does not look like this, and I think
that's what I was expecting.
But I think what's
actually being delivered
is more of a Chinese-style barbecue sauce.
What this one makes me think of is more
when you eat, like, a char
siu pork bun, for example.
Because while it is barbecuey,
it's still got some sweetness to it.
There's Chinese five spice in here.
But if you're expecting,
like, Heinz barbecue sauce,
that's not it.
I think out of all of these ones,
the one I would reach for the most
would be the sweet and sour sauce.
It's because I'll almost always order
the chicken balls when I'm making
a Chinese takeout order in the UK,
and one of these will come with it.
Yeah, I think in the UK,
it's kind of just the definitive sauce,
closely followed by curry.
I think that's one of
the biggest differences
between Chinese takeout
in the US and the UK.
Our takeout comes with the
sauce already incorporated,
for the most part.
You do get a mix, though,
of tiny little sauce packets like this.
So, we've got soy sauce,
duck sauce, which is so good.
It's kind of just a sweet sauce.
We have mustard usually,
which I'm not seeing here.
But you do get mustard.
And hot sauce.
I'm pretty sure there are more,
but that's just what we have right now.
And then we have a couple little cups of,
this looks like a paste.
I think that this is a
little tiny container
of oyster sauce, and this
is just a little container
of extra soy sauce, probably for dipping.
If you do not have a drawer
full of these sauces,
I don't know what you're doing.
I feel like everybody has
that drawer in their house
that's filled with random
sauce packets like this.
Now that we've covered
every item individually,
what I wanted to do was
show you my ideal plate
of British Chinese takeaway food.
You might have seen these
on TikTok or elsewhere,
as these kind of broke
the internet a while ago,
but I'm going to show you my version.
I need some chow mein.
The amount of carbs that
might end up on this plate
could be alarming to some,
because we're going to go noodles.
We're also going to go rice.
You know we're going to get
the salt and pepper chips involved.
Then I want a healthy portion
of my crispy chili beef.
I'm going to want some seaweed on here.
Some of this prawn toast.
Definitely a couple of spring rolls.
And of course our prawn crackers as well.
So generally speaking, this
is a pretty normal plate
of Chinese takeaway food
for a British person.
But we're not done there.
The final step, of course,
is to add our sauces.
Yes, that's sauces plural,
because we're going to be
adding both the curry sauce
and the sweet and sour sauce to this.
And honestly, I'm not discriminating here.
This is going pretty
much on the entire meal.
And of course our sweet and sour sauce.
Love it or hate it, that
is your typical plate
of British Chinese takeaway food.
I think I've done a pretty good job there.
British people, please feel
to agree or disagree with me
in the comments below.
Nico, I've got to hear
your thoughts about this.
Would you eat this?
Let me stop you right there.
Why do you guys sauce the whole plate?
Like, doesn't the whole plate just then
taste like that sauce?
You want everything to taste
exactly like that sauce?
Bone app the teeth.
Now let's make up an American plate
of Chinese takeout with
a bunch of staple foods
that I think are pretty
nationally beloved, I would say.
Let's start with our sides,
our little appetizers.
So, we'd probably throw a
couple of wontons on there.
I'd also do some type of roll.
I would usually do an egg roll,
but all we've got left are spring rolls.
Next, you'd have your rice.
I prefer white rice.
I just think it's really easy to pair
with any sort of entrée.
OK, I wouldn't normally eat
the full container of rice,
but we're going to keep it on the plate.
We've got to get some chicken.
You definitely need a side of veg,
so we're going to do broccoli,
because I feel like that's literally
at every single Chinese restaurant,
they have broccoli on the side.
If you ignore the huge
mountain of white rice,
I think this looks pretty appetizing.
The last thing I would add to this plate
is probably some lo
mein, so let's do that.
I didn't mention these before,
but these little fried,
I think they're fried noodle pieces.
They come with soups,
so you can just throw them in your soup.
Have them with your soup.
They're just good to snack on.
I think this looks like a
pretty appetizing plate.
This is probably the point
where folks in the UK
would douse their plate in sauce.
I would do things a little differently.
I really like dipping egg rolls
into the duck sauce, which is this one.
It's so good.
And some people put sauce, I think,
over their rice and stuff.
So we have our white rice, our wontons,
our fried noodles, some spring rolls,
a side of broccoli, sesame chicken,
and the lo mein, which I
think, this kind of sums up
what a typical order
from a Chinese food place
would look like here in America.
If it doesn't look like what
you would order, sorry, babe.
I don't know what to tell you.
This is just what I think.
I can't even believe I
didn't mention it yet.
You have to get a can of Coke on the side.
Any soft drink really will do.
I just think you need a can of soda
with your Chinese takeout.
It's just, it's a sensation like no other.
It goes together.
In the UK when we order
food to be delivered,
we say we're ordering "a takeaway"
rather than ordering "takeout."
Also in the UK, we tend not to bother
adding with the words "food" or "takeaway"
to the type of food we're eating.
For example, if we're
ordering Chinese takeout,
most Brits will just say that
we're having "a Chinese."
Same applies for maybe Indian food,
when you have "an Indian,"
or even a full English breakfast.
In the US we call it "takeout."
They obviously both mean the same thing,
but that's just our
preferred way of saying it.
We also say "Chinese
food" or "Chinese takeout"
rather than just "a Chinese."
We also wanted to look at how each country
packages its food.
In the UK, you might
find your Chinese food
in one of these foiled
boxes with a paper lid.
The other most common form of packaging
is one of these clear plastic tubs.
And then finally for
your appetizer options,
such as some spring rolls,
which we've got here,
they generally will just
come in a paper bag.
I've always seen those
folded cardboard boxes
in American TV shows, and
they do look pretty cool,
I have to say.
Also the cute little takeout boxes
are something that I
feel like we see a lot
maybe in media when someone
orders Chinese food,
but they're not super, super common.
Mostly the food comes in
these kinds of containers,
which is like a black
Tupperware with a clear top.
These are usually reserved for the rice,
maybe the lo mein, but it's not reserved
for all of the food options.
These boxes were actually
inspired by Japanese origami.
Frederick Weeks Wilcox
was the first person
to introduce the paper pail
box in the 19th century,
to carry raw oysters.
He created a patent for it
and called it a "paper pail,"
which it basically is. It's
like a cute little pail.
In the UK and the US, portion sizes
and menu items will vary slightly
depending on the different
restaurants that you go to.
But we did want to compare a
couple of standard menu items
in the US and the UK
to see who might be
getting bigger portions.
One iconic appetizer from a
Chinese takeaway in the UK
is the spring roll.
The restaurant that we ordered from
serves these in a portion size of six.
In the US, spring rolls are
made a little bit differently.
They're made with rice paper,
and they have thinly sliced
vegetables on the inside.
This particular Chinese
restaurant only gave us two,
but I have ordered from some
places that give you more.
It just depends on where you order from.
We do have egg rolls, which
are kind of similar to the UK.
These come in only one
size, as far as I know,
but depending on what
place you order from,
they could be a little bit bigger,
a little bit smaller than this.
My local place, they're actually
a little bit bigger than this size.
In the UK, our egg fried
rice only came in one size.
I don't want to weigh
this outside of the box,
so I'm just going to weigh it in the box.
This is a mountain.
All of this rice just came out
of this tiny little container.
So, this is what our
fried rice looks like.
At this particular restaurant,
they only had one size of this fried rice,
but I have seen places
do small and large sizes.
All right, let's weigh
this mountain of rice.
Harry: It's, like, just
maxed out the scales.
Nico: That's a lot of rice.
We do have chicken included in that.
Just letting you know.
And we did weigh the plate beforehand,
so that's not part of this weight.
The restaurant that we
ordered from had chow mein
in two different sizes, regular and large,
although the large was only available
with certain varieties.
So this is a chicken
chow mein regular size,
and this is their house-special
chow mein in a large size.
We do have chow mein here in America,
but we didn't have it at
this particular restaurant.
We do have pan-fried noodles,
which I think are similar-ish,
so we're going to weigh these.
Harry: Although I feel
like it might once again
be slightly too heavy for the scales.
Moving on to sweet and sour chicken.
That is a tried and true
classic with takeout.
I think that I'm supposed
to sauce it myself,
which isn't the norm for me.
In my experience getting Chinese takeout,
everything is already sauced.
You don't need to add anything.
This time, they came without sauce,
so we're just going to add it ourselves.
In the UK, our sweet and sour
chicken came in one size.
In the UK, this consists of
little fried pieces of chicken,
peppers, onions, and also pineapple.
I'm getting worried that I think
I was supposed to dip
the individual pieces
into sauce and eat it like that.
I've never ordered this.
I just know it's a
common takeout item here.
But I already poured
the sauce all over it,
so let's just weigh it
and see how much it is.
As we mentioned before,
each Chinese restaurant
is unique as to how they
prepare and cook their food,
so it's kind of impossible to know
exactly what's going into each dish.
One ingredient that we did
want to highlight, however,
as it's commonly associated
with Chinese food,
is MSG, or monosodium glutamate.
In 1907, a Japanese
chemist named Kikunae Ikeda
discovered a substance called glutamate,
also known as umami.
He later broke that
substance down into MSG.
MSG is a seasoning and food enhancer
that gives a rich, savory flavor.
MSG is actually very
commonly found in fast foods
including Chick-fil-A, snack
foods including Doritos,
and naturally occurs in some cheeses.
MSG has been recognized as
safe by the FDA several times,
and only contains a third
of the sodium content
of table salt. So why's
it got such a bad rap?
In 1968, The New England
Journal of Medicine
published a letter titled
"Chinese Restaurant Syndrome."
In it, a doctor describes his experiences
after eating at Chinese restaurants,
citing symptoms like "numbness
in the back of the neck,"
"general weakness," and "palpitations."
The blame was placed on MSG,
and the Chinese-restaurant-syndrome
myth quickly spread.
The phrase even ended up in
the Merriam-Webster dictionary.
Despite there being no evidence
that MSG was dangerous,
there was still a public panic around it.
Chinese restaurants in
particular were deemed unhealthy.
Thankfully, the use of MSG is
much more normalized today,
although the xenophobic
misinformation from the 1960s
does still linger.
If you Google "MSG," some of
the suggested search terms
include things like, "Why
are Americans afraid of MSG?"
and, "Is MSG a neurotoxin?"
Short answer, no, it's not.
The first Chinese restaurants
to appear in the UK
were called eating houses.
They would serve Chinese sailors
who would dock in British ports.
This goes as far back as the 19th century
when Hong Kong was part
of the British empire.
Notable locations for
this included Limehouse,
which is part of the East End of London
and was actually where the
original Chinatown was.
The East End of London
was particularly hit
by bombing raids in the Second World War,
which caused Chinatown
to relocate to Soho,
where it is today.
The first recorded Cantonese
restaurant in London
was a place called Cathay,
and it was opened in 1908.
It was opened by a former ship's chef,
a guy called Chung Koon.
It was Chung Koon's son
who opened a restaurant
in Bayswater decades later,
which might have been the kind of origin
of the Chinese takeaway in London.
Apparently, the food was so popular
that if customers couldn't get a table,
they would simply ask for the food to go.
Chung Koon's restaurant, Maxim,
had a very popular dish consisting of pork
and a sweet and sour sauce called jar jow.
While the origins of the dish
are specifically Cantonese,
it just became known as
Chinese food to Britons.
The first known Chinese
restaurant in the US
was called Canton and opened
in 1849 in San Francisco.
The 1850s saw the appeal of the Gold Rush,
so to escape worse conditions in China,
there was a flood of Chinese
immigrants in this time.
Restaurants began popping
up to feed Chinese workers
who missed their cuisine from home,
modifying their favorite dishes
using ingredients that
they could find in the US.
In 1882, the Chinese Exclusion Act
forbade Chinese immigrants
from coming to America.
An exception was made for restaurateurs,
who could apply for merchant visas,
which saw a boom in Chinese restaurants
opening up in the 1910s.
Any new restaurants that opened
had to be considered "high-grade"
to be within the 1882 act,
so the owners lavishly
decorated the restaurants,
and by 1943, the act was revoked.
During this period,
dishes such as chop suey
and egg foo young were
popularized across the country,
especially the spread of chop suey houses.
Chop suey was made from food scraps.
Its name basically means leftovers.
Male migrants who came over from China
had little to no kitchen skills,
and ingredients were different
from those back home,
so they threw together
what they could find,
creating a dish that
was very easy to make.
Chop suey was a popular
Chinese American dish
up until the 1960s, after
which General Tso's chicken
kind of became the new popular thing.
Also during this time,
Chinese food began to be
preserved in cans for
pickling and freezing
because the Great
Depression meant that people
were looking for food
that was more affordable.
Popularizing the chop suey
houses was a turning point
for integrating Chinese
cuisine into American culture,
even if the dish was
eventually less popular.
Chinese food increased
in popularity in the UK
during and after World War II.
Recipes for Chinese cakes
as well as other simple
Chinese recipes were
introduced to Brits by the BBC,
and as some Brits returned
from being stationed
in the Far East, they
brought back with them
a taste for Chinese cuisine.
An influx of Cantonese immigrants
arriving from Hong Kong in the 1950s
brought with it a wave of
Chinese restaurants to the UK.
These restaurants really
blew up in popularity.
The restaurants grew so popular, in fact,
that Billy Butlin introduced
chop suey and chips
to the restaurant menus
at his holiday camps.
One trend that you also saw
was Chinese families taking over
old fish and chip restaurants.
This is why you still see things
like fish and chips or
battered sausage and chips
on the menu at some Chinese restaurants.
Around 1960, The Mandarin
opened in San Francisco,
introducing Americans to
Chinese food beyond chop suey,
like hot and sour soup and pot stickers.
Cecilia Chiang, the
owner of the restaurant,
wasn't sure what food
customers would want,
so she added over 300 items to the menu.
President Nixon's trip to China in 1972
began to normalize relations
between the countries,
and Americans were influenced
to try more Chinese food.
In 1989, the National
Restaurant Association
concluded that Chinese food was actually
the most frequently consumed
cuisine across the country,
and over the next few decades,
the number of Chinese restaurants
went up by the thousands.
In 2007, there were over 43,000.
In the US today, there are over
23,000 Chinese restaurants.
In the 1950s, there were
only 36 Chinese restaurants
in the UK, but the next few decades
saw that number rapidly ascend.
By the late 1990s, that number
had risen to over 5,000.
Today, there are a little over 7,000
Chinese restaurants up and down the UK.
According to a survey, Chinese food
is the second-most-popular
cuisine in the US,
right behind pizza, as of June 2023.
A 2001 poll said that Chinese food
was British people's
favorite foreign cuisine.
Harry: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Cadbury products
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, classic Dairy Milk chocolate
comes in a bunch of sizes.
The smallest one isn't sold individually,
but it's one of these
selection-box bite-size pieces.
Then we move up to one
of these little bars.
These are sold mostly
as a snack for children,
and they weigh 18 grams each.
Then we have a multipack
bar, which weighs 33.5 grams.
Then we have what I would
say is the standard bar,
which is 45 grams.
If you're feeling hungry,
you can have a duo bar.
As you can see by the
crease in the middle,
it's kind of separated
into two smaller bars,
and in total it weighs 54.4 grams.
In terms of standard Dairy Milk,
you may also be able
to find a 95-gram bar.
We actually found a
90-gram bar of Caramilk.
The portion size varies slightly depending
on what type of chocolate you're getting.
Moving more in towards the larger sizes,
we have a 110-gram bar of Dairy Milk.
Up from that, we have a 180-gram bar.
Our second-biggest size
is this 360-gram bar.
And finally, our biggest size is this one.
That's 850 grams of Dairy Milk.
In the US, our Dairy Milk
bars come in one size,
the 3.5-ounce, or 99.2-gram, bar.
Now, this bar right next
to it, the Caramello,
is actually 4 ounces, or 113.4 grams.
Right here in the middle,
there's a fruit and nut size
that's 5.4 ounces, or 153 grams.
I couldn't get it in time.
But our, I guess, biggest
size, or other size, is this,
a bag of miniatures,
where it is an 8-ounce,
or [227]-gram, bag, but it's
all these little guys in there.
Our Cadbury bar, the 99.2-gram bar,
comes in 18 squares per bar.
If you divide it up,
it's 6 grams per square.
For comparison, we'll take
a look at our 110-gram bar
of Dairy Milk in the UK.
One of these bars has
24 individual squares.
We're going to find out how
much one of those weighs.
So, according to our slightly
inaccurate analog scales,
one square weighs around 6 grams.
Although if we divide
the 110 figure by 24,
we end up with around 4.5,
so somewhere between there.
So there's no difference.
Good on you, Cadbury.
Here are all the Cadbury
products from the UK
that you won't find in the US.
And here are all the
Cadbury products from the US
you won't find in the UK.
This is going to be an easy one for me.
Now, I want to remind the audience
that this is for Cadbury products produced
in our respective countries.
Yes, all this stuff is
available on Amazon. We know.
Now, obviously we have a ton
of exclusive products here in the UK,
so we're going to break
them down into categories.
We'll start with standard Dairy Milk bars
but with different flavorings.
We're going to start off with a bang here
with what's possibly my
favorite just standard
Dairy Milk bar, which is Cadbury wholenut.
It's basically fruit and nut
but with none of that
gross fruit in there.
It's just the nuts.
Fruit and nut, wholenut.
Now, depending on what
time of year you're looking
for your Cadbury in the supermarket,
you might be able to
find orange Dairy Milk,
but because we're in the
buildup to the festive season,
we got winter orange crisp instead.
Chocolate and orange is kind
of a beloved flavor combination
here in the UK. I think a
lot of people will think
of Terry's chocolate oranges,
but Cadbury's are getting
in on the act too.
Next up, we have Cadbury Dairy Milk Oreo.
You might see a few of
these as we go through.
They seem to have some kind
of partnership going on
with Oreo because there's
actually quite a few
Dairy Milk x Oreo products.
I'll open this one up
because it's actually
quite cool what they've done, to be fair.
From the outside, it looks
just like a standard piece of Dairy Milk,
but if you see, they've actually
filled it with Oreo cream.
But they also put little
pieces of the biscuit in,
so you get these crunchy bits as well.
If the Cadbury Dairy Milk Oreo
somehow isn't sweet enough for you,
you can also get a white
chocolate Oreo bar.
We're sticking with the classics here,
and we're moving on to Dairy Milk caramel.
Now, I know I said that this
might have been too sweet
for me, but I actually do
really like the caramel bars.
So, what you get is Dairy Milk chocolate,
but then you have this quite
liquidy caramel on the inside.
The caramel, it is
sweet, but it's not like,
it's not like you're just
tasting sugar, you know?
There is something else going on there.
We did see that in the US,
you guys have Caramello.
Is that kind of the same thing?
Joe, what do you think?
Hi, Harry, and, yes, we don't
have the Dairy Milk caramel.
We have the Dairy Milk Caramello.
I remember Caramello for
a while was a US brand.
I remember the commercials. It went like,
♪ Caramello ♪
So that's yours. Let's
take a look at ours.
Here's ours. It's already
kind of coming out there.
It's caramel. Heavy, rich, I guess.
Yeah, can't really get a straight answer,
if Cadbury just bought Caramello in the US
and repackaged it or what,
but it looks like it's
probably relatively the same.
Sticking with the caramel theme,
we now have the new salted caramel bar.
I feel like, I don't know if
this is the case in the US,
but there's been a real
salted caramel takeover
in the past couple of years, to the point
where it's very hard to
find unsalted caramel now,
and I suppose Cadbury
had to get on the trend.
I really don't think I taste
much, if any, difference at all
between that and the regular caramel.
Since I have nothing else
to do for this episode,
I'm going to go ahead and try some
of this UK Cadbury I'm
hearing so much about,
starting with the OG
Cadbury Dairy Milk bar.
Mm, yeah. This is a much smoother, nicer,
richer, creamier chocolate.
I do really love this. It's fantastic.
You brag a lot about your chocolate, UK,
but another thing you
should be bragging about
is your caramel. It's also really good
and way better than what
we have here in America.
So, the Caramellos from earlier,
just not the biggest fan of those anymore.
I liked them when I was a kid,
but caramel in America is just too bleh.
But yours, oh, yeah.
I mean, pulls apart nicer.
Now, this one got cheers of approval
from the crew when I mentioned it.
This is the Cadbury Dairy Milk Daim bar.
Now, for those who don't
know, Diam is a chocolate bar
in its own right, and it's,
like, a layer of chocolate
on the outside with quite a hard layer
of toffee caramel on the inside.
Now, Daim bars themselves I
think have maybe fallen out
of favor a little bit in the
UK. They were very popular
with my granddad's generation,
and I think people don't really buy them
on their own anymore.
However, I do say they are delicious.
You can also still buy
them in places like Ikea.
I think they're popular kind
of on continental Europe.
Next up, we have another new bar.
It's the Cadbury white confetti bar.
I've never seen this before,
before I went to do the
shopping for this episode,
but it's white chocolate, and
it contains oat biscuit pieces
as well as milk chocolate beans.
But you do see quite a few
of these biscuity pieces.
Oop.
Yeah. I get a lot of the biscuit.
Not much of the chocolate pieces.
You may also be able to
find a mint Dairy Milk,
a Crunchie pieces Dairy Milk,
and also Dairy Milk with 30% less sugar,
but I wasn't able to
track them down today.
Then we have a couple of Dairy Milk bars
with either slightly different
compositions or flavors.
Firstly, we have Dairy
Milk marvelous creations.
This one has jelly popping candy inside.
Don't quote me on this,
but I feel like back
in the early 2000s in the
UK, we had a Wonka series
of chocolate bars, which
were inspired by Willy Wonka.
Now, I think that was
actually a Nestlé product,
but they had interesting flavors.
They did things like putting jelly beans
and popping candy into
their chocolate bars.
They've disappeared. Don't
know what happened to them,
but I feel like this is Cadbury's attempt
to get in on that, bring
that back a little bit.
Probably pretty well timed
because, you know, the
"Wonka" movie's out soon.
It's going to really date this
video, but we love Chalamet.
These are pretty good.
I do think it's an interesting
textural experience
when you eat one of these,
because it's the kind of
chewiness of the jelly bean
mixed in with the melty milk chocolate.
Not my favorite, but, hey,
if you want something
a little bit different,
then this is for you.
Then we're on to the big taste bars.
This is the Dairy Milk
big taste Oreo crunch.
I did mention there was
a theme of Dairy Milk
and Oreo crossover products,
and this is the next one in that line.
So, with the big taste bars,
they are thicker than a
standard chocolate bar would be,
and because of that, they
have layers going on.
Basically double the height.
So, here is the standard Dairy Milk Oreo,
and here is the big taste Oreo.
As you can see, you get much more
distinct layers on this one.
I'm going to be honest,
I think I just prefer the standard one.
One iconic Cadbury product is the Freddo.
A Freddo is a small, individually
wrapped chocolate bar
that's in the shape of a frog.
You can get two versions of this.
You can either get a standard one,
which is just milk chocolate,
or you can get a caramel Freddo.
Much like a Dairy Milk caramel bar,
it's a shell of milk chocolate
with that kind of liquidy
caramel on the inside.
I love Freddos. I feel
like a lot of Brits have
a nostalgic attachment to them.
I can't tell if they've
shrunk over the years
or if I've just got
bigger, or possibly both,
but I do feel like back in the day,
when you're a little kid,
these are a nice little snack-sized treat,
whereas nowadays this is a mouthful.
This is kind of tiny.
They're also worth pointing
out because in the UK,
they've become an unlikely
economic yardstick.
When I was a kid, they cost just 10 pence,
but the price has risen drastically
over the past few years.
At one point in 2017, the
price rose as high as 30 p
for one of these, whereas I
think it's now dropped back down
to 25 after probably a
lot of public outcry.
Because of the fluctuating price,
they've kind of become
a measure of inflation
and cost of living here in the UK.
People's paychecks do not buy them
as many Freddos as they used
to, and that is a sad thing.
That's funny, Harry. In the US,
Cadbury tried what I think
are similar shenanigans
by decreasing the size of the products.
Back in 2007, US comedian and actor
B.J. Novak outed Cadbury
on the Conan O'Brien show
for suddenly making Cadbury eggs smaller.
In the UK, we also have a couple
of plant-based-chocolate options.
They're made with almonds instead of dairy
in order to try and replicate
a milk chocolate feel,
and they come in two forms,
either as a classic bar
or as a salted caramel.
It's actually not that bad.
They've done really well, I think,
to replicate the texture
of milk chocolate,
because as it kind of
claims on the packaging,
"smooth" I think is the word.
It really is quite a smooth experience.
It does kind of melt in your mouth,
almost like a milk chocolate bar would.
I think what's letting
it down really for me is
still the taste of it
rather than the texture.
It tastes almost more like
a sort of cooking chocolate,
or like, you know when
you get those really cheap
chocolate chips and it feels like
there isn't enough cocoa
or creaminess to them?
We have these four exclusive
bars here in the US.
We got rock the road,
which is milk chocolate
with roasted almonds,
marshmallows, and fudge.
No, I don't like that.
We have a royal dark dark chocolate.
I'm sure you have several dark
chocolates. Ours is royal.
Not a big dark chocolate guy.
Not as bitter as I expect
from dark chocolate,
so not bad, but, eh, I don't know.
Again, just OK.
Roasted almond.
Hm, generous with the almonds, right?
It's a pretty good almond haul.
Last of our exclusive flavors
are Black Forest cake,
which is dark chocolate
with cherry-flavored fudge
and cookie pieces.
Oh, man, OK. So, apparently, in the UK,
you would call this a Black
Forest gâteau, which is funny
because you didn't use the
French words for black or forest.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
And the Black Forest is in Germany.
You guys don't know what's going on.
Gonna be honest with you,
chocolate and cherry,
not my favorite combo.
Oh, God. Ugh! This is terrible.
This is the worst one.
Oh, I hate this. Blegh.
Next up, we're on to buttons.
Now, Cadbury buttons are just
pieces of Dairy Milk chocolate
shaped into little
buttons or little disks.
Buttons come in a range
of sizes and flavors.
So, the original ones are actually tiny.
I feel like they've kind
of fallen out of favor,
or maybe they're just only given to kids,
but this is what, honestly,
the classic button looks like,
and it's these really tiny
little chocolate disks.
It's literally just plain
Dairy Milk chocolate.
The ones that I would more
commonly go for in my adult life
are the ones which are served
in these big sharing bags,
and they're more like this size.
I'd say that's, like,
that's more than double
the size, I would say.
And then if that button size
is still not big enough for you,
then we have mega buttons.
So we have classic, giant, and mega.
Just one more note on
the size of the buttons.
We've observed that the classic ones,
on the packet, are just called buttons,
but what I think used to
be called the giant ones
are also now just called
buttons, which you can see
because they're still called giant buttons
in the orange-flavored version.
You can also get buttons
in a range of flavors.
So, here we have some
mint chocolate buttons,
some orange chocolate buttons.
These ones are called caramel nibbles,
but I always thought they
were just caramel buttons
because, again, they're
kind of the disk shape
but with a little pocket
of caramel in the middle.
And you can also get Darkmilk buttons.
Now, these are a Cadbury
invention which is somewhere
between dark chocolate and milk chocolate.
As well as Caramilk buttons.
And if you want just
actual dark chocolate,
Cadbury's calls that Bournville,
and they have giant Bournville
dark chocolate buttons.
Another Cadbury product in
the UK are Cadbury fingers.
Now, these are a classic.
I feel like these are a staple
in a lot of British households.
Basically what you get is a layer
of biscuit along the bottom,
which is then kind of
just completely dunked
in Cadbury milk chocolate.
Can't figure out exactly
what the biscuit is.
I think it's kind of like shortbread.
You can also get Cadbury
fingers in a range
of sizes and flavors.
For example, you can get these
little bite-sized pouches.
We have the salted caramel fingers here.
Then you can also find
white chocolate fingers,
orange chocolate fingers, mint
chocolate fingers, and dark.
One thing which has
just launched in the UK
at the time of filming
is Cadbury delights.
These are a new range of products
which I believe are nougat
covered in chocolate.
These come in the flavors
of hazelnut and caramel,
orange and caramel, and salted caramel.
Another exclusive we have in the US are
the mini chocolate eggs, harvest eggs,
but it's around the holidays right now,
so we have instead mini snow balls.
I feel like they're the same.
These are the same. Come on.
Yeah, just milk chocolate
with a crisp, sugary shell,
as they say on here.
Good for snacking, I think.
I think these taste the best
out of everything here, to be honest.
Also have the Creme Eggs.
Couldn't find them anywhere!
I thought they used to be
everywhere. Now they're gone.
I don't know what happened to them,
but you know what they look like.
We have them.
Tragically, we're
filming this in November,
so we can't get our hands on
our seasonal egg exclusives.
Cadbury's is obviously
known for Creme Eggs
but also has mini eggs, which
I believe are eggcellent.
In the UK, we can obviously
get the classic Creme Egg,
but we can also get white
Creme Eggs and caramel eggs.
We can also get classic mini eggs
as well as a mini eggs bar.
However, I will point out that
because it's in the run-up
to Christmas, we are able
to get Heroes right now,
which is a Cadbury selection box
typically eaten around the holidays.
As part of a Heroes box,
you can get a little bite-sized
twisted Creme Egg bar.
I get that you want to create
that artificial demand,
but I feel like people are
going to eat Creme Eggs
year-round regardless of
availability, so I feel like
you should just give the
people what they want.
Have Creme Eggs year-round.
Same for mini eggs, please.
I need those much more than Creme Eggs.
Now we're on to some
exclusive chocolate bars
which you'll find in
the UK but not the US.
Going to go through them
in a roughly alphabetical order here,
starting with the Boost bar.
Now, I believe when these
were first introduced,
they were almost
advertised as an energy bar
in chocolate form
because I think they had,
like, mortifying levels of
sugar and glucose in them,
whereas now I think they've
actually dialed back on that,
and it's kind of just like a chocolate bar
with some biscuit and
caramel in the middle.
Got that Boost bar. Gimme the boost.
Mm, everyone in the UK's watching me like,
"This dummy's never had this before?"
No, I haven't. Or if I had
it, I don't remember it.
Now, you might remember from the buttons,
but when you see dark
chocolate and Cadbury's,
it's going to be marketed as Bournville.
Comes in this iconic
red packaging as well,
compared to the usual purple
colors used by Cadbury's.
Fun fact, Bournville
is actually a real town
which you can visit in the UK.
It was created basically by Cadbury
to house all of their workers,
and apparently it's quite
a nice place to live.
I'm not sure why they've
ended up using that name
for their dark chocolate
range, but here it is.
You can get it in a few different flavors.
Here, for example, I have
the old Jamaica flavor,
which is a dark chocolate
with rum and raisin.
We also have the
Bournville mint crisp bar.
You can also just get it
in a standard plain dark chocolate one
as well as an orange bar as well.
Next up, we have Caramilk.
So, as the name suggests,
this is kind of like a
caramelly milk chocolate hybrid,
which Cadbury's has released
over the past couple of years.
What you end up with is this
slightly weird yellowy golden color.
Kind of weird because it's got the texture
of a milk chocolate,
but the flavor is much
closer to a buttery fudge.
You can also get Caramilk in the form
of a Caramilk crispy bar,
which is Caramilk chocolate
with little crisped rice pieces.
Speaking of crunch, next
up we have a Crunchie Bar.
These are pretty iconic.
Basically what you get is a honeycomb
which is then dipped in milk chocolate
to produce a Crunchie Bar.
When I say honeycomb,
obviously there's no
actual beehive in here.
What you do is you mix melted sugar
and, I believe, baking
soda, and it kind of aerates
and puffs up and then
solidifies to leave you
with what we know as, I guess,
confectioner's honeycomb.
Again, slightly controversial take.
I don't like Crunchie.
I don't like the texture
of the honeycomb on my teeth.
It feels really weird,
and I don't enjoy it,
but I know it's a very popular bar,
so you do you. That's fine.
Next up is another
possible favorite of mine.
It's a Curly Wurly.
Now, I love these because it sounds like
an American has kind
of improvised the name
for a British chocolate bar.
They're a little bit hard to describe.
It's a combination of
chocolate and toffee,
but it's in this very
distinctive, unique shape.
I'm not really sure what the
logic is behind the shape, but.
I'm not sure if the same
distinction exists in America,
but here in the UK, if we say
something has toffee in it,
that implies that it's
going to be very chewy.
Kind of similar to caramel
in terms of the taste
but a lot more chewy.
Curly Wurly. Let's go.
I have had these before,
and I do really like them.
Oh, yeah.
Mm. Mm! Yeah.
Next up, we have some
more Darkmilk products.
Again, this sits somewhere between dark
and milk chocolate on the
kind of cocoa-content scale.
This one is flavored with some
little salted caramel pieces.
More of the salted caramel.
Again, with the salted caramel.
We get it. It's fine.
You might also be able
to find the same bar
but flavored with some
hazelnut praline pieces.
Next up is another classic.
It's a Double Decker bar.
Our buses aren't the only things
that are double decker here in the UK.
We also have these chocolate bars.
There's quite a lot going
on in a Double Decker bar.
I do love them. I'm going to be honest.
But so what you get is, obviously,
the Dairy Milk chocolate
coating on the outside,
but then on the inside,
you see you have this big layer of nougat,
and on the other side you have
lots of these little crispy,
I think kind of crispy rice pieces.
Moving on from that, we have a Flake.
So, I don't really understand
how Flakes are made,
but they are quite impressive.
Basically, I think what
they do is they get
a kind of waterfall of chocolate,
and the way that it kind of
hits the refrigerated surface,
it kind of folds in on itself,
and you get this really
layered, flaky texture.
Flakes are pretty iconic.
The main use of Flakes, arguably,
in the UK is in ice-cream cones.
What you will usually get
is a whipped ice-cream cone,
Mr. Whippy, and then
they just stick a Flake
in there as well.
Flakes have also
apparently been the center
of some controversy this year
because, due to the
weird structure of them,
they don't melt.
Now, unlike most of the chocolate
that I've been trying today,
I've kind of come away
with little bits of melted
chocolate on my hand,
but basically due to how thin the layers
of the chocolate are, when it melts,
the solids and the fats
don't really separate
like they should do, and
therefore it just can't melt.
You can put one of these in a bain-marie,
and it will just not melt.
You can microwave one,
and it will just burn
before it starts to melt.
The fun facts don't stop there.
We're rolling straight in
to the Fry's Chocolate Cream, whoo!
Now, obviously, these do
not have the same packaging
or branding as the rest of them,
but they are indeed
manufactured by Cadbury's.
So, these are bars of dark chocolate
with a fondant cream center.
They're worthy of special
mention because these are some
of the first-ever
mass-produced chocolate bars.
They took their name from the Fry family,
who were a Quaker family
from Bristol in the UK.
Now, the Frys were actually
the first people to figure out
how to make mass-produced chocolate bars.
We're going all the way back
to the 1840s here in the UK,
but around that time, people
only really drank chocolate.
It was quite rare to
get a piece of chocolate
or a chocolate bar.
The Frys were the first
ones who figured out how
to press cacao beans to separate
the fats from the solids.
Now, they were doing
this just to try and make
a drinking powder that was
kind of easier to dissolve
but inadvertently figured
out how to separate
all the materials and
then reincorporate them
in order to make a
shelf-stable chocolate bar.
It's a taste of history right there.
OK, so the packaging, it's
a Fry's Chocolate Cream.
The packaging of this one is suspicious.
It's, like, lowest effort of packaging.
It's just this white text, no drop shadow,
little bit of the bar right there.
No, I do not like this.
Now, while they're not
technically products themselves,
rather an amalgamation of products,
we have some selection
boxes here in the UK,
which are worth pointing out.
Now, these will start to pop up in stores
around Christmastime, which
is when they're usually eaten.
Now, these are what's
known as a selection box.
So basically you have
small individual versions
of quite a few of their
different chocolate bars,
which you can then share with the family.
So the box of Heroes will
contain Eclairs, Fudge, Wispa,
Dairy Milk, Crunchie bits,
Twirl, Dairy Milk caramel,
Double Decker, and the Creme Egg twisted.
We also have Roses.
And these aren't really
based on existing brands.
These are more just like
classic chocolate box
selections, I suppose.
So we have things like the orange cream,
the strawberry dream.
We do actually have some mini
Dairy Milk bars in here now
as well as a few other ones.
I feel like in my power rankings
of all the chocolate selection boxes,
I don't know if the
Cadbury ones win for me.
I do think Celebrations might win for me,
which is like the Mars brand
equivalent of these ones.
I'm thinking it's probably
Celebrations, Heroes, Roses.
And Quality Street, of
course. The classics.
Man. British Christmas,
what a wonderful time.
While we're talking about selection boxes,
I should also mention the milk tray.
Now, these are a classic.
These have been going back
years and years and years.
I feel like it's less of a thing now,
but these were very, very
popular to gift to people,
whether someone's had you
around for a dinner party
or it's a birthday.
Give someone a milk tray
back in the '60s or '70s,
it was just the done thing to do.
Back to the chocolate
bars, this is a Picnic bar.
I actually don't know if I've
ever had a Picnic bar before,
mostly because they contain raisins.
It's a milk chocolate
bar, but then inside,
it's kind of just like
a mixture of everything.
You get raisins. You get peanuts.
There's crispy cereal in there.
I think there's caramel as well.
Next up is the Cadbury Timeout wafer.
I'd say this is more of a
biscuit bar than a chocolate bar,
but you have layers of
biscuit and chocolate,
which are then obviously coated
in more Cadbury Dairy Milk chocolate.
Then we're on to a Twirl.
These are kind of similar to the Flake
in terms of the texture.
It's kind of like Flake texture inside,
but the actual individual bars
are coated with chocolate.
Twirl. What is a Twirl?
No, I don't like this. It's just OK.
I don't like the airy texture of it.
Man, these are a classic.
I feel like these have
almost gone extinct.
This is a Chomp bar.
It's kind of the same as a Curly Wurly
in that it's basically a
layer of toffee covered
in milk chocolate, but instead
of that weird patterning
with the gaps, this is just a solid bar.
I feel like these have
always been served in this
kind of small-size bar as more of a snack,
maybe aimed towards
kids, but I love a Chomp.
These are brilliant.
Shh, it's a Wispa bar.
I don't fully understand Wispa bars.
I like them, don't get me
wrong, but it just kind of feels
like you're getting less
chocolate for your money
than you are with some other bars.
Because basically they've
taken a milk chocolate bar,
but they've figured out how to aerate it
and kind of put little air bubbles in.
What they've really gone for is a texture
where when you bite into it,
it almost melts on your tongue.
We also have a Wispa gold bar.
Wispa gold is the same aerated texture,
but it has a layer of caramel
running along the top.
Next up, we have a Starbar.
Now, the way I see it,
this is just like a better Picnic bar.
So, a Starbar is basically
just milk chocolate
on the outside, caramel, and peanuts.
Next up we have the Fudge bar.
It's a layer of fudge
with some Cadbury
chocolate on the outside.
They're still in the
Heroes box, which I like,
but I feel like not that many
people like them anymore.
And then finally, for
the time being, Eclairs.
So, the Cadbury Eclair is very different
to the pastry eclair.
It's basically a ball of toffee
with chocolate on the inside.
I always liked these.
There's always something really satisfying
about the texture of toffee to me.
I had braces as a little kid,
and I really missed
toffee when I had braces,
so I'll never take
toffee for granted again.
Now, Cadbury in the US is a brand
that's manufactured by Hershey,
so there's no sub-brands under
Cadbury in the United States.
However, Hershey does own about 29 brands.
Here are a few that are
exclusive to the US.
In no particular order,
first one, Milk Duds.
If you've been to movie theater in the US,
[rattling]
recognize that sound?
Some jerk sitting two rows behind.
He doesn't understand he's making noise.
He got Milk Duds!
Milk Duds are like Curly
Wurlys in button form.
Eh, that's actually pretty
good, what I just did there.
It is just caramel covered in chocolate,
but it is in button form
and not, like, drizzle form.
These, guaranteed stuck to your teeth.
Guaranteed you're digging
these out of your teeth.
A Heath bar is, hang on,
"English toffee enrobed
in a rich, chocolaty coating."
They wrote that like they thought
an American would read that and be like,
"This is from England."
Mounds is chocolate and coconut.
There it is. It's a mound.
Looks a little bit like a rabbit turd.
It's just a chunk
of coconut covered in dark chocolate.
Now, if you're looking at
this and you're being like,
"It needs something
else, Joe," yes, it does.
How about almonds? Almond Joy.
The exact same thing as a Mounds
but if said rabbit ate
a bunch of almonds whole.
Coconut and chocolate.
Coconut, almonds, and chocolate.
Some of the bars are also
available in the form
of these bite-sized
pieces. These come in bags.
Notably, we have some Crunchie
rocks, we have bitsa Wispa,
we have Curly Wurly squirlies,
and the least fun name, Twirl bites.
These are more designed to be shared
than obviously a classic
chocolate bar would be.
I think the idea is maybe
you get a bag of these,
take it into the cinema or something,
watch your film, got a little snack.
Next up we have Brunch bars.
These are Cadbury's take on cereal bars.
We've got these Brunch bars
in three different flavors.
We have a raisin one,
a milk choc chip one,
and a dark choc chip one.
I do actually quite like these.
These were a occasional
packed-lunch inclusion
when I was growing up.
Basically, it's a cereal
bar made mostly with oats,
but then you get this base
layer of chocolate as well.
In this case, some choc chips as well.
Yeah, they've got a nice chewy texture.
And then, finally, it's
time for what we'll call
the best of the rest.
These are the kind of
miscellaneous Cadbury products
which don't really fit into
any of the other categories
but are still worth talking about.
Firstly, we have animal biscuits.
These were, again, a
classic packed-lunch staple
when I was younger.
You get a little biscuit,
which on one side
is kind of decorated in
the shape of an animal
and on the other side is just dipped
in Dairy Milk chocolate.
Gotta give a shout-out to mini rolls.
These are another maybe
grandma-biscuit-tin staple.
These are actually like a cake basically
rather than a biscuit or a chocolate bar.
It's a roll of chocolate sponge
cake, which is then, I say,
rolled up with a little
layer of cream in the middle,
and then the whole thing is dipped
in milk chocolate as well.
And then while we're
talking about Cadbury cakes,
we also have Cadbury cake bars.
Kind of similar to mini rolls
in that you have the chocolate sponge,
it's all coated in chocolate as well,
but you have that caramel
layer along the top.
Then we're on to to a
couple of fridge desserts.
These are Cadbury's milk
chocolate sticky puds.
So, these are great. I've had these
or an iteration of these
many times in the past.
Basically, they come in
these little plastic pots,
which are microwavable,
and the typical way to eat these is
that you maybe pierce the film on this,
put the whole thing in the
microwave for 30 seconds,
a minute or so, take it
out, flip it onto a plate,
and it comes out.
Cooking it kind of steams the
sponge when it's in there.
And then there's a chocolate sauce,
as you can see on the packaging,
which is kind of collected at this end,
and then when you flip it,
ends up kind of drizzling
down the side of the puds,
and it's very nice, like a fun
kind of fancy-feeling dessert
that you can just have
at home in 30 seconds.
Pud, of course, is short for pudding,
which is what we call dessert.
And then we also have these
Dairy Milk pots of joy.
These are apparently a
"smooth and creamy dessert
made with melted Cadbury milk chocolate."
I've not had one of these before.
I think they're like a yogurt, basically,
like a chocolate yogurt pot.
I'm not sure what to make of this next one
because it feels a little bit
like America is infiltrating
our Cadbury products, but
this is Cadbury Dairy Milk
fruitier and nuttier orange trail mix.
These, I believe, are new.
I don't think Cadbury's
been doing trail mix
for a very long time.
I also don't think trail
mix is very popular
in the UK in general.
It's just not that common.
So, in a bag of this, apparently
you get sweetened cocoa,
Dairy Milk orange buttons,
raisins and sultanas,
roasted almonds, and hazelnuts.
Speaking of things meant to sound English,
it's a York Peppermint Pattie,
all the way from the city of York.
Is this, it is just, instead of coconut,
it is peppermint.
Mr. Goodbar, chocolate and peanuts.
This bar, the packaging,
you can tell this is an old-school bar.
This bar is so old that its
main selling point was like,
"We assure you there's
peanuts in this bar.
We're not lying to you, all right?
Yes. You won't believe how
packed with peanuts this bar is."
Is this true
to the Goodbar guarantee on the back?
Possibly more.
Wow, they overdelivered
on the promise of peanuts.
5th Avenue bar. I don't know what this is.
Ugh.
Whatchamacallit, let's go.
Chocolate, peanut-flavor
crisps, and caramel.
Definitely very peanut
buttery. Eh, it's OK.
We have two options when it comes
to beverages for Cadbury's in the UK.
Here we have original
Cadbury hot chocolate,
and then we also have
Highlights milk choc drink.
I'm not massively sure
what the difference is,
but I think just judging
from kind of a look
on the packaging,
Highlights might be designed
as kind of a diet option,
just because it's described
as an "instant low-calorie milk
chocolate flavor hot drink."
Staying in the cupboard
section of the Cadbury's aisle,
now we're on to the chocolate spread.
This is effectively
kind of like a Nutella,
but it doesn't have hazelnuts in it,
so this is just like a
pure chocolate spread.
Now we're moving on to the bakery section
of your supermarket.
I got most of these
from an Asda in London,
so I do think the availability
will vary slightly depending
on where you are and which
supermarket you're visiting,
but I will say that most
supermarkets will have
a bakery section, and you'll probably see
some Cadbury branding in there somewhere.
Here's what I was able to find.
We have three of these bagged goods
from the bakery-at-Asda range.
Firstly, we have some oatie bakes,
which are oat flapjacks
containing milk chocolate.
Next up we have some Cadbury
Dairy Milk shortie squares.
Shortie's like a melody in my square.
Shortie squares are a
shortcake packed with, again,
some Dairy Milk chocolate chunks.
Then we have some Cadbury
Dairy Milk chocolate cookies.
We're staying in the bakery aisle,
and now we're on to Dairy
Milk caramel doughnuts.
Now, I'm kind of intrigued
by these. I love doughnuts.
It's just very dry.
And then we have a few more baked goods,
namely Dairy Milk caramel mini cookies,
Dairy Milk cornflake cluster bites,
and some Dairy Milk brownie bites.
Then we're going to round things off
with a few seasonal items.
As I mentioned,
unfortunately we weren't able
to get the Easter exclusives,
which are pretty iconic,
namely the Creme Egg and the mini egg,
but because we're kind of in
the Christmas/Halloween period,
I was able to get some of
those exclusives instead.
We'll start with the Halloween ones,
which has just come and
gone here in the UK,
but we were able to find
some mini bonfire logs,
which are fun.
I think these are like a mini roll,
but instead of the
classic chocolate sponge,
they've used a honeycomb sponge instead.
And then another spooky
seasonal exclusive are
the pumpkin patch cakes.
These are chocolate cakes
with an orange-colored cream filling.
Then we have some Cadbury Christmas puds.
These are Dairy Milk chocolate balls
with a hazelnut truffle center,
hazelnut pieces, and rice crisps.
Again, it's that combination
of chocolate and nuts.
Just can't go wrong for me.
And of course, we can't talk
about seasonal exclusives
without talking about Advent calendars.
We love our Advent calendars over here.
Cadbury's, of course, has to get involved,
and they have a very simple
but very effective
chocolate Advent calendar.
This 110-gram bar of
Cadbury Dairy Milk costs
£1.35 at Tesco.
Breaking that down,
you're paying 1.22 pence
per gram of chocolate.
In the US, our bar is 99 grams,
and it costs $2.79 cents,
which is 2.8 cents per gram.
So per gram, it's a
91% increase in the US.
Ooh! Getting gouged, baby!
Here's everything in a bar
of Dairy Milk chocolate
in the UK: milk, sugar,
cocoa butter, cocoa mass,
vegetable fats (palm and shea),
emulsifiers (E442 (ammonium phosphatides),
E476 (polyglycerol polyricinoleate)),
and flavorings.
Here's everything in a US
Dairy Milk chocolate bar.
We got sugar, milk,
chocolate, cocoa butter,
lactose, lecithin, PGPR,
natural flavor, artificial flavor.
UK chocolate is often
considered as superior by some,
including myself, to US chocolate,
and there are a few reasons for that.
Firstly, the UK rules for
its chocolate production
from the Cocoa and Chocolate
Products Regulations of 2003
set minimums for milk
chocolate at 25% total fat
(cocoa butter and milk fat), 5% milk fat,
20% dry cocoa solids, 2.5%
dry nonfat cocoa solids,
and 20% dry milk solids.
In the US, our FDA rules
for our milk chocolate differ quite a bit.
10% chocolate liquor; 12% milk solids,
which can be either
powder or condensed milk;
at least 3.39% fat;
and no more than 55% sugar.
Secondly, those of us on
this side of the Atlantic
can feel that American
chocolate has a sour,
almost vomity taste to it.
That's all very well and good
for American-branded chocolate bars,
but why doesn't US Cadbury taste
like it does over here in the UK?
It starts with The Hershey Company.
Back in the early 1900s,
the company introduced
cost-cutting measures,
including a process to make its milk
last longer in production.
For this, they used a secret method
called liposis? Liplosis?
Yuelei: Lipolysis.
Lipolysis!
The details of Hershey's
chocolate-making process
are a company secret,
but part of the process
involves butyric acid.
Butyric acid extends
the shelf life of milk,
but it does partially sour it.
It's also found in Parmesan cheese,
fermented foods like sauerkraut,
and, of course, vomit.
Hershey's became a powerful
chocolate company in the US,
so much so they successfully
forced a ban on an import
of Cadbury's chocolate into the US.
In 1988, Hershey's acquired
the US Cadbury license
and has been producing it in the US
with their own Americanized formula,
putting them in similar-looking
Cadbury packages ever since.
Remember the price section from earlier?
Well, it turns out that not
only are Americans paying
basically double the price
for their chocolate as we are,
but they're also getting
a worse-quality product.
That's kind of sad.
100 grams of Dairy Milk chocolate
in the UK contains the following:
534 calories, 30 grams of fat,
of which 18 grams are
saturated, 57 grams of carbs,
of which 56 grams of sugars,
and 56 milligrams of sodium.
Let's compare that to a
99-gram bar over here,
seeing as there's only 1 gram difference.
500 calories,
57.5 grams of carbs,
27.5 grams of total fat,
17.5 grams of saturated fat,
55 grams of total sugars,
7.5 grams of protein,
and 100 milligrams of sodium.
If we compare the 100-gram stats in the UK
to the 99-gram stats in the US,
we'll find that the UK actually has
slightly more calories and fat,
although it has less carbs
and much less sodium.
What?
I've been watching the current
season of "Love Island" UK.
So I'm like, "Are you
joking? Are you joking?
You're having a laugh.
Are you having a laugh?"
This is journalism, baby.
This is why we went to journalism school.
I didn't go to journalism
school, so I have an excuse.